[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
they've reached the midway point at the
v-day candidates in madrid spain with
opportunities for points dwindling by
the round players raced to gain ground
on the surging leaders former challenger
ian oppongiacci continued his impressive
tournament performance defeating richard
rapport with his fourth win but fabiano
caruana refuses to give up besting timor
rajabov to stay within half a point of
the lead the colors have been swapped
and the pairings reset round eight of
world-class chess coming up next
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022
candidates tournament from madrid spain
we're in studio in saint louis ready to
bring you all the action of today's
around hello and welcome i am grand
master yesterday's here on
dorsa hi i can't believe it it's so nice
to have you thank you for coming
everybody yeah and filling in uh when
needed doris says taking over for one
christian and it's so nice of you to
come and replenish the ranch thank you
very much absolutely well we're getting
ready for uh round eight and it has
turned into a two horse race essentially
the tournament started with wins by fabi
and by nepo and it finished the first
half with just those two guys winning as
well
and the standings we've got two runaway
leaders dorsa yanatop yeah jan is just
having a wonderful tournament and it's
quite scary for fabi i have to say
exactly he keeps winning too right
but still a half a point behind one
player ikaru with 50
three players at -1 yan richie and ding
and unfortunately timor and ali reza at
the bottom of the standings and
for nepo our tournament leader
we think his magic number could be nine
nine and a half points
exactly there there's only seven rounds
left and he's already five and a half so
it's amazing it's it's an absolutely a
fantastic result and our tournament
format uh dorsa
well it is a eight player double round
robin this is a very special time
control it's 120 minutes for the first
40 moves then players get an extra 60
minutes for the next 20 moves and
finally 15 minutes and 30 second
increment for the rest of the game no
draws before black's 40th move and 500
000 euros in prize money and our
schedule our remaining schedule yes
we're halfway through so we are on round
eight today is sunday it's a good day
it's a good day monday to uh monday
tomorrow will be round nine and then
we're gonna go into our rest day and
that's the pace we've been keeping three
games
rest day three games rest day and we of
course are very very fortunate to have
in studio our friend grandmaster
alejandro ramirez
good morning alejandro nice to see you
good morning yasser good morning doris a
pleasure to be calling all of the action
with you guys but you've said it this
tournament after only seven rounds has
already turned into a two horse race and
nobody is really talking about the rest
of the field let's take a look at how
they got to their positions at the top
of the leaderboards let's take a look as
you said fabiano carona started with a
win an impressive win against hikaru
nakamura and has scored two in a row he
won a great game yesterday ground down
timor rajabov in a very very long game
full of calculation and you would think
five points out of seven are you kidding
me that's enough for first place at the
very least shared but
uh the certain yadni pomnyachi has
proven that he learned a lot from the
world championship match he came in he
came furious and take a look at that a
plus four scintillating score
against the rest of the field he is in
full position with five and a half but
let's remember guys that they're playing
to challenge magnus carlsen and that man
has said you know what i already beat
this guys this is a very taxing event
it's too many months of preparation i
don't have anything to prove i am
rethinking about defending my title and
it happened once before in the history
of chess bobby fischer refused to play a
natalie karpov for many reasons in the
90s in their supposed 1975 match of
course for chess historians for chess
fans this was one of the greatest
matches never to happen in our sport and
everybody is now waiting with baited
breath what will magnus decide to do
based on how this candidates finish well
we're gonna have to find out but i know
that favi doesn't want to wait for that
he wants to secure his number one spot
and today it's gonna be a big day for
him well thank you alejandro and uh
dorsa let's take a look at the pairings
do the honors and lay the table for us
please well
i think for me the most impressive one
to keep uh keep a lookout for is naka
versus caruana today huge huge fight for
the second place but nepo our tournament
leader is playing the number one seed
ding if dink can win
it could bring him back richie duda
at minus one trying
to get their first victories in perugia
and unfortunately timor both fighting to
get out of the cellar and of course they
are fighting for half a million dollars
in prizes 48 000 euros to the winner
second place is 36 third place 24 each
player will get an additional 7 000
euros for every point played every 0.1
but the big prize is to become
challenger winning it all to be first
the winner gets to play this man
in a site to be determined in 2023
magnus carlsen our world champion is
waiting in the wings yeah it's going to
be a very exciting next few months
figuring out if magnus will play her or
not
yes exactly and of course
if
magnus declines the challenge
then it's the first two
in this candidates who would play the
candidates match and as we were coming
on air alien alejandro and i were
discussing
why hikaru's game today
could be so crucial uh jump right in on
the conversation alejandro
what is hikaru playing for
well this is big pairings because
remember hikaru is white against fabi
and hikaru was dealt a big blow by
fabiana carano beating him in the first
round and it's difficult to imagine that
hikaru will win this tournament nepo is
so far ahead of him but if he wins today
he would be half a point away from
fabiano caron and as you mentioned
yasser the important thing it's those
two top the top two that play against
each other for the world championship
match in case that magnus declines to
defend his title so if you want the
stars to align you got to give yourself
some hope and in that case it's hikaru
winning today against favi to try to
knock him off that second position okay
and just on that note because how do
these two guys match up with each other
hikaru
and um fabi have been winning a lot of
u.s championship titles
between them doris
how do you think uh
what here's their lifetime score well
we have six wins eight losses oh my god
33 draws look at that result and
bobby's got a little edge you have to
say two extra wins for fobby but those
33 draws goes to show that they really
know each other and they've been
fighting for u.s championship titles for
quite some time
so this is a very very big match and
drill down a little bit also alejandro
for me
when
hikaru is white what's his go-to opening
to try to win as white is he doing e4 or
is he going d4 what's he trying hikar
has tried a lot of things against
fabiano corona but mainly he tries to
move e4 and e4 has made his go-to in
this tournament remember his only win
and actually the only win of any player
outside of netball or five year in this
tournament was hikaru's e4 win against
taymor rajaw trying to take down the
berlin now we know that fabi is a great
petrov player but on the other hand
fabi's saying that he wants to make sure
that he gets that first position he
looks at napo and says i i can't let
this guy run away with it will he try to
do something a little riskier with the
black pieces today okay and dorset for
yourself
when you have the white pieces are you
an e4 kind of gal or a kind of a d4 kind
of guy i've been with e4 for
18 years now
ever since i started playing chess it's
been always e4 and was that because of
bobby fischer by the way bobby fischer
would respect you one e4 is best by test
said bobby uh
who influenced you to play e4
exclusively my dad your dad
not bobby fisher okay and they're off uh
e2 e4 you
we we called it uh e4 e5 knight f3 no
petrov no
berlin
and uh fabi uh has
so many defenses in his repertoire one
of the ones he likes also i've seen him
play as this kind of archangel
uh variation with uh bishop c5
um
[Music]
so far
ooh an open
open
uh
d2 d4s
yep so fabian is going more risky today
yeah that's the thing too is it risky or
is it a is the open uh
the
open variation safe solid or is it risky
uh
there's been so many games uh this is
just the players are catching up to what
we could imagine is just the tapia
position here
a number of moves c2 c3
main line most popular but knight
b1 to d2
also a very good choice and players are
just
blitzing out their moves bishop c5
not the bishop e7 but bishop c5
knight d2 it just should be it yeah yeah
and then it's just going to be so
wonderful for me to watch
when you play
against the open
i'm assuming you play the
the um
rui lopez have you ever faced this
dilworth attack with knight takes f2
actually not in a classical game
but in blitz or yeah yeah oh yes
exactly this is uh
i
i know that the
analysis of this theory is incredibly
deep
correspondence games galore and we
recently saw i think in bucharest and
the players
are doing it
uh also uh double-edged
game bishop takes f2 okay normally
they're waiting
to make that capture but uh jump right
in on this one uh alejandro as
this huge fight
a very very important game i mean to say
and they're just blitzing right through
it all
it's the modern twist as you said it
yasser in the previous move
uh you had the option after rook takes
f2 to not take this rook immediately
because you could play the move f6 and
nothing's really going to stop this
bishop from capturing however after the
move bishop takes f2 which has been
essayed
in quite a few times recently we have
some great players here we have uh
paravian a great theoretician with the
black pieces playing it and a certain
alaresa furuja lost last year with the
white pieces against vedic so that is a
cool game that we have on the database
definitely a new twist we're going to
get straight into this position and a
fascinating struggle it does transpose
as it does many times to the original
variation with f6 and you can see a
couple of great games still here uh
vasherla graph played against mamadiara
from michelle graf beat a grand master
andreas hyman so this is still deep into
theory both players are extremely well
prepared hikara has really brought a ton
of theory into this event and i like the
preparation that he's had so far now
bishop e3 is the main line you could
develop a lot of the knights i do think
however that favi is happy with the
situation gets on the board as i said
he's a hungry player and i think that he
is willing to risk in today's match you
can see it already the material
imbalance the craziness in the position
it's not even steven so
i like the approach it's a little risky
but at this point favi needs those
points in the game between yani
pomniacci and dingle run well dorsa
you're familiar with this position
it's a four night it's your favorite
opening an unambitious approach by nepo
i don't think he has anything new this
is considered to be dry dry dry chest at
the top level okay but when you're at
plus four you're trying to secure your
position dry chest is pretty good um
help us out here alejandra wasn't in
bucharest that we saw
a game from this position but instead of
the move bishop e3 i seem to recall it
was bishop g5 what did mvl
who was was it against shaq
that wasn't it mvl beating favi
or was it envy of leading fobby pardon
me it was nvl beating favi yes i'm going
to try to find that position because
it's not on my database for some reason
i do remember the game that you're
mentioning right but i think the move
orders somehow
it changed something's different okay
let me just figure that one out it's
and i'm being told that it was the move
queen d7 that's right queen d7 here
instead of the move queen d6 that favi
played very very recently against maxima
sherlock graph ended up losing an
important game there so perhaps a lot of
lessons learned from that one
absolutely that's what i'm thinking as
well so let's see if we can't break this
down for our audience uh dorsa so when
we so
bishop e3
now presumably these
two top top top grand masters they got
their
preparation
they've got all their homework they've
drilled down
and the move bishop e3 is considered the
best now
one of the things i i'm looking at this
position and i'm white i'm thinking okay
with the minor pieces i would like to
launch some kind of an attack maybe
based on the move knight g5 and
therefore the move h6
uh wouldn't be a surprise for me you
want to kind of stop that but bishop f5
was chosen
and one of the things that i like to do
whenever i'm in the position where i
have the two bishops yes i like to keep
them
[Laughter]
the those two central pawns for black
are just so
good yeah look at all the squares black
has too much space and it just feels too
comfortable you know we were always told
don't give up the two minor pieces who
are broken upon that's not a good trait
but in this case it's just
that's the compensation right there's
those two really wonderful pawns in the
center of the board
controlling uh these minor pieces by the
way this knight on f1 is not earning its
key we need to get that knight into the
game anyway bishop to b3 putting
pressure on the d5 pawn and that's a
very nice diagonal on which to sit and
after
rook to d8 to defend the pawn
queen e1
intriguing
preparing to play the move rook to d1
again
putting nice pressure on this pawn i
like this move very much by fabi knight
a5
not only threatening to capture the
bishop but also maybe even knight to c4
to
number one neutralize the bishop in any
captures you take with the b5 pawn
so knight to a5 idea knight to c4
and also
you want to play maybe c7 c6 just to
buttress those pawns but what how about
participation
oh sorry no it's okay
uh pawn to c5 if if black could would
you want to yes okay i think so as well
absolutely uh no question about it if
you could get in c5 and maybe knight
captures in d4
then you could you know push them baby
just get those pawns right on the board
that would be very nice uh queen f2 okay
there's a square there look at that uh
bishop c5 and
that's awkward i'm kind of sad that
for fabi that he would have to do that
um
i would want to resist playing the move
knight to b7 tonight
no great shakes on b7 that's for sure
but uh this the this threat of bishop c5
is serious we got to do something
he played knight b7 and after knight b7
okay
um
it would be nice if he could get the
pawn to advance
so moves like queen g3
anything that could provoke the pawn to
advance would be good
uh ikaru played rook
e1 which basically says hey
look i want to
hit this pawn and try to get it to
advance and
we are been told
that
c7c5 in all of our database and our
database by the way kind of we we only
have like five million games oh well not
not not not impressive i know i know i
know but in all of our games we've been
told that c7 c5 is a novelty and guess
what hikaro hasn't slowed down for a
single second
bang he immediately
blitzed out the move knight g3 move 21
and these guys are playing not like it's
a classical game but it's a rapid i have
to ask how many more moves do you think
they have
memorized because this is not a very
usual
line so
blessing at 21 moves so far it's it's
i have to say that in my view
when you're coming into these candidates
there's no such thing as not you know
preparing enough and one of these things
one of the things is that the players
really try to push their seconds push
themselves push their teams into
analyzing as deeply as possible so in my
opinion
the players are still probably
well inside their preparation and maybe
many more moves to go alejandro jump in
on that question of dorsa
how deep do you think they've analyzed
from here
it's got to be very deep but yasser
knight g3 is not the top engine
recommendation if you're watching this
show with an engine you might be
thinking didn't favi just blunder
because the engine for a second jumped
all the way up
to one and a half and then was saying
well you know what perhaps i'm wrong
take a look at this variation instead of
the move knight g3 he could have played
the move bishop g5 now that hits the
rook
on the eight if you move the rook to d8
to e8 in order to defend this pawn
notice that the rook and the knight are
now hitting this you can take the pawn
anyway the idea is that rook takes e5 is
met with bishop f4 you get this rook
back you can defend the rook if you
wanted to but after knight takes e5
don't take it again queen g3 is going to
skewer this and that's game over you
just have too much material at the
moment so instead the engine was saying
you know what bishop g5 just give up
that rook go rook d uh go c4 first the
difference being that if you go bishop
d1 at this point and you play rook d e8
and you take and i take there are some
tricks that were not available because
of the move bishop takes d5 in certain
positions for example the move bishop f4
is met with this really cool move rook
e2 queen takes f4 and giving back some
of the material but getting a winning
position have you done that in the other
variation at the very end bishop takes
d5 check picks up the knight on b7 very
subtle stuff clearly the players are not
calculating just yet so what would
happen to play after the move bishop g5
the engines are saying just give up that
rook bishop takes the eight c takes b3
the bishop drops back the pawn gets to
a2 this bishop is threatening to go to
b1 block this rook out of a promotion
it's moved 23 and the pawn is already
promoting down the board the game is
crazy actually the engine still gives
white an advantage but i'm sure that
fabi's analyzed it way further than this
the move knight g3 however it's frozen
fabiano carrana it seems that hikaru
gets the first hit in on this game the
edges are saying black is completely
fine in this position enough
compensation to have the pawns for the
pair of pieces bishop g6 is one
possibility sticking the bishop on d3 is
another following it up with e4 from
a preparation perspective clearly hikaru
is the first one to surprise his
opponent that being said black's
position looks pretty good plants are
obvious just push the pawns down and
as a practical practical matter i'm not
as sure what white's plan is for example
i play the move bishop g6 how where
exactly do you want to pressure me i'm
gonna go c4 at some point i'm gonna go
knight a5 if you ever leave this
diagonal i really don't like this bishop
here and now as soon as i get rid of
that bishop these pawns start marching
fascinating position and interesting
struggle i think both players are
getting pretty much where they want to
be and remember this is their
head-to-head this includes fabiano
caronas win in round number one of this
tournament nakamura is certainly looking
for his revenge from that one six wins
and eight losses for hikaru who at some
point actually had a crushing amount of
victories over fabiano and those tables
turned and turned very strongly
wow
alejandra those variations you just
showed i mean did you see that pawn
getting to a2 come on
you're never going to let that bond get
to a2 if you don't mind could we just
see that bishop g5 again
so instead of the move knight g3 which
by the way as uh fabi's saying not
engine approved bishop to g5 that's a
tempo no way
am i going to allow that pawn to get to
a2 i don't care what the computer says
that white's better after the pawn gets
eight dorsey you would never do that no
no no of course not thank you thank you
happy to hear it rookie ate but
look at this variation rook takes e5 so
we just went upon everybody's happy
rook takes e5 bishop f4 now you can't
defend the rook the rook actually has to
go here
then we're going to take the queen
he's going to take our queen we're going
to take this rook and at the end of the
day the rook's going to capture
this pawn and it's
we still got the two pieces but with the
rook already
on the seventh rank we're not a happy
camper right no no no no we don't like
this
okay so that whole thing and then
alejandro laid a challenge in front of
us he said well look you've played the
move knight g3 well good for you
you're attacking the bishop the bishop
drops back that looks really good well
what about bishop d3 which one would you
prefer
that's a good question the bishop coming
to d3
i'd like to put it on d3
i mean
why not right i mean because
you know we we are playing for c4
we
with the pawn
pardon me with the with the queen and
the pin
you got to be
aware of e4 i guess it's it's going to
be queen d2
and now
you're probably going to anchor oh sorry
please no i'm just very tempted for c4
exactly
you you you want to anchor that bishop
though
i i don't think you want to live with
this bishop on your doorstep uh right
there
and
wow this is this is a very
you know there there are certain
positions that it's hard to make a
judgment about
[Laughter]
this is one of them
let's leave this one alone we're going
to go back to alejandro and rescue us
from from this very awkward position
alejandro we're going to let us players
think about that one but i want to show
you a game
that is no longer a game
this is
and i mentioned it's a very dry
variation of the four knights at the top
level of chess it's very often that you
get these kind of end games and what's
going on opposite-colored bishops the
structure of black is a little bit
weaker but who cares you're not going to
attack it ever the rooks are going to
come off on the e-file at some point and
i expect a draw the moment the players
can get to this isn't even anything new
this isn't even anything new for dingley
ren he already played this game this
exact position he had against maufen all
the way back in 2019
every single game that's ever reached
this position at the grandmaster level
has ended in a draw and i guarantee you
this is no exception
well it's funny you should put it
exactly like that because it was
yesterday
that
richie had his preparation in the petrov
which all the top grand masters knew was
was a draw
and then after the game richie said well
i wasn't trying to win so much as i was
trying to make suicide
and he and he was nepa was trying to
force a draw yesterday and he got a win
uh
could lightning strike twice thrice with
this position with four nights
i don't know if there's anything too
strange
exactly it looks like just a bishop of
opposite color
and again from napa's point of view
may not be exciting for us but he's
securing
each draw is going to bring him closer
and closer to tournament victory so i
can understand why he made this decision
to kind of shut down the play
uh in this in this bishops of opposite
color alejandro uh anything happening in
the other games
let's take a look we have uh this game
between alireza furujia and tema rajava
perhaps not the most important for the
standings but still an interesting
battle between these two players they're
going right down this line of the djoko
piano but black hasn't castled a little
bit of a difference i expect him to
castle soon he hasn't done so yet he
took the time to maneuver his bishop to
a7 took the time to play the move h6 and
you can see the trade of the bishop on
e6 which is what really characterizes
this position opens the file does give
yourself a bit of a weakness on these
two squares and what the game usually
ends up revolving around is how fast and
how effective white can play the move d4
d4 starts challenging the center it also
kills this bishop on a7 this action of
the bishop on the diagonal so it all
really comes down to that alireza trying
to get his first win of the tournament
knight f1 knight g3 is one way you could
just castle immediately and since you've
already expanded on this side you might
be thinking of the move p5 and it is
always possible but it doesn't usually
help white that much why because after
pawn takes pawn takes you have to make
sure that this rook is defended there's
this trick of playing bishop takes f2
king takes f2 rook takes f1 and we get
this kind of position similar to what
fabi has where he has a rook and two
pawns for a piece but in this case white
doesn't have any central domination
doesn't have the pair of bishops and
it's really lacking strategically still
okay for white but definitely not
playing for the advantage
f6 e6 currently uh alireza is the one
that is in a think we're gonna let this
one stew a little bit meanwhile in the
game of
richard rapport against janji stuff dude
we have another four knights but a
completely different style
in this position instead of going for
the move d4 as nepo did and richard
played the move g3 and in this case you
open up a whole new kind of worms the
bishop will go to g2 and usually you
castle short try to attack on the
kingside very quickly with a pawn
expansion we're gonna see if he is able
to get that in this is the current
position on the board you see
there's a reason he hasn't castle just
yet he plays them with h6 first
preventing bishop g5 puts the ball on a5
first allowing this bishop to survive so
knight a4 doesn't catch it taking his
time bishop g2 is a little bit of a
slower variation it's not considered to
be as theoretically sound but well
that's the kind of chess that richard
likes a little bit creative a little bit
crazy and not afraid of risks thank you
for that this g3 reminds me of
uh the georgian grand master joe baba he
likes making these fianchettos with the
bishop on g2
what's your take uh what's gone wrong
for ali raza
in this event what do you think happened
to him a little too high expectations
dorsa well
i would say high expectation i think
that's well the having to move your
whole family to a different country and
then becoming world number two and
having to just kind of sit in that for a
minute right and you know just it's just
too much for him but um i i still
remember him being like yay high
[Laughter]
when he's winning world junior
championships under 10 or something yeah
yeah but he always has had a very very
supportive father yes
yeah it's it's been a very amazing
journey for him
but he'll bounce back he'll he'll have
better tournaments later
yes i mean and your expectations for him
when
uh he achieved such great successes
at 18 do you start thinking oh my gosh
we were having an iranian world champion
does it such a thought go through your
mind
yeah kind of a yes or no see like uh
he switched
to france so it was already a little
he's still my countrymen though right
exactly always will be yeah always
it would be wonderful to see him
you know try his best and eventually i
would like to see him um compete against
world champion whoever that may be in a
few years okay very good and the
position that he's got
uh because this pawn structure as um
as ali alejandro was saying the defining
characteristic is these double pawns
on e5 and e6 but the pawn on e6 does
have this enormous benefit of
covering these two squares
um
if you were in
in white shoes
would you what what plan would you make
it's not that easy i mean
alejandro said if you make the knight
journey to g3 congratulations but
you're not going anywhere any further
no no i had a question about that
because
for me um i have most of my students are
like between 15 to 1800 level okay so
they love playing italian they love
getting themselves this position but
this like early
way before that oh even way way way okay
so we started starting at d3 right so d3
is nice everything is still normal it's
not a c3 d4 line but now for me the fact
that
they both start playing h3 and h6
that's not something that i've seen that
much and if i see one of my kids playing
it i'll have to you know sit them down
and talk to them about castling right
right
one of the things that is really uh
taken place at the highest levels most
especially at the candidates and i'm
thinking about a game that um
vladimir kramnik
defeated uh
i can't think of his name uh
from uh
oh boy
with g7 g5 i'll remember it in in just a
moment but the idea was that uh
uh
thank you so much when when lavon
castled early
on the king side as white he walked into
a g7 g5
and so one of the things that i'm seeing
these top grand masters do
is they're delaying
castles now again as a scholastics level
most especially it's you know you you
pound
into the kids you know castle early get
your king into safety but i have been
seeing some of these flank attacks
whether it be g4 when you're white or g7
g5 when you're you're black and people
are beginning to be a little bit
reluctant of castling early and being a
little bit savvy they're they're making
these kinds of moves on the queen side
knight d2 b4 a4 black is making a5
and bishop a7 levon
by the way suffered a huge a huge defeat
and this whole move with bishop e6 if
if you're black and you're trying to
equalize you look at the position and
the first thing i ask you is what's
white's best piece oh yes exactly the
bishop on c4 well let's trade it off and
that's exactly what timor did
with this move bishop e6 also by the way
i wanted to ask you about this i don't
know how closely you followed this
candidates but it seems to me
like ali reza has had
a woeful
time
mismanagement his clock he has taken 40
minute things 50 minutes things
in the opening position where it's moved
well
and then he's missed that time later in
the game
and very unfortunate for him right i
don't actually know much about who who
is his team helping him right but um
yeah i've also noticed that that the
certain um potential lack of open
opening
sharpness yeah yeah
it's missing
finally finally castles uh on the board
again this is
alejandra this is all still quite the
theory i would imagine and probably a
lot of games
from this exact position not at all
yasser actually there are not games in
this position even the move b4 already
is rather rare the way that
white and black set up remember the
italian all these transpositions they
come with very very small subtleties but
they're all very important and in this
case the fact that you played h3 that
you did not castle that you played
knight bd2 right away before the move a4
that this bishop can be caught with the
move knight a5 they all change for
example how do you castle here black can
start thinking about knight a5 there's
b4 you can take on c4 there's variations
like that but even the move b4 is
already a novelty and this is way back
already on move eight changing the
character of the position slightly of
course as i mentioned uh having the
bottom b4 does change things but after
bishop a7 bishop e6 uh we kind of
transpose a little bit into positions
that we know and now that both sides
have cancelled we return we're back into
known territory this is a few games of
significance nepal played this against
kramnik in 2018 how you find play this
against jakovenko both of those games
ended in draws there are other examples
there are a lot of typical moves knight
c4 is the most common one you now that
you castle you don't have the move
knight f1 knight g3 you do want to
control the e3 square so that you can
exchange these bishops in some
variations another way of doing things
is to try to defend this pawn on e4 and
defend this pawn on d4 so that you can
get the paw the break d4 in cementing
your control of the structure so the
move bishop b2 is also possible to move
rookie one has been seen and i see it on
the database that somebody blundered
with a move b5 so
so nicely from what i expect but as you
mentioned and you really hit that nail
on the head what has already's problem
been overthinking he's made bad
decisions after very very long things he
did it against favi he is just very
prone to wasting his time and it seems
that even though we have what seems to
me an eternal time control he manages to
still get in time trouble every game
wow remarkable and it and
these two players
have only played once
the first half of the candidates they
never played each other before
zero zero zero one draw
well okay
away you go uh this game of uh richard
rapport
one of the
things that you always want to do in
these positions i i like crave
this
desire
as white to get in the move f2
f4 as soon as possible when i see this
bishop
eyeballing my king
oftentimes i want to play the move king
over to h1 move the knight whether it be
to h4 and or g1 and get in f4
very surprising for me
was uh this decision
i'm
gonna guess that this move b2b3 is a
novelty i'm gonna ask
alejandro if that's indeed true i
wouldn't even understand why
my bishop wants to go to b2 i i would
want to
i don't know i mean if i was white i
would be thinking even about moves like
bishop d2 and queen c1 and wanting to
sacrifice is it possible that
uh roberts was uncomfortable with upon
trying to play pawn to a4 that's that's
why he played on b3 exactly well okay
you can get no question you get some
space over there with the move a5 a4
personally i wouldn't feel my feathers
being ruffled
because you've got your pawn to a4 like
go for it what knock yourself out with
what's going on over there
but the move b3 really is a suggestion
that you're going to put your bishop on
b2 and what is the bishop being doing
there
i'm clueless i don't get it i don't get
it what would your approach be if you
had white's position here would you be
going for the f4 business yes i'm a f4
lover i've every time i get drew lopez i
just want to play the g6 d6 bishop g7
move the knight go f5 so this for me is
like it's a f4 waiting to happen right
but
the one thing that i might
be a little concerned about if i were to
play f4 is potential d5s for some black
at some point okay i get that eventually
but it's still a lot early to say but i
feel like f4 is
kind of a must you've already played g3
already you have bishop g2 you've
already done the short castle everything
is ready for that move the king and go
pawn uh f4 right soon so i'm i'm hoping
to get some of four exactly and what you
just described in your own games by the
way that whole d6g that's lavonna romeo
that's the guy i wanted to say
castles move your king get in f7 f5 but
the combination of white's last two
moves is really confounding
b2b3
castles by black
and then
okay
bishop b2 i get that but h2h3
that's kind of confusing because
i didn't think that bishop g4 was a
threat sorry
so i was just thinking maybe instead of
king h1 richard is trying to go king h2
and then move the knight and go upon f4
but fair enough i i like that so let's
just go
so bishop to
e6 right so we're thinking that maybe
the queen will go up to d2
and you're saying that well he played a3
maybe in order to put his king not
necessarily on h1 but on h2 and
get this position you mentioned that
maybe d6 d5
also
becomes on black's agenda
these two gentlemen
richie and duda
really the first half was nightmarish
they couldn't win a single game between
the two of them they both got all draws
with one loss
and
for their maiden voyage into candidates
this has not been nice
both players looking for a victory
kind of i want to say a must-win game
for them as you see there they're tied
for fourth with the ding liran at minus
one and again hikaru nakamura all by
himself and third
hoping that he'll be able to catch fabi
and maybe in case
well magnus says no i don't want to play
uh he can catch him let's jump
back to hikaru's game
because that game
is such a
an important game for us we left it on a
crazy position oh bishop d3 has happened
you're moved yourself i mean
you
you came sharp this morning was it
difficult wait wait waking up these
early morning uh for you i'm well i'm
i'm uh incoming medical students i've
been preparing for my 8 a.m
but it was a little bit earlier
but not taking a quick red bull and a
caffeine bar and some coffee once
okay
welcome again um bishop to d3 and uh
well finally the players really have
slowed down because once again for those
of you who are joining us late
both players seem to be blitzing all the
way out to this position
and we are told that the move c7 c5 is a
novelty
seemed to
set maybe a trap
with the move bishop g5 and
karu played very quickly not necessarily
the engine recommended move either he
played the move a knight to g3
uh black set up shop
bishop to d3 dorsey i just have a quick
calculation
so if i'm not mistaken fabi spent about
25 minutes on bishop d3
uh about 23 yeah whoa
that's a long uh
i think knight g3 so that was um once
again um alejandro
um i understand the move knight g3 came
as a slight surprise for uh fabi got
that
doubtlessly he
calculated bishop to g5
was there a third alternative
besides knight g3 and bishop g5 that
fabi would have had to have calculated
yeah the game is still wide open at that
point so it wasn't necessary for hikaru
to go for knight g3 or for to go for the
bishop g5 complications the engines are
saying you could have covered the d3
square first right before you go the
move knight g3 and if you go c4 then
just retreat with the move bishop d1 no
problem you're okay with the bishop
coming to d3 once the move c4 is on the
board but hikaru is not surprised at all
yasser he played knight g3 long thing by
fabi played the move bishop d3 and
hikaru got back to his seat and said you
know what i know that move
boom then move queen d2 on the board now
you might be wondering why not move c4
in this position it's probably okay but
after bishop d1 how do you really follow
it up you would like to play the move e4
it really gives up
a very important square right you want
don't want to give up this huge knight
on d4 and this blockade look you have a
very nice bishop congratulations i have
the rest of the dark squares all of them
right you don't want to give me that
much space so the reason of not playing
c4 in this position could be that you
want to kick out this knight on f3
without giving up the square on d4 so
don't start with c4 start with the move
e4 actually the interesting c4 is
already a big mistake c4 bishop d1
white's better so there is the
possibility of playing e4 and there's
two complicated lines that could stem
from this i'm sure hicarus looked at
them and fabi's gonna have to figure
them out because knight h4 is one with
the idea of knight f5 where you could be
a little more
devilish with the move knight g5 look at
this it has a threat it does threaten
the pawn on e4 and it is not so easy to
defend this move if you play the move
king h8 again a hidden resource in the
position something difficult to figure
out for favi if he's just looking at
this for the first time i'm sure that
hikaru has this prepped the move queen
d1
a little cheeky a little devilish
the queen goes to h5 and suddenly it's
not so comfortable to defend the king
side why because you got your bishop
stuck on the wrong side of the pawn
chain you can't return the bishop to
defend the king said queen h5 is coming
it does not the engine that is does not
think it's a huge advantage for white
but it does think that at this point
black starts becoming a little bit
uncomfortable what does the engine want
to do after the move queen d2 e4 knight
g5 it says congratulations take that
pawn i don't think i would ever think of
this and goes for the complications of
knight a5 you you have this pin i need
to get rid of it it would continue
knight takes e4 it doesn't matter which
knight you take on e4 with bishop takes
knight takes e4 and we go down this
variation knight takes b3 you have to
take this knight pawn takes here
queen takes d6 rook takes d6 bishop
takes c5 that skewers the rooks
regains uh the material balance but
after rook d2 bishop takes f8 king takes
f8 you could take on e4 take on b2 edges
are saying this is a draw
but will fabi figure all of this out
this is typical welcome by the way to
the candidates tournament what happens
is
these guys calculate these long
variations
all the way to the very end and it's
like somebody came in and just vacuumed
all the pieces off the board and you get
these drawn rook and pawn end games
fascinating stuff and by the way what we
also like is uh to give our audience an
opportunity to join the conversation so
through the magic of social media we get
all kinds of questions dorsa so here's
one
let's go
from twitter user at
gm aster g4 sounds good is it possible
that hikaru predicted caruana's surprise
surprise
absolutely so the novelty was this move
c7 c5
and it's funny
how
often times this kind of a novelty that
we're seeing c7 c5
not only does your opponent know
that's a novelty and that surprise and
how to react but it's like the everybody
in the tournament
has been preparing these open positions
against fabi and they seem to know it as
well so oftentimes a novelty
uh
doesn't
it's the opposite it doesn't stun the
chess world everybody's aware of it and
in this case i think it's the
that that uh hikaru was aware of the
surprise well i also want to mention
like if when um fabi played the knight
a5 and followed by knights b7 i think
that c5 was kind of a given otherwise
why would you go knight p7 right
exactly exactly i mean that would be a
move that i would really want to resist
i mean i'd rather move my queen or
my rook to sidestep this um
skewer but once you've played the move
knight b7 it's a given he's going to
play c7 c5 because otherwise this knight
is really too passive now
this material imbalance of two minor
pieces for the rook but these pawns uh
once again i mean
it's
that they make this formidable looking
wall
but what alejandro was saying
is that after to move e5 e4 your
bishop's really good
it's right like right on the doorstep of
white's encampment but after the move
knight g5 just playing
around the bishop this cheeky threat of
knight takes e4
but this move
what aleandro mentioned that's a really
nice
hidden move the queen suddenly
you know
i i want to say it's
it's not so good it's not so good on d2
i mean
really what exactly is it doing there
it's hard to decipher but once you put
the queen on d5 you see the mate you see
the knight coming to f7 and you go oh my
gosh the queen is a huge attacking force
this move queen d1 looks really nasty
let me just update my board and see
yeah queen d2 and that's it
wow and after this move f7 f5 by the way
thank you for joining the conversation
with that question about c5 it sure
feels more and more like hikaru
is the one who's out prepped
fabi uh
we're getting this right uh alejandro
does it feel like
like hikaru is
caught fabi a little bit
uh
you think yeah
look at the time situation he grows an
hour and 53 left against an hour 24.
yeah i think i think probably got caught
right now is it going to be enough
that's the question because remember who
got caught in this in preparation in
this tournament a certain hikaru
nakamura got caught by alireza furuja he
was on the defending side there in a
nimzoo indian where alireza brought in
this great prep sacked some stuff and
went into some cool variations and
hikaru just sat down and calculated his
way out of trouble it was a razor sharp
escape but at no point did alareza have
a win now this is the question will five
be able to do that himself is his smell
of danger strong enough in this position
clearly he's been caught i'm sure that
he is not pleased with that but you do
what you have to do to be in the
candidates and that sometimes includes
taking prep from your opponent sitting
down and figuring out anyway what the
engine wanted you to do
wow
once again for me
alejandro it's kind of confusing
that the move c5 c4
is
maybe second best or something like that
because i think for a lot of
people ourselves
included you know cementing the the
bishop with the move c4 and essentially
what
if i've deciphered what you've said uh
the problem is the pawn on e5 you can't
maintain the pawn on e5 and you
definitely don't want to give up the d4
square but
did we look at just
defending the pawn on e5 for example
after rookie eight it's absolutely
playable don't think that favi would be
in a lost position if this happens it's
a playable position it's just that the
engines don't think it's accurate and
the reason for this in this position is
that eventually white plays a move
before you could play before immediately
i'm just going to put it on the board to
illustrate the point you're going to
play around the bishop so the bishop on
d3 very often is pretty without an
actual job it's defending the f1 square
from this rook challenging this one but
when you think about it white doesn't
want to trade works he only has one left
you don't want to give up this file so
the rook is sitting pretty on e1 away
from the bishop the bishop is also
controlling b1 but who cares right
nobody cares about that square what is
the bishop doing on d3 it's pretty it's
kind of annoying because it does cover
the d file but besides that it's not a
big deal meanwhile take a look at that
knight yeah that is
bad
it's real bad it doesn't have a really
good square it's defending c5 which it
needs to defend because otherwise the
bishop hops there and eventually white
starts maneuvering his pieces he even
considers at some point thinking what is
my worst piece in this position the
bishop on d1 needs a new square the
knight on g3 is dominated by this bishop
on d3 let me move it to another square
and it starts thinking of how to
remaneuver the pieces and there's tons
of potential and i like that for wide
potential the knight even can go to h1
and f2 to kick out this bishop on d3 and
yet again ask you if you really want to
play the move e4 and there is just no
scenario that improves black structure
and that's what i'm talking about with
potential e4 just never works for the
rest of the game the move e4 is a
strategical blunder the idea of playing
d4 takes an e4
it's a typical way of breaking
structures in order to get that move e4
right you cover the d4 square the
problem is that again it's a strategical
blunder because you give e5 to the
knight and in a situation where you
don't have the material to fight for
certain squares because remember black
has a rook against two minor pieces you
cannot fight for certain squares anymore
sacrificing the exchange is no longer
sacrificing the exchange sacrificing a
piece and in this case white is just
winning so it's the potential about both
positions that really changes
dramatically with the move c4 with the
move e4 instead it's this knight that
becomes uncomfortable now check out the
move c4 instead this knight it just
never moves it's cementing the position
and it covers the f file beautifully
where where is the play for the rooks
right the rook on his train would love
to just get rid of this knight on f3 and
just everything in the position the more
you think about it says black wants to
play e4
not c4 right well that kind of makes me
to ask the question
who would you want to be white or black
after that explanation
that one was too good dad
i mean he made it sound like white's got
all kinds of opera options the night
even that knight to h1 was pretty cool
before c4 before c i agree right here
right here right here well again uh
you know
when what we've seen
is the move c4
has issues drawbacks
the move e4 has issues drawbacks even
the bishop on d3 can be caught
offsides
i mean after a long think if we see the
movement
i wouldn't be completely uh surprised
but okay i understand it's not that
great a move why did we play
uh
bishop d3 in the first place we played
bishop d3 in the first place dorsa to
play c4
i mean we didn't necessarily want to
commit ourselves with e4 but again this
this
maneuver
[Music]
if you see the move queen d1 you really
start to get scared because
the queen jumping out to h5 these pawns
uh seem like kind of stuck sorry oh no
no i was just thinking uh well what if
queen g6 here because i remember
alejandra did mention this and it was
still white was more comfortable exactly
but
okay well let's say we go here
and again i'm thinking that my threat is
to take and maybe drop a knight in on e6
so more or less i'm trying to encourage
you to capture now you might think okay
now is my time
to play d4 right
and we could get a position where maybe
um
[Music]
knight f7 is on white's agenda did i do
it right with bishop to c1 i don't know
knight f4 knight takes e4
knight e6 also
[Laughter]
that's a painful fork
that looks pretty good uh so yeah the
queen g6 covering up makes sense but
then you have to
ask yourself well at the end of the day
are whites
the minor pieces seem to be
you know in a in a flurry while the
rooks are kind of stuck in mud unless
you get this d4 e3 business going
um it feels just nice for
white by the way our tournament leader
when we left it he shut things down a
long time ago
let's just uh let's just get back to it
what do we have one two three four one
two three four there's bishops of
opposite color right out of the opening
as alejandro mentioned
in all of the grand mass all the games
between grand masters got to this
opening the game ended in the draw doors
this was usually my go-to when i played
against like if i played against like a
25 25 50 26 2650 and i'm just like yeah
i don't really feel like like you know
going for scotch or rudolph i just want
a chill day i would go i would play for
night every time they would like give me
oh god look and they would just play it
out and like 30 moves in it's just a
dead draw and they would just accept
their fates exactly well
uh one of the
one of the really
great errors that uh
um
nepo has made in the first uh
well pardon me i want to say in the
candidates that he won
uh he started like plus three
he was doing really really really well
and then on he he played a super sharp
variation
as black against mvl this winner were
french and he lost
and
so like yesterday in that moment when he
was plus three no winner were french he
played the petrov the russian defense
the most solid that he could and today
with white i mean as as nice as as it is
to play with white against englerin and
play for a win and blah blah blah he
said there says no no no discretion the
better part of valor let me just shut
this game down in this bishops of
opposite color from this position that
we have on our analysis board to the
position that they have on their on
their board uh
this is
a draw in the site i just want to
quickly mention that why do you think
pla black played the f5 f4 idea because
the pawn on fcs could have just you know
stayed there they weren't obligated to
push that exactly so i think the fear
was that if
the game were the contin the game was to
continue
as it did and the knight would end up on
f5 and maybe you would capture
the knight
then these two pawns never move
and the idea is if in the game
the pawn is on f4 instead of being on f6
it's a much better chance that the pawn
would get traded
and
you get rid of one of your weak guys you
know these double pawns
and that's pretty much what what
happened white did end up playing the
move g2 g3
and from black's point of view from
black's point of view for just a moment
if the pawn were on f6 his whole king
sights doubled and
split right the pawns on f7 f6 double
the pawns on h6 split and what you say
what you see from ding laren in the game
is he's getting rid of his weak pawns
the pawns on h6 the pawns on f6 are both
weak
so what he's trying to do is trade them
off which he successfully did and
achieved what he what for ding
feels is a very easy draw because this
rook on h4 is now
trying to prevent the king from actually
getting a very aggressive
uh position and the rook is tied up so
we expect a draw in this game once again
the game of duda let's just double check
in
very early in wow now now i'm getting
more and more confused by the movie b2b3
we see knight to d4 one of the
problems in these
what do we call really lopez joko piano
kind of positions as this knight on c6
oftentimes doesn't have a really good
role the knight on f3 is hitting the
pawn on e5
sometimes this knight actually goes to
the f5 square so
black says you know what would be really
good
is if i could trade off this knight on
c6 for this knight on f3 i'm a happy
camper so he plays the move knight d4
and we reach a position where
he played not bishop to b2 but bishop e3
and i'm kind of thrown off
by white's approach here alejandro
help us out i mean i don't think white's
worse or anything like that but the
whole b3
oh
ali hum is not ready to ready for that
one but the whole
b3 connection doors i don't get it for
me i think it's still he was just trying
to wish block dude to not let him play
a4 because okay the pawn on b3 doesn't
serve any other purpose and also i
highly doubt he was trying to go bishop
b2 or bishop a3 okay
so i think it's more of a wish blocking
like hey
white's long-term plan is going to be in
the king side so white wants to make
sure that black doesn't have stuff in
the queen side so he can just kind of
focus on the king side later on but i
still the way that the game also played
with pawn c6 uh black is setting up to
play
um pawn d5 soon
so
i i'm still not sure if white can
comfortably play f4 and get away with it
yeah but he did play uh that is to say
uh richard played the move king h2 seems
like you're going to need to get the
king off of g1 if you're going to play
f2 f4 in the future
whether you put the king on h1 or
whether you put the king on h2
is a question in the old soviet union by
the way
this question of where to put the king
king on h2 or king on h1
was
answered
in a very peculiar way
when you're white and you're trying to
decide whether to put the king on h2 or
h1 you ask yourself where my opponent's
queen is
okay on a dark square or a light square
so if the opponent's queen is on a dark
square you would play king h1
okay if the opponent's queen was in the
light square you would play king h2 at
this moment since the queen is on d8 you
wouldn't play king h2 according to the
old soviet models of how to play middle
games a very peculiar thing and a lot of
player
uh now uh a lot of players in the west
were unfamiliar with that concept by the
way first game in the history books for
round eight it's over draw four nights
he said that like ah this is a personal
victory for you dorset i i have to take
some credits because you see yesterday i
finalized my decision i'm i'm team nepal
for at the moment and he played four
nights oh that's really great that's
really great so you come in halfway can
you believe this
alejandro she comes in halfway through
says my prediction
your bold prediction is
well napoleon team nepo and he plays
your opening yes thank you thank you for
playing foreign
but it's over it's over as soon as it
started look at this
alejandro can you believe that she comes
in and says i'm choosing godzilla i mean
i think nobody's told dorsa there's some
serious money here
exactly the production
oh yeah so the idea is
the idea is the production team they all
generously reach into their pockets pull
out the elusive green
and then we share the proceeds
now if you could put those uh
picks up once more i would like to
explain to doris how it works okay so if
you pick up the
so essentially
fobby and nepo don't count oh man why
because they're winning the x exhibition
they're just beating the heck
but the guys who are playing the
tournament
in this case nakamura and look who
choose
are you winning the exhibition right
alejandro
sure
exactly but that's a big half point
let's talk about it guys it's a big half
point for nepo he's taking a look at the
second half of the candidates and
correct me if i'm wrong guys but we
haven't really mentioned this so much
in the first half nepal had more blacks
oh yes that's correct he had four out of
the seven games and now with the white
pieces he's gonna be looking a lot of
this
half points
running around on the bottom of the
field if he is white and he wants to
make and force draws yeah what what are
his opponents going to do about it
they're not interested in the tournament
anymore right
they're going to allow him to achieve
his goal that's right and there he is a
full point now over fabiano caruana and
it's really up to the americans at this
point who is going to give nepo a bit of
run for his money remember we also talk
about second place in this tournament
just for the
extracurricular circumstances let's put
it that way
right
uh good point no
that that first half
that the players obviously are just
flipping colors for the second half
and having that extra black getting
getting the extra white in the second
half
and perhaps that's why
these statistical models give such a
huge edge to nepal over favi now then
combined is something like 98 chance
right 98 chance to win between one of
nepo or favi but between these two it's
about 66 to 33 in favor of nepo and it's
not just that he's half a point ahead
you're that important that's important
but favi
gets one more black
in the remaining seven
nepo gets one more white
in the remaining seven he just burns one
to make a draw but that's part of the
strategy no problems there nepo just
doing it by the playbook yep absolutely
so network's magic number it was nine or
nine and a half nine and a half yeah
he's like if if he manages to win one
more i think he's just it's unbelievable
and it's just over yeah it's just over
over
uh i'm not it looks like more or less
bobby has burned 50 minutes
of his two hours that he is allocated
for the first 40 moves burned about 50
minutes to get to this position
and c5 c4 is on the board and maybe
this is actually the first time hikaru
is actually slowed his pace because he
was just snapping out all of those moves
c5 c4 and once again um one of those
nice
moments that alejandro pointed out that
after a move like say bishop d1
because the bishop is actually on the
square d3 and it requires the protection
of the pawn when white sneaks in the
move b4
there's no amphison
you can't ampus on because the bishop
would be hanging if white gets in the
move b b4 like we're just going to put a
move on the board for black which is a
moment probably not a very good move but
then we get b4 and then this knight on
b7
is really crying this is paralyzed
bingo you got it it sure is and
it's getting more and more tough for
black to simply keep his center defended
this is such a huge game i cannot
emphasize it enough a few more moves
that were played in
ali reza's position rookie
knight f1 all looks very standard where
is that knight trying to go though which
one this one on f1
in the immortal words
of robert hubner
i do not know
so robert hoovner was one of these
intellectual giants
of the chess world he spoke about 17
languages
is a professor of paperology so he
studied hieroglyphics
in his youth and all the ancient
languages ancient hebrew ancient greek
he knows
and you read everything like he does
everything so he should know everything
everything
so whenever robert stops himself and
robert what do you think should happen
and he would adjust his glasses and say
i do not
know we all stopped he said how could he
not know i mean
robert hootner
and uh over to you alejandro but
somebody who does know where they are
it's tamara rodrigo but i want to tell
you why because the italian it has these
cool things where the move orders
they're subtle but sometimes they become
the same game we see this very often
happen and players tend to bamboozle
themselves into the different variations
and it seems to me that yet again ali
reza has bamboozled himself more than
his opponent why because timor java is
looking at this position and saying
dude i'm going to spend 19 minutes
because of the different move orders but
i've already had this position in an
important game from a tournament that
apparently alireza did forget that ever
happened now alireza in the world cup of
sochi didn't have a
great result but we're talking about
even the one before this is the one
where teemu rajabov ends up winning the
whole thing in 2019 in huntyman sisk and
in one of the first rounds he's playing
against grand master from the faroe
islands helgi siska 2 500 quite strong
and quite talented and rajab with the
black pieces got this exact position
exactly this one and alirez is now in
the tank spending 45 minutes figuring
out his next move rajab was sitting
there like
i already analyzed this dude what what
what what's the what's your idea where
are you going i already played this i
already got a comfortable draw against a
strong player where is your new idea
where is your novelty where's your
handling of the position because i don't
think alireza is even aware that this
game existed based on the time
expenditure
uh
crazy that i i just wanted to ask you
alejandro when i see this move rook a2
and the fact that the king is on h2 i
think that white is at long last
ready to play the move b5 and d4 could
that bring him some advantage if he
could get
those
like he played bishop e3 he did not play
b5 bishop e3 exactly like grandmaster
helgi see she got played okay so nothing
new here for teamwork i'm sure he's just
gonna recall his preparation maybe take
a couple of minutes to refresh his
memory okay and play something quickly
to answer your question yesterday
unfortunately b5 is still not quite it's
not quite as effective and the reason is
that in this case is when i don't have a
tactical trick against the rook black
generally does not hurry and take on b5
instead i would think the natural move
is to play the move knight e7 now if you
really want to say modern chess yeah
after the move uh king hd queen f7 b5
you can also play
oh dang it's a very typical idea of
certain reload passes to remaneuver this
knight from b8 to d7 and now that you
spend two tempe on b4 b5 and you're
giving me the c5 square i'll be more
than happy to do so if you play the move
d4 the game just kind of goes on you can
take on d4 play bishop b6 or even play
knight d7 immediately developing
computers consider the position to be
about balance both sides with their
chances so it's not like java has an
advantage or anything like that it's a
known position right uh but the move b5
perhaps a little bit rushed the engines
do prefer the move bishop e3 taking
advantage of the fact that at this
precise moment neither knight takes h3
nor knight takes g2 work so that if you
take on e3 probably you take with the
pawn and then transfer the rook is this
bad for black no position is still
pretty symmetrical you could just
retreat the knight to either g6 or h5
follow this up with queen e7 or queen g6
the structure yeah well you have a
little bit more space on the queen side
perhaps you can get your rook to f2
but is this really that dangerous for
black no it doesn't seem so it doesn't
seem so at all
this is usually the point in the show
dorsa where we invite our viewers to
support us by
offering them specials at cue boutique
we usually give a friends and family
discount of five percent
to people who would use their coupon is
that the case today what do you have for
future from what i have in front of me
75 no way
five percent is the best that we could
offer yeah this is actually my brother
has that really
you're already ahead of the crowd yes
what is it what are we looking at well
we are actually looking at last year
tournaments merch
and if you use the code sale 75 because
75 percent of this gorgeous maroon grand
chess tour t-shirt which has the
landmarks from all of the cities
that
they had the tournaments in my favorites
yes this is two of the saint blues haha
rapid and blitz in the sink field very
very nice it's very very beautiful 75
off that's crazy i've never heard that
that though such a beautiful arch nice
arch oh i found that mistaken that's um
eiffel tower on the back
i have to i like that the arch is bigger
[Laughter]
nice well we're going to see you on the
other side of this break is once again
we do have one game completed as our
tournament leader nepo continues his
streak undefeated streak leads the
tournament by a full point with three
games still going see on the other side
of the spring we'll be back yeah very
nice
so this story uh that i'd like to share
is the downside
of analyzing with a chess genius i got
tons of bobby fischer stories
and this one comes courtesy of robert
byrne and robert
tells me the story of the havana
chess olympiad 1966
where he's playing on the american team
and the american team is being led by
none other than
robert james fisher bobby
was the only one on the team who had a
suite in the evenings the whole team
would
congregate together at bobby's suite and
they'd replay
the games that they just played that
afternoon in the olympiad robert was
saying this was really the highlight of
the olympiad and everybody on the team
would scramble to get to bobby sweet
because bobby
would show the game he played and
analyzed and explained
what was going on these lectures these
moments
were just
absolutely absolutely awesome so bobby
is showing a game that he had played
that day
somewhere as bobby is moving the pieces
and explaining
he then in a derogatory way
calls his opponent a pizza and he goes
and the pizza
played this move and as he's making the
move
bobby starts chuckling and laughing and
then kind of laughing
really really hard the kind of painful
he literally
falls off his chair on the carpet going
back and forth withering an absolute
joyous
abandonment laughter
about his opponent's moves the five
grand masters on the team
are looking at the position because the
pizza
played a reasonable move
and they couldn't understand why bobby
was laughing
nobody saw the reputation
and
robert was in a panic
an absolute stone cold
panic because
he's laughing and robert doesn't see why
bobby's so
so incredulous about isabel
then
bob sees the reputation
and bob starts laughing
and then collectively around the table
all five see the move
bobby who's now in tears just barely
makes it back to the table and makes the
move that robert byrne anticipated and
boom boom boom and bingo bongo so robert
tells me the story decades later
that he was an abject terror
he would not have seen the move
and that bobby would realize that
nobody's seeing the move and kick
everybody out and think of them as
posters too and robert did not want
bobby fischer thinking he was a weak
player so the moment he saw a winning
move he said
the relief that i felt
was almost the taste of honey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the candidates 2022 we are
in round eight with one game already in
the history books our tournament leader
nepo has made a draw against ding lehren
and therefore has six points and a one
point
lead over his nearest rival fabiano now
fabiano dorsett
he's playing black in a very crucial
game as he's up against his countrymen
nakamura who's currently in third
position
is a scary game from what i remember
right and it's getting scarier
exactly and that game when we left it
featured this position with c5 c4
bishop d1 and then alejandro was saying
you know it's kind of getting awkward
for black to keep his center most
especially the e5 pawn
under control
the rooks aren't exactly doing what they
need to do
coordinate
after some time rook d7 fabio spent an
hour and 10 minutes i believe to get to
this position even though they were both
blitzing like mad the first uh 20 moves
or so and after the move rook d7 we can
see that the rooks
are
most likely headed
for the
open f file with the move rook on d7 to
f7 but i really like what
yes um yes alejandro was saying about
the move before sorry please
i was just thinking like
do you think it's possible that folly
has
missed
b4 because rough d7 doesn't really do
much to
combat it's
yeah but on the other hand i mean did
you want to play a7 yeah i couldn't
imagine you wanted to play
a5
kind of things um at some point though
you can see that this whole
i mean black needs a long-term plan he's
got his bishop on d3 and it's sort of
like kudos and hats off and things like
that
but black needs a long-term plan white
on the other hand
with his minor pieces he's just looking
for
uh
a square
literally like you can imagine that this
bishop might drop back just picking a
move bishop f2 okay
move this pawn we've seen on countless
occasions we don't want to move the pawn
exactly so we maybe move
make a move with our rook and then let's
just say we go back and then we start to
see well
certain things are getting awkward it's
getting more and more difficult uh to
maintain now there is this knight c5 and
i'll i'll grant you i've totally
misplaced
this but you see where i'm coming from
with this idea that i'm going to put
pressure on e5 a long term
now
rook d7 doesn't address that and things
are really getting uh
heating up i want to say alejandro yes
nice
okay things are getting spicy alejandro
and
who
who's favoring uh the spice
i would say that hikaru is the one
that's more familiar with the position
remember that hikaru's prep is not just
move by move but it's the understanding
of the position that comes from it and
as you guys mentioned b4 is scary but
the move a5 doesn't address
the bigger problem the bigger problem
right now is that this pawn on e5 is
rather vulnerable and if you move it
forward it's very difficult for white
for black to ever control a dark square
again so here the move bishop f2
immediately targeting this pawn says
after rook d8 you know what guess what
i'm gonna attack it again and the reason
that i can do this i have two minor
pieces against the rook the rooks can't
hold on to the structure forever if you
give up the pawn i will take it there's
dangers of the pin on the file
but they're not strong enough to deter
white from taking on e5 it is the
takeable pawn i'm sure that car would
have done it the movie rook d7 addresses
this in a couple of ways for example if
you play the move bishop f2 right now
you can pin
the knight
with the desirable move anyway
rook d to f7 so the major threat for
white wasn't b4 which is a nice move to
play you can play it at any moment
it's more that this bishop would move
sometimes to a7 sometimes to f2 hide
somewhere so that this rook on e1 is
attacking the pawn on e5 as it stands
right now the bishop actually lacks
squares on the diagonal and that's why
one of the top engine moves there are
choices of course by this point after
the move rook d7 is to give the bishop a
u a good square a hidden square away
from the power of the rooks of the f
island play the move king h1 now b4 is
playable of course and the laking h1 for
a future moment but king h1 right away
is definitely playable the idea is that
this bishop will drop back to the g1
square and again the pressure on the
pawn on e5 tactically you can't play
knight c5 because knight takes e5 always
works and always takes an important pawn
the knight going to d8 could be playable
and this is where we start playing b4
jumping with the bishop on c5 so again
the knight is not great on b7 but it is
a bit stuck there as i mentioned because
allowing this bishop to come to c5
really
populates black's position the queen on
d6 as well plays the rook on f8 doesn't
move and that means this knight it can't
really hop around that much objectively
the more the engines think the more they
think that this is a terrible position
for black that it is slightly better for
white but it's not that bad from a
practical point of view i don't see it
so i think that it's just so much easier
to play with the two minor pieces in
this point because when you play with
the pawns you want them to be mobile
that you want them to be able to rush
down with the pawns and if you can't at
least threaten to do so so the pieces
have no activity but in this case the
pawns are already kind of stuck they
look very nice they're very pretty but
which pawn maneuver pawn break do you
want to do in this position you don't
want to push your e-point you don't want
to push your d-pawn so what's really
left of plans for black yeah the engine
says you know what go h6 and k shaking
g8 i don't care see what white's going
to do but do humans play like that not
so much no it's going to be very
difficult and i absolutely love by the
way that move king h1 and bishop g1 and
love the saved king to begin with but
the problem as i see it in white's
position
is white really wants to put as much
pressure on the e5 pawn as he possibly
can
and the bishop quite frankly is in the
way
if you put your king on h1 you put your
bishop on g1
your bishop's out of the way tucked away
and maybe on even on a good day one day
you'll even play h3 and bishop h2 and
the bishop will find a really purposeful
diagonal so i really like this idea of
king h1 i really like this idea of
b4 and i think we have a move i think we
have bishop f2 on the board already
which
well i mean rather straightforward idea
yeah and dorset you were able to say
something i was just wondering because
you know it's always like fight upon its
most active piece and get rid of it so
where do we stand on exchanging the
light square bishops
you mean something like bishop c2 and
getting rid of yeah and getting rid of
it uh frankly that is the type of move i
would always be attracted to i would
always be attracted it just seems for
the moment
that um
white
wants to play around the bishop it's
sort of like if i can play the move b2b4
i take advantage of the fact that the
bishop is on d3 in truth i hate
my opponent having such a gorgeous
looking bishop sitting there staring me
in the face and so i personally would be
attracted to moves like bishop c2 and
bishop e2 this particular case we can
imagine another example let me just uh
make another move or just a moment
here here
here we we could see that maybe this
bishop gets a little bit offsides
like this bishop might actually
be more comfy
on the g4 square than this bishop is on
the d3 square now uh
alejandro we just saw the move bishop f2
but i think
the whole idea of rook to d7
was to
swing
the rooks to the f-file isn't the move
bishop f2 encouraging
black to do what he wants bring his rook
to the file and what other choice does
he have really you got to defend the
pawn on e5 somehow you could defend it
with the move rook e7 and the engines
don't think it's that bad you can put
the rook on e7 and defend somehow but i
think it's just more logical to put the
rook on f7 it's more active it might
threaten rook takes f3 one day you know
what move e4 is finally a threat because
f2 is hanging exactly and it really
forces white to make a decision how are
you gonna reply to my threat now you
could repeat moves but i don't think
that's what he carries wants to do
especially now that you forced my rook
to f7 the only other move is knight h1
and i think this is what hikaru is
eyeing the move knight h1 defends the
bishop on f2 but more importantly gives
the bishop a room on g3 which allows
this knight to get to f2 what's the only
disadvantage of this that temporarily
white pieces are not where they want to
be especially if it's not on h1 being
blocked from f2 this is the moment where
black would need to be playing precisely
and very actively because at this
particular moment with the move e4 and
you could play knight g5 it's a messy
but i think knight d4 is what we want to
play and with this piece is still a
little bit far away you will be able to
get in moves like knight c5 and knight
e6 depending where the bishop goes for
example if the bishop ever goes to g3 i
could go knight c5 96 get rid of this
knight while this knight take a look
it's sleeping on h1 right the movement
this bishop leaves rook f1 is made so
it's going to take you a while to move
out of this construction it doesn't
think that black can do something super
active while this happens but it can get
rid of the knight that's a good start
knight c5 knight e6 you can't replace it
with the bishop this is the important
part because again the pressure on f1 if
you exchange my bishop then maybe i'll
change my mind and instead of going 95
96 i'll say well knight c5 knight d3 and
all this moves with knight c5 and having
the knight jump somewhere is the reason
that the computers really like to put
the pawn on b4 before going for this
king side maneuvers now it doesn't think
that nakamura has spoiled anything it
still gives white a slight advantage
after the move bishop f2 i personally
thought the move king g1 was more
harmonious but of course the move knight
h1 bishop g3 is also a very tempting way
to handle this position the only issue
is that black
finally has a little bit of counter play
and it all revolves around the
possibilities of the f-file that would
be surprised if if fabiano does not play
the movement df7 it's just a much more
logical move in my view than passively
defending the position with rook e7 no
question about it because uh the the two
bishops pardon me
the two minor pieces versus the rook
if you got the rook you better make sure
that they're effective and this rook on
d8 wasn't that great
doubling the rooks on the default we can
see that it's nice to have a threat
exactly e5 e4
give me that bishop on f2 so doubling
the rooks
makes the most sense trying to go into a
position where you're somehow defending
the e5 pawn i don't like it this is also
one of the things that's been happening
in our candidates tournament we get four
rounds a day but because the two players
have just run away with the event nepo
and fabi it's like are it's like a
magnet we ended up we end up focusing on
two games to the exclusion of the others
but let's jump in to the other games um
i'm thinking specifically of the one
between richie as white against duda
b3 a move i didn't understand is now
followed up with the extraordinary a2 a3
another one of those moves that you know
just has me perplexed i would i would
assume knight h4
instead of a3 because everything felt
like it's ready for it
at long last i'm agree with you
wholeheartedly that it really feels like
white wants to play the move f2 f4 but
now keep in mind what duda has been
doing with his last few moves what he
played was this move c7 c6 a clear
indication
that he wants to control the square d5
maybe support the advanced t65 he really
doesn't want to do that with the pawn on
e5 hanging so after king h2 rook e8 is
very consequentially
he's uh is just like i'm winding up
lining up lining up right getting ready
to play dc d6 d5
a2 a3 uh richie is basically saying go
ahead play d5
and
no yeah dude i said let's trade a couple
of minor pieces takes on f3
takes on
e3
we're going to recapture of course but
the question is
should we recapture the queen or the
pawn if you take with queen i still keep
f4 but i feel like the whole purpose of
f4 is to open up a file right that's the
greater purpose no question yeah then
why not just take it to the pawn
immediately yeah and uh open up the
f-file that way
uh of course one of
the
uh great founding principles
of uh wilhelm steinitz uh you go back in
the day our very first world champion
and one of the things that stein it's
the scientific method
of playing against pawn weaknesses he
liked this idea you've opened up the
f-file what we would call the half open
f-file
the knight on f6 is a target i'm not
afraid of queen takes f6 but maybe i'd
be afraid of rook takes f6
so one of the things he would like to do
in such situations is queen c7 and just
move away so let me just put a move on
the board for just a second and he would
play like this and then he would play f7
f6
in order to keep the
file closed and then this night on a
good day you know would be
remaneuver the problem when you play
f2 takes e3 the double pawns
long term they could become a static
weakness i like what you were saying
about playing for f4 queen takes you do
keep this
but you are encouraging d65 it feels
even steven actually yeah truth be told
i think that
it's more equality than advantage either
player and the one thing the players
don't want they draw they're just
drawing themselves
right out of the competition finally uh
let's go back to uh
teamwork wow what is going on we left it
i think that night was on f1 and i was
asking where is that knight trying to go
i guess
you just found out
yeah right there okay so king h8 a very
reasonable uh temporizing move
we don't know if the king is well placed
on g8
it's not that we're ready to go g7 g5
it's just that we're giving ourselves an
option that maybe sometime in the future
where you might knight g4
well that's a straight that's a peculiar
place to land is he trying to go upon
day four
seems so seem so
the knight on g4 otherwise doesn't look
that great okay so kind of confused
could have played d4 and maybe
achieved a position like this
but he did play knight to g1
and we've caught up with the players
knight g1
maybe because now the knight is no
longer
um
vulnerable
well what how would you follow up g3 g3
uh i mean after like even if you do get
g3 are you hoping i don't think you can
do f4 at any point so what are you i it
for for me i'm thinking that has to be a
d3 d4 related just because what you've
just said
that there's no way you're getting in g3
and f4
so i think the idea is to get in a d4
and a g3 for the moment also
i think black would probably like to
trade one pair of knights let me just
put a move on the board
knight g8 i mean
with the idea of maybe challenging this
night and if you drive me back well you
drove me back well done um
still uh
again this looks
pretty even i wouldn't ask please which
which color would you rather be right
now i think it's i think it's a pickup
in other words i don't have a clear
favorite here
i think it's
maybe a tad easier to play black
is that my own file semi-open file
um but when you look at the position
so long term i'm sitting there saying
okay i like that target i like to win
poems that's what i'm trying to do we're
on the we're on the same page on the
eating poncho eating bonds oh very good
well welcome to the club
very nice very nice we'll make sure you
get a gold card gold membership uh but
yeah dorsa i sit there and i go
okay so what's the target then
no ponzo that's
vulnerable right i mean i don't see the
targets really for either side and i
think it's one of those games that you
know the players are preparing their
respective breaks whatever they may be
and d3 d4 seems to be white's only one
if d3 d4 happens black is kind of forced
into taking because if not
then those double pawns would be
isolated yeah one of the things
if you play the move d4
strangely enough the knight on g4 which
looks like a
weirdo like what are you doing there i
mean what are you doing there you might
encourage me to just get rid of you you
know get
get out of here you play the move h5
drive the knight back to e3 once your
pawn is on d4 so hold on let's
let's make some moves
let's do it d4 h5 knight back and some
crazy ideas let's just put some things
on the board just to kind of give us a
zen of what's going on here
you can take
on a d4 let me take here and let me just
put some
this is uh
the knights
look a little bit okay
um i don't know this knight on g1 is not
making a great impression
c3 is weak
potentially f2 is weak so as the game
opens up i'm just saying you both
players are going to be trying to
maneuver their pieces in such a way that
that they get advantage
as the game opens up guys the most nice
g6 was played a little quiz for you you
might be thinking doesn't knight g6
blunder a pawn
how dare you really because well you if
you play g3 where's your knight go
exactly so
you you go g3
knight goes back to h5 yummy
can you believe this
we get checkmated
that's oh my gosh dorsa we get
checkmated that would be gross right
we're just about it ready to achieve our
favorite living condition
and then suddenly
oh such a beautiful tactic exactly
queen takes
oh
nice
nice
the old smothered mate
that being said as beautiful as this
tactic is it does make me wonder what
exactly
are black's pieces doing on h5 and g6
let's assume that alireza can see move
two moves ahead and then he won't
blunder into checkmate and two and that
he plays a normal looking move whether
it's you know rook d2 or you over defend
f2 there is no threat right now because
the knight on g4 is covering f2 so there
is no queen takes f2 at the moment that
only if i blunder with knight takes h6
but g3 already on the board don't the
knight on h5 and the knight on g6 cause
let's face it kind of a bad impression
the best you can really do with this
knight on h5 is bring it back to f6
meanwhile you maneuver your knight from
c6 to g6
and then weird is achieved
nothing i'm a little more curious about
the more in-depth analysis so can we
actually talk a little bit more
alejandro
about uh after uh
say king g2 yeah a move like king g2
well basically what alejandro is saying
is
is black has spent two moves on the
maneuver bringing his knight to g6 where
it
doesn't have a particularly bright
future in the meanwhile these knights
kind of offsides he's explaining that
well you're probably going to play
knight f6 yeah
and then the knight on g6 really doesn't
have a role to play um
alejandro having said all of that though
it still feels very balanced
how are the players going to unbalance
the position to give themselves some
chances
well if it seems balanced to
you guys
okay to the engine no no the engine says
for java just play badly the the moves
knight e7 and knight g6 don't really
make a lot of sense to it it actually
thought 97 was dubious move and
immediately wanted to go back to c6
really yeah it doesn't like the knight
on g6 and i can kind of understand it
the move king g2 is fine it's not a bad
move it's one of the many top moves of
the engine and the idea for white is
going to eventually put the rook on d2
and force through d4 you already have an
advantage of space on the queen side
only thing you have to make sure is that
the king side doesn't become
weak so how do you continue with black
i'm gonna put together a few useful
moves for white i'm gonna put the rook
on d2 this knight on g1 will return to
f3 now that i got my ideal construction
yeah there's some pressure on the knight
on f3 but that's it pressure there are
no tactical tricks against it knight f4
just never works if you're really
worried about that you can even put your
rook on e3 and solidify that way so i
put rook on d2
knight on f3 rook on e3 and then i push
for d4 okay you have tactical problems
with the knight on h5 so at some point
you have to go knight f6 back and guess
what i'm just going to ignore you
because if you take on g4 thank you so
much h takes g4 and now i have the
ability to play g5 and open up your king
you're never hitting the pawn on g4 no
ps can attack it from any angle so
what is your next move the engine saying
knight f6 for example rookie 3
clear advantage white
clear advantage white because of this
whole rook to d2
to d4 okay we'll uh we'll definitely
keep that in mind and we have some
social media questions questions thank
you for uh joining the discussion what
do you have for us dorsa
well it's twitter this time nice
what was the wildest game you ever
played oh do you want to take that one
sure and you think about it but i
remember
this was a a terrible event for me so it
was the dreams and nightmares uh story
so what happens is
you have these open events
where i'm godzilla i'm on board one
right but i'm like 500 rating points
higher rated than my first round
opponent
so the great fear of the master
is that in the first round of a swiss
tournament
you're going to end up playing a much
lower rated player that lower rated
player is going to play the game of
their lives oh i've done that before
and destroy you
and it's like okay so that's the
nightmare
and of before the master and the dream
of course for the the the
uh club player is that you know they go
behind the nice little robes they
introduce themselves and of course they
play
so there i was
in the first round of an open in seattle
and i'm playing a much lower rated
player
and i play the theory but the theory is
wrong
my opponent refutes the encyclopedia of
chess openings
and i end up having to sacrifice my
queen for a lone
bishop
in two pawns
so i'm a queen down
for a bishop and two pawns but i have
the most unbelievable initiative and i
turned the game around i was lost
the the the queen was definitely winning
but that was completely wild the first
round of an open event nobody would ever
know about it except it's this crazy
wild game
and the whole tournament hall comes over
and sees that i'm losing when my
opponent matthew darby resigns
they all rushed to him and congrat they
saw that i was shaking his hand they
thought he had won
so they all rushed to congratulate him
when he had resigned why did they resign
at that point i was winning
but it was pretty uh oh that was super
chaotic super wild alejandro your
wildest game ever
oh man oh man it's hard to uh
hard to say i mean i've been involved so
many king hunts i've been involved in
being hunted it's it's uh it's crazy out
there but i think i'm gonna have to go
with my game in reykjavik against an
international master by the name of
yakov norwicz
i don't know what came to my mind i'm
not normally that type of player but
that day i decided to sacrifice a bunch
of pieces
and his king went from e1
to a1
and god made it on g3
nice that was a game it was it was
really fun uh i i must admit i was very
lost in that game but you still had to
find you know some precise moves to get
out of the complications my opponent
luckily wasn't able to find them i won a
nice game that sounds wild dorsey you
got to get in there what was your well i
have a few choices i'll just go for the
one that's
most hurtful
i like it the most hurtful one okay so
this is back in like 2015 and early 2016
i'm like hunting down my final wgm my
early is you want to get your norms yes
i already had the rating for especially
for wgm i was already like 2 405 and i
was like oh my god i just need to get
the last one and
like
for three
tournaments in a row uh the last round i
kept getting janish and i would like i
would
lose or i needed like a draw or i needed
like a win and it wouldn't and then a
draw and it was just i was just not
getting it so finally
this is the last round of a different
tournament i'm white i'm like you know
what i need to win i don't want to go
fortnite i don't want to go scotch let's
just go with rory lopez i play it
opponent plays the honest on my karma
no finally win it this time is white
and i get the norm and i'm just like
okay
this was just terrifying because three
yarnishes three last rounds oh i'm just
i was just sick of it at that point and
i have not played yanish since as black
i'm just
i'm just done with the honest [ __ ]
that's it i think everybody
everybody who has got their titles
uh has been in that situation where they
need one more norm
and achieving that final norm splat
splat face plants
flats flat and eventually when you get
it then it's easy
then it's sort of like i i mean
no problem two more gyms right after
that
nice and by the way we do have uh timor
has played the move uh knight f6 and
this is where
the move rook on a2 ii to d2
followed by knight f3 and playing for d4
that is the prescription
that alejandro has given us and said
this is how
alireza can
turn the position into advantage for
himself he starts with the move of
knight f3 which is fine and just as
alejandro was mentioning if you take and
double up white's pawns on the g file
you're actually
yeah you're doing
you're doing white a solid
uh g4 g5 can be used as a battering ram
and i would not
make that trade if i was in black shoes
a quick look once again as we go back to
this game which will be this
magnet for us
the game between fabi
and
hikaru uh well more or less as we
expected the rook did go to f7 big
threat e5 e4
the rooks are doubled and the bishop on
f2
uh needs protection knight h1 was
predicted yes yeah not exactly ideal uh
the knight on h1 but on the other hand
do something the pawn on e5 is
definitely ready to be captured and
maybe even captured in a nice way with
the bishop coming to g3 the knight would
come to f2 that would be a dream
scenario
e5 e4 and help me out here dorset what's
the difference
of the clocks it's about 50 minutes
whoa
that's a big edge for hikaru this is
like 94. yes i had this coach this is
like
15 years ago what was the name of yours
not alejandro
he would always say
a real coach in other words i get it i
get it i get it
he would always say like every 20
minutes you can think of it as like an
extra pawn
now i don't exactly believe that but it
will it always made me like think about
my time way more like oh if i'm getting
like 25 more minutes lower on the clock
that's like another pawn
so
how do you feel about that your your
coach was saying that a very big or
20-minute advantage on the clock was
worth almost a material advantage on the
board
it's so meaningful
um
you know
i actually had such ideas that that was
the case
until i played
a guy by the name of walter sean brown
six times
walter was the u.s champion and that guy
i wanted to wring his neck
[Laughter]
i am not kidding he would get one minute
on his clock for 20 moves
and in that one minute and in those 20
moves he'd be going bang bang bang bang
bang bang and playing perfectly
and i was like this is unbelievable i
have seen him
not
dozens of times but i mean almost
dozens and dozens of times
completely outplaying his opponent when
he has no time on the clock and it was
like
it it was so disturbing
i mean here i would i mean like you know
an extra 30 extra 60 minutes and i'd be
reveling oh i could do this i could do
that and i'd come up with some idea and
he just refute it
and some people have this unbelievable
uncanny ability of playing incredibly
well in time trouble
walter sean brown
alexander grishok or victor korchnoy
are uh examples of people who can play
in time trouble i am not one of those
people i mean i i i play poorly uh how
about you do you like how have you
played into time trouble i'm well i mean
i like playing bullets but i feel like
different categories totally right but
exactly no i mean i don't i don't
actually know anybody who enjoys playing
under time time travel one of um one of
my well ex slew teammates because now i
have a new team so i can't see my
teammates okay
always in time pressure i i i i don't
want to say i swear to you but i kind of
swear to you i've seen alejandra like
sweat and bite on his hand
i couldn't kill you you don't move
yeah
but she plays amazing she's very high
rated she's very comfortable she's great
so i mean i guess it works for her but
for me i i i have my my heart just hurts
when it's too too low on time
nervy uh to be sure alejandro do you
play good in time trouble no i play
terrible the lower my title is the more
um pressure i get i just blunder
everything so i don't get myself in time
trouble i'm actually a player that
doesn't have that issue i if if i'm
getting in time travel was because my
position was bad anyway right so at that
point it didn't really matter but in
normal games of chess i don't really try
to get into time trouble i'm not
comfortable at it i hate it and i hate
seeing my students do it
i remember
being in the world cup that i mentioned
in hunty man cisco's one of my students
benjamin bach playing against one of the
players that you mentioned yasser
alexander grisjoe they're playing in the
world cup
we sat down they finished their opening
i was at the press room just looking at
the games and they decided well this is
maybe a good time to do a little bit of
shopping you know some power bars some
juice take it back to the hotel then i
came back to the press room i spent
about an hour i took a walk in the city
they had each made one move
[Laughter]
nice
nice uh yeah that's
yeah time trouble and the weird part
is
if you become a time trouble addict it's
like you never get out of it i mean i
have watched players over the ages uh
again viktor korchner is the
the player who comes most
strongly to mind as somebody who
embraces
time trouble
and never cured himself that was always
a problem by the way jumping back into
the game
we can see that
that
hikaru would just be winning the game
the game would be over if he could get
you know moves like bishop g3 and knight
f2 that knight on h1 is terrible but as
alejandro mentioned previously
rook f1 check mate
is kind of stuck right now it's going to
hurt your feelings
your your bishop can't move so it's
going to require you know a little bit
of well maybe a lot of preparation
you're going to require you to play h3
uh bishop to g3 even in those cases by
the way the rook could
conceivably go rook takes h1 so
why it's going to take a few moves to
untangle
on a good day this night oh yes
might
start jumping around the board too so
whether or not you take it take uh b2b4
as a consideration of something yes i
don't think if b4 works anymore that's
well then you can emphasize yeah yeah so
i think icar definitely
missed on that opportunity to play
before previously yeah and just
paralyzed that b7 knight
and i feel like knight c5 feels like a
natural move i mean obviously there's
calculations to follow but knight c5
even even if you go knight e6 after that
and get to the vet opponents yeah also
e3 knight
i feel like knight c5 is a very
comfortable move
i
if i'm in white shoes one of the things
i'm always trying to do
is improve my pieces the knight on h3
we've already discussed that i'm not a
big fan of the bishop on d1 and i see
what you're saying
about the knight jumping to e6 so i'm
thinking
you know what that bishop on d1 it's got
to earn its oats
uh i want to play the move bishop to g4
to stop knight e6 and then again um
i'm still you know like if you went
queen g6 or something you know i still
like this whole queen d1 maneuver but
dorsa asked a very interesting question
aleandra that i want to put to you
did
hikaru miss an opportunity to play b4
did he do it right
miss would be a strong word at no point
at the engine really think that
a plus one position or something like
that strong fifa was one way of playing
the position the way that he's done it
was also a viable way it's a very
logical way it's a little slow because
you're going to have to take a lot of
time to remaneuver your pieces but on
the other hand you don't give yourself
certain weaknesses in some variations if
the knight got to a4 you got this move
e3 9694 sometimes c3 was weak so it
wasn't exactly
a super required move and you can see
with favi's move that the knight doesn't
always go to c5 he's played the move
queen g6 perhaps hinting at the move 96
now the engines don't like this move and
the reason they don't like it is the
move h4 it goes back to your ideas that
you had earlier of exchanging queens
that in this particular position because
the fact that we've mentioned king
safety a couple of times more for white
than for black and the fact that this
queen controls a lot of the dark squares
you want to just chop it off the board
and if you don't play the move h5 as
black then white will play h5 themselves
grabbing that space on the king side
moving this queen out of that side and
as you mentioned yasser bringing the
bishop to g4 which the screen on g6 is
currently preventing now if you do play
h5 which i think
is kind of sadly the only logical move i
see for black it does give up the g5
square but i don't think that you can
allow this queen to be knocked out of
the king side you trade
no real choices here and you go g6
defending the pawn it's still a little
unclear if white has that much the
engines are saying they white does have
them a lot but you have to start with
the move knight c6 to maneuver the move
knight e5 again you're trying to kill
the coordination between the rooks
somehow get them off the f-file you
still have the f5 square but remember
the g6 is hanging so 95 is a little bit
of a threat and the engines think white
is still better so your car hasn't
really spoiled anything it seems that he
got a slight edge from the position from
the opening and he's still nursing it
just in a different way than on b4
thank you for that alejandro just
clarifying i i see that pressure down
the f file
and i must say that the idea of h4 and
queen g5 was definitely not the first
thing
i was thinking about but on the other
hand like the move h4 if only to prepare
bishop g3 and knight f2 um
still it just feels like
awkward maneuvering ahead for both uh
players uh not so easy and you would
expect
in such a important game for our
tournament standings
that that these two would play a very
very difficult game uh strategically all
kinds of complexities dorsev now
queen exchange is very nice i'm not sure
if that would also be the first thing i
would think about but what about the
idea h3 bishop g4 because the bishop
would be really nice on g4 and if h3
it's kind of i feel like it forces black
to consider h5 more seriously i agree
i agree with you but then
okay you you you
you tricked me
you dirty rat pink you forced me to play
the move uh h5 uh
how do we exploit that can we exploit it
also what alejandro was saying
is that now that the queen is no longer
sitting on d6 we're
giving the knight
a different possible pathway into the
position knight d6 knight f5 i still
think you know at some point you're
going to want to play i don't know king
h2 bishop g3
get the knight coming to f2 this rook
coming to f1 is really disturbing
um
still a
very very tough fight i i favor
the minor pieces
but uh i do think that uh
fabi did it very nicely doubling his
rooks on the f-file making it awkward
for for hikaru
to make progress once again we're going
to just jump to the other two games see
if anybody's making progress anywhere
over the board and we do have
a lot of moves going on between
uh richie and duda kind of in a funny
way maybe a little bit mirror
if you consider the game of team or for
a moment you know there was a rook a2 by
the rook coming over well look at this
uh the rook comes up and the rook could
come over
and let's see how the players got here
we left it we've just seen a
double trade of minor pieces
he took with a pawn not so unexpected g4
okay so the rook and again we're seeing
this stein it's way of playing you know
clear
yeah the open the half open f-file
h5 how do you feel about h5
uh i see that move as a very provocative
move i i like uh
forcing my opponents to do things that
they might not necessarily want to do i
mean i'm thinking knight h7 would have
been a more sedate way of playing it
maybe to play knight f8 and knight g6
maybe to get the dark square over here
uh very provocative and maybe very good
actually because
if you don't play g5
um
we just wouldn't be very happy would we
i mean we've just kind of like
essentially we've kind of helped our
opponents
you know
gain some squares on the king side so g5
seems forced
look at this h4
knight h7 and that trade of h pawn for g
pawn i very much feel
is in duda's favor
as we have now just now caught up with
the players could you help me with the
clocks uh dorsey um any uh it's only 15
minutes
so dude is ahead 15 minutes
duda has 15 more years than his opponent
and
[Music]
whoa okay and we just see this this move
i like this
i
one thing i would be terrified i would
not
want to see this knight landing on my
doorstep with knight f6 to h
to g4 so i do like this move bishop h3
very much with the idea of trying to use
these open files now i like
black structure but do the dynamic do
you feel like the dynamic play you get
to go rook f3 you get to go rook g1 is
worth the slightly worse uh structure
see i like those rooks my problem is the
night the night doesn't feel like it's
doing anything i can't really see a
bright future for that night on c3 yeah
right i mean if i if i managed to do
like knight e2 move the queen knight g3
knight h5 yeah i like it but i'm having
a hard time actually picturing that ever
happening
so you did it so very well just now
[Laughter]
righteous you go knight to e2
you trade the bishops
you move the queen you go knight g3
knight f5 you put the knight on f5
and black's crying if the knight gets
there i'm happy but without the knight
and just the rooks i i don't think
that's that's worth the position okay
but i also from from everything i know
from um richard reports chess is he
likes it crazy and dirty so i think
that's what he's trying to go for
hopefully it will get interesting now
from black's point of view black is
sitting there saying i've got the better
structure in other words you've got upon
weakness out here and it's saying come
get me
if i'm in duda shoes that's why you like
black's position you see a pine pond
winking at you
all the time that's the way we play this
is the way we roll uh rook to e6 kind of
a rook up and over first of all because
i do want to disturb
whatever uh devilish ideas you have
of utilizing the g-file i want to try
to tie you down
to the weakness on h4 so rook e6 to h6
as you're trying to
double up your rooks on the g file i'm
going to try to hit this pawn on h4
battle of ideas i love it but my first
oh by the way look at that how's that
for cutie i like this move uh rook g1 uh
just uh hello
um
if richard can induce the move g7 g6
then he's very happy because then the
rook doesn't get to go over the rook up
and over no rover for you
uh
i like this move a lot uh rook g1 i've
missed it i kind of
played uh you had the other one
yeah well i i recaptured the piece man
we
checked
i like that move rook g1 very much
alejandro does it turn the tables
because a moment there ago
when i got the rook to h6 i was liking
black's position
now i'm not so sure i like black's
position after this
cute move rook g1 it was a necessary
move yesterday you guys were very
accurate if you take on h3 with either
ps rook e6 and rook g6 or h6 and white's
position is a disaster right inducing
the move g6 changes that because as you
mentioned the rook doesn't get the third
rank anymore now g6 is the best move you
could play queen f6 but after queen h3
because of the pressure with rook af1
you will eventually have to play g6
anyway so just go g6 right away you can
take with either piece it doesn't really
matter and you really want this pawn
yasir will go and take it king g7 and
rook h8 is the way to play the idea is
of course that when the knight leaves on
f6 and goes somewhere rook takes h4 will
finally be a threat the move h5 is just
too happy at the moment after rook h8
there's too many pieces on the h file
for white to really consider going into
these variations you could play the move
h6 but this pawn is going to end up
being a weakness more than it is going
to be a strength so we might as well
leave it on h4 the engine is still like
black a little bit after the move uh
either take on h3 and king g7 because of
this weakness on h4 this is kind of a
stalemate on the queen side yeah black
has more space but what are you gonna do
with it that moves a4 pawn takes doesn't
really help you b4 pawn takes the knight
somewhere doesn't really help black
either so this is stalemated you don't
want to play d5 as black and give
yourself weakness especially since b5 is
hanging so play is on the king side the
question is who has more pieces there a
lot of the times when this happens the
side that is better is the one that can
attack more weaknesses in this case that
would be the pawn on h4 but what also
ends up happening is that if play is
only on one side of the board you don't
have that many problems in keeping one
weakness defended and it gives richard
good chances to equalize now that is
what i said richard is the one trying to
equalize in this position gotcha
and as we prepare for uh our break um i
just want to remind everybody we've been
using just by the numbers
to talk about the odds and how
through each uh round of play how the
odds the winning percentages have
changed it's been a wonderful sight and
on the other side of the break we have
the gentleman
ty
who runs the site
to come in and explain the models and
how
we get all of these winning percentages
because right now
it's nearly a 98
certainty that one of the two players is
going to win the event
and how did we get the model that's so
certain stay with us we'll see you on
the other side of the break
cool okay
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of st louis slough attracts
students and professors from around the
globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slough
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament we've got one game already in
the record books as aneppo has made a
very short day of the office draw
versus dingler in which has given him a
full one point lead over his nearest
rival fabiano fabiano could catch him
with a win
and crazily enough bobby is playing
against hikaru and hikaru with a win
would secure his clear third position at
the moment lots to play for as we've got
three important games underway again
that one game's already been decided
look the game between ali reza and timor
sorry to disappoint you dorsa it's
boring it's boring uh
maybe slight advantage white but looks
boring to me the big game is hikaru and
hikaru
went into
i'm going to say about a 20 minute think
or so uh exactly here what's something
you were mentioning
yeah alejandro said
that in this position
it's not the first move that came into
my mind uh really i like this idea of
unwinding with h3 and king h2 but the
more you settle on it you go okay
h2h4 creating oh
no worries creating some
weaknesses
but at the same time
this queen on g6 is covering the g4
square i'd love to play bishop g4 just
love it would you like how do you feel
about the coin trade because we talked
about it a little before the break and
right we were talking about how the
queen trait would just feel a little bit
more comfortable for white overall
especially i think like i feel like
black's position is good but it's like
stuck good like black can't really
improve after that right but white has
all these nasty maneuvers and this is
just pieces dancing here and there
exactly a little uh prancing going on so
um
yeah one of the things i'm sitting there
thinking about if i'm in white shoes yes
i would love to keep the queens
especially if i had if i could bring my
minor pieces to knight square put the
bishop on g5 put the knight on g3 or f2
and so forth and so on and i'm a happy
camper but the truth is is that my queen
on d2 is passive playing the move queen
g5
i think my judgment would tell me that i
have to be a little bit better here as
white
maybe it's not all that it's cracked up
to be i still
i really don't like
allowing this rook ever to get to f1 so
maybe i would pull back with my knight
just for the
temporary
inconvenience of playing knight to e3
and then i could move my bishop to g3
and then i could play
uh
knight on h1 to f2 but dorsa we have a
very very special guest uh from a chess
by the numbers tai has joined us welcome
welcome welcome thank you it's great to
be here i gotta tell you up front ty
we've never met but i've been exploiting
you for an entire week i love your site
i love your models and your way of
writing and explaining
to the audiences
the uh
the winning percentages
and it's extraordinary that
after a single half of play
this most eagerly anticipated event it's
a near 98 certainty according to your
model
that uh napo or fabi will be the
challenger
so my narrative from the very beginning
of the tournament was that this is an
unpredictable tournament just about
anything could happen right and i'm
shocked that this happened
well put i think we all feel that way
yeah
yeah we all expected uh the unexpected
and right someone's gonna come out of
nowhere and instead just the two people
that have won it before
running away with it
yeah yeah dorset questions for type so
one of my questions would be like do you
take
like uh the whole game like would you go
over specific moves and compare them to
maybe engine moves or the expected most
like do you go move by move or do you go
game by game result by result my model
is result by result um yeah so i've
always kept the model as simple as i can
because i want to make sure that people
can understand where the numbers are
coming from
my ultimate goal isn't necessarily to
predict chess as perfectly as possible i
want to come
close so that it means something but i
really want to provide that context for
understanding as much as possible about
what's going on in a tournament
for the fans so a simpler model makes
that easier i think
so i use just the players ratings
live writing
and put a win draw and lost percentage
on each game from
and treat all the games as independent
and just simulate out all the unplayed
games in the tournament see who won
simulate it again
add ad nauseam until i have a large
enough sample size to see who won the
most of those simulations wonderful all
right ty what we're going to do is we're
going to bring up on our
screen
the
percentage
where things stand
after six rounds and could you explain
to us
why even though there's only a half a
point gap between fabi
and yan yan is almost
two to one favorite over fabi at this
exact moment and they have to play
uh they have a date with destiny in
round nine
that's going to be the huge game of the
tournament but
so the reason he's that big of a
favorite is because he's got that half
point lead um
one of the things i like about the model
is it helps us figure out how important
something like half a point is or isn't
when it might not be completely
intuitively clear right and what the
model is telling us is that a half point
is more than it feels like even with
seven rounds left the fact is he's ahead
so fabi has to outplay him in the second
half
and in fact if if bobby wants to win
outright he has to outplay yon by a full
point over the final seven games
uh if they if if fabi outplays him by
half a point
they still have tie breaks and if they
play equal to each other through the
final seven games yawn's through
so that's where that two to one edge
comes from
okay ty this is not going to be
intuitively obvious for our audience in
round seven
fabi
won
right
yep i know where he is and his
percentage went down
it did
whereas jan won and as you would expect
his percentage went up but went up
tremendously explain why
because of who they were playing uh fabi
was
supposed to have a good chance of
winning that game against timor again
yeah he had white against the lowest
rated player in the tournament the model
thought he was likely relatively likely
to win that game a draw is always the
most likely result of a game but he had
good winning chances okay so his
expected score for the tournament didn't
go up that much by winning right yawn
won a tough game as black
he improved his expected score by more
so he gained and extended his lead in
that expected score at the end category
and all fabi's win was enough to do was
to keep pace
he did lose percentage even with a win
but keep in mind if he had drawn that
game he would have dropped to like 16
so the win was still way better than a
draw would have been it just wasn't good
enough to actually improve his odds
because the player ahead of him also won
he won and he still wasn't good enough
what else did you want from the guy
you wanted him to see john lose
there you go you got to win your games
and we've actually seen that throughout
the tournament welcome tied to the
conversation where players go check out
the other opponent's boards and they're
disgusted by what they saw when nepo
checked out favi's game against ali reza
and favi already had an extras exchange
nepo was cruising through duda he looks
at the game and just makes a grimace
like man this guy's still on my heels i
can't shake him off and yes absolutely
it does seem that favi's most important
to keep pace but nepo's results
especially with rapport with the black
pieces just catapults them in the
numbers
i mean yeah that's that's why uh
why nepo is the two to one favorite on
half a point
like to if we wanted to go with an
extremely impossible example if they if
bobby could win his final seven games
we've seen him do it before
and it wouldn't be enough if nepo won
his last seven they play each other so
technically that's not possible say they
draw their game and win each win etc
but the point is bobby can win as much
as he wants but as long as nepo keeps
winning there's nothing he can do about
it
um it's the thing about the round robin
or the double round robin format
you only play your opponent in two if
you're neck and neck with one other
player like this you only play them
twice and the other 12 games are against
other players and it's what you do
against those other players that will
decide it
wonderful tai i
once again i just want to say thank you
so much for taking time out of your day
and joining us and once again i want to
say how much i personally enjoy your
site i love it i mean wake up in the
morning i go i like your
writing style and making it a very
simple to understand how can
the chess world support your efforts
so i do have a paypal donation link on
my blog
[Music]
chessnumbers.org
and
has that link i also have a patreon page
i will admit i do not post any
subscriber exclusive content i intend to
but it just doesn't happen
but it's still a way uh if you wanted to
subscribe there just to support the work
that i will keep doing there's that
other than that read the blog follow me
on twitter i do a lot of stuff that's
twitter only for smaller tournaments uh
the candidates all write 1500 words
every night and put out full articles
and all the explanations but for a lot
of other tournaments i'm still
calculating odds and i'll just tweet the
screenshots of those odds and leave it
at that so follow me on twitter at chess
numbers is a great place for a lot of my
content that isn't anywhere else
and
yeah just following and supporting is i
really appreciate it it means i can't
tell you how much it means to me to hear
you say that you're reading reading the
work i've been following you for ages
and you're just a huge inspiration for
me so i really appreciate it
and ages and ages and ages i get it i
get it todd thank you very much
but thank you for all the good work and
uh
really appreciate a question yeah i was
we were wondering um
well what are your experiences with
chess do you play regularly
i have been
an on and off chess player my whole life
i've always loved the game but whether
or not i'm playing it all has sort of
come in a couple waves
i've loved the game since i was seven i
inherited a huge chessbook collection
from my grandpa and
taught myself
to love the game from those books i
really never i read them like novels i
never really like studied them with a
board very much so i didn't actually get
that good but i
fell in love with the game
uh when i was 17 i found the concept of
tournament chess for the first time
played for a couple played a few
tournaments over those couple years then
lost some interest
then came back in my late 20s and got
involved in tournaments again the last
tournament i played was in 2014. i got
my rating up over 1500.
and i'm actually
pretty sure this summer i'm going to be
back over the board for the first time
again i've been doing a lot of study at
home over the last year or so and i'm
hoping that i've improved and that i can
go prove it
well go get em tiger and again thank you
so much for uh joining the conversation
absolutely thank you cheers
nice nice that's chess by the numbers uh
do read his blog as uh tai uh
has been keeping us
up to date with
each round how that impacts
the winning percentages please the
screenshot was in your email
about the percentages that i got this
morning
yeah you actually read the evening so
you're the one who really know you
very good that's the confirmation i was
wondering who did it
i mean tom and the production team
forget them
forget about it trash
h2h4
by hikaru and my goodness
is now fabby's turn to burn a clock
as five minute difference if my math is
coming yes yes that's worth two pounds
according to your coach right
20 minutes is worth a pawn it's
alejandro jump in here what's happening
to
fabi
i'll start by saying i love the numbers
i love what they bring to us the
statistical models they're very useful
when it comes to actual moves there are
some intangibles hikaru is a very
dangerous opponent when somebody angers
him over the board and you can make sure
he is angry with favi for killing his
chances early in the tournament beating
him in round one and hikaru is here to
prove that he can still fight and
remember second place might be a world
championship spot we don't know that yet
so he wants to knock favio h4 excellent
move it is just so good to kick out the
queen from the king side that it is
worth weakening a few squares why
because you have the pieces to cover
them the bishop on d1 does a wonderful
job of covering anything that a pawn
would have covered on h3 now for the
moment h5 is a huge strategical threat
the engine's screaming you gotta stop it
you gotta play the move h5 and now
hikaru with a couple of ways to continue
we saw the move queen g5 as one of the
ways to try to put pressure on black's
position but it's not the only way you
can also play a move like bishop e3 and
slowly try to get out of this hole
you're in you can throw in a check if
you felt well that's not a check
close
enough
rook f1 check but it doesn't do very
much i can just go king h2 i can trade
the rooks and then go king h2 you can
even infiltrate by doing this
and this
and then what
knight g3 is coming knight g3 is coming
kicking out your rook you kind of have
to prevent that by playing queen f6
hitting this but even in this position
where it seems like black is just about
to get there
you realize that you have nothing
this rook very pretty but it's after
knight f2 it loses coordination with the
queen the knight is very far away from
the king's side and this king just feels
safe white is essentially saying you've
run out of attackers
uh let me interrupt you to tell you that
h7h5 was not
uh fabi's move in fact he just threw
down the move knight c5 inviting h5 take
it from here
what happens next alejandro i think
bobby's doing a favi thing when he feels
uncomfortable in a position he tries to
use the dynamics of the position to
solve his issues okay in this case after
the move h5 queen
runs away but where uh f6 is in the way
of the rooks i guess d6 but i'm always
worried that bishop g3 hits me for free
right let's put it on d6 anyway because
i guess rook f1 at some point and let me
develop yes i love that move bishop g4
we've been talking about this move
before it dominates the knight right it
doesn't allow this knight to trade
itself for the knight on d4 not sure
that i wanted to do so but even if you
felt like it now you can't the knight
can't really move because bishop e6 so
you don't have that many useful moves
white is going to continue bishop g3
you're gonna go king h2 you bring your
knights out and at some point you
realize bishop stuck your knight's not
very good and your rooks are doing not
that much on the file congratulations on
your open file they don't have targets
down on the first rank they don't have
targets or access to the second rank and
black feels very uncomfortable the
engines already say decisive wide
advantage they love white's position
here after the move h5 and bishop g4 no
matter where the queen goes and at some
point i i feel that 5 is going to go
desperate and play something like the
move e3 and put the knight on e4 where
it's finally useful the issue the moment
you do that
white regains the f3 square right and
i'm going to be able to stick a knight
or a bishop just stifling these rooks on
the f file and if you're not playing for
the move e4 giving me
the square on e4 for the knight i ask
you again where is your knight going
it's not going to go to e6 because this
bishop on g4 is going to make
sure it never reaches that square so
again black is the one that has problems
with coordination his pieces look pretty
but don't do anything well that whole
that sequence you showed h5 queen d6
bishop g4 e3
queen takes e3 alejandro if you put it
on your board yeah of course you don't
have to play e3 but of course no
there's always that bishop e6 move so
queen takes
e3 knight e4
bishop e6 is gonna really uh hurt your
feelings that's gonna really hurt your
feelings buddy even bishop f3 is winning
also right it's just the straight the
strategy of the position that you don't
have enough pieces right you just don't
have enough pieces and of course bishop
e6 picks up the exchange black design
yeah
yeah
so uh for a huge huge gain for our
standings and
not just for the revenge or things like
that but just this idea that there's
going to be this enormous fight for
maybe
a second place uh hikaru's fans are
saying whoa we got something going on
here and i don't know if we have h5 on
the board yet it's just it is on the
board yes yes and finally down to 18
minutes to make 13 moves of chess okay
guys
nepo is going there like let's go hikar
you can do this you can do this right
just watch my really running away with
it yeah not not my nearest rival down
and once again
uh help me out with the time differences
uh dorsa uh well naka has
over like uh 61 minutes so okay that's a
lot of times
17 and 17 minutes and queen d6
not a lot of uh good-looking squares for
the black queen and he chose d6 we like
this bishop g4 a lot
just stopping 96 not that exactly 96 is
necessarily a great move but just
bringing the bishop off the first rank
controlling some nice squares and as
alejandro was mentioning you put the
bishop on g4 you start putting the
bishop on g3 you really feel you're
taking over exactly all the all the good
squares
uh are being possessed by white so this
is just huge a quick gander
oh by the way we went on break and i'm
not kidding
duda came up with a move i never
considered yes before i move on i just
wanted to quickly mention that
uh tomorrow is supposed to be the huge
caruana um nepali nepal niagara matches
so that that's that's still you know
it's still not all the way over even if
everything goes wrong and hickory here
is tomorrow what you're talking about
the date with destiny
as the two number one and number two in
the tournament bobby carl rowan with the
white yes
so it's still you know even if
everything goes terrible and fabi ends
up losing this game uh tomorrow he's
still just a point down if he ends up
winning
uh jan then he's back again it's six and
six and it will be a bloodbath
absolutely well round nine is uh
definitely boy we mark your calendars
folks you don't you do not want to miss
that game and we do have after h5 queen
d6 bishop g4
why not car was blitzing it out i guess
yeah they're paying off
uh bringing your bishop to a very um
attractive square where you're
controlling e6 uh the knight on c5 as
alejandro says kind of gets stuck you
don't want to lose an exchange to bishop
e6 in the meanwhile
white is now starting to think that
bishop to g3 knight f2 and i can deal
with a rook check it's just a check
ah you're not injuring anybody after i
finally found the word i was looking for
do it ornamental i kept thinking how's
the blacks pieces like they're good but
they're not doing anything what's that
word what's that word i've been thinking
about it like the past 10 minutes
yes
walter sean brown used to say pretty as
a picture
but not doing anything ornamental i'll
go with ornamental so pretty the rooks
are good you know the king white king
looks weird but there's no way black can
actually use any of them
so i'm i think it's
alejandro said it really well too
where's the targets in white's position
you put the bishop on on g3 you put the
knight on f2
there's no targets in
white's position b b2b
iv starts to look like a serious threat
your bishops are taking over and
right now
and you're feeling the clock as well oh
yeah so you're but you're you're in
fabi's shoes you're not happy about your
clock you're not happy about the
position
but he but what you've got to do
is try to calculate your way out of this
this is something you mentioned
alejandro that fabi is incredibly good
at
but even the calculators need to see a
force variation i don't see a force
variation which reduces white's pressure
is there one no i mean the best thing
you can do no in this position is go
king h8 wow just so that one day the
move bishop e6 doesn't actually win the
rook i promise it doesn't really matter
what he plays the more the engine thinks
the more he thinks he's just busted wow
the problems are strategical they're
long-term and they don't have a fix
sometimes you have a bad position and
you think well if i get a couple of
moves in
i solve my problems right but what
couple of moves do you
i'll let you play for free right play
play moves with black for free exactly i
pass i pass i keep passing with white
which i won't i'll improve my position
right but let's say that he did pass
how do you improve blacks
you pretty much maximize your pieces
right the bishop doesn't have a way to
return knight stuck advancing the pawns
does nothing makes no sense in fact it
makes no sense in fact it makes your
position weak i mean you can play h6 and
move the king i guess but it's such
minor improvements to very real problems
that you have in this position another
player with real problems
wow
and you can take a look at this visually
let's compare this position that you
have right now and check out for example
rook on f1 queen coming to h4 you can
see who's king's in danger right it's
blacks you have this open h foul it's
hard to
it's hard for black to fight on the king
side why there's a huge pawn on g5 right
well guess what
you put it you put it there man bishop
h3 takes rook g1 knight g5 well okay
thank you for the space right h takes g5
i'm not gonna have the open g file i
have the open h file much more dangerous
and the other variations we were looking
at with g6 stakes black has play on h
white has play on g we have this battle
of ideas on the king side in this
position that we have on the board it's
not a battle of ideas on the king side
um it's it's black
hoping that white can't double up on the
h file and win the game exactly so yeah
and the computers are saying
why it's
close to winning i don't think it's as
easy as the computer say it is not by a
long shot
but since play as i explained earlier is
not in the center and it's not on the
queen side it all comes down to
positioning on the king side and this
pawn is huge it's a huge pawn on g5
stifling all of black's play the rook
and go to f6 the queen can go to f6
enjoying this phrase the rook can't go
to h6
thank you for the pawn on g5 said
richard
wow
it just seems to be a day where white is
pressing in all three of the games that
we have
uh again uh for those of you joining us
late nepo made an easy draw is white
against dingleroon
and uh farouza better but
i'm still sorry to say i'm just like
drawn
to
this game of hikaru because it's just so
absolutely absolutely vital it would be
very nice to see richard or duda win a
game i mean and get off the schneid of
uh you know it's their maiden
experience and the candidates you come
to the candidates
first of all you're so proud to get
there you've achieved something
remarkable and then not to win a game
uh sorry i was just trying to put my
thoughts together it's their first time
right yes
so we have three players who have never
played in the candidates before and uh
wait a minute i know
for sure ferugia for sure and duda for
sure so though those are our three and
richie
yes richie uh and uh duda so um
from those players they they want to
come and say i belong in this tournament
really
how many did you win
uh if you can't give a number if you go
zero you go uh-uh you don't belong uh
you were just you were cannon fodder for
these guys i've had those tournaments
that i have however i do i just can't
win i'm just draw draw draw draw draw
i'm happy frustrating yeah i like even
if i get like plus three and it's just
for some reason it just ends in a draw
so i i completely feel their pain
hopefully it will change there's still
six more rounds left exactly now bishop
g4 and uh
you know
alejandra has been saying that
fabby at 2800 is one of those players
who is
[Music]
at
calculating deep
long forcing variations and saving
awkward to difficult to impossible
positions
and i said okay the challenge is
where's the forcing sequence and
he doesn't have it and sometimes the
best thing you can do
literally is nothing you pass and you go
look i can't improve my position
my rooks are good my queen sorry please
go oh no i'm just uh i just wanted to
clarify from myself and sure viewers um
so fabian has 10 minutes
and counting no increments no increments
for the next 11 moves till move 40
that's correct
oh boy he's better
and it's really scary because yes well
white wants to play pawn h6 white wants
to play bishop g3 white wants to play
even pawn b for white wants to do all
kind of weird freaky stuff so i'm i
exactly exactly exactly uh
what white's the one who's sitting there
saying
my goodness i've got all of these ways
of improving my pieces
maybe even something as simple as queen
e3 uh the queen might be better on e3
going i don't know the h3 maybe queen to
g5
all kinds of ways for white to improve
his position
a after
i don't know exactly maybe 10 minutes
somewhere in that ballpark h7 h6 after
eight minutes i'm corrected
h7h6 and uh at a certain moment this
bishop is going to come to g3 this
knight on h1 dreaming of jumping back in
the game going to go to f2
by the way
exactly in this moment i find myself
irresistibly drawn i don't know why
i was just thinking about it because
when b4 i feel like black would have to
blitz out amazon that's the only option
exactly
again you want to play b4 so precisely
the i can't i mean
black has to come up with a way in the
remaining nine minutes to stop b4
which seems very impossible to achieve
or let b4 happen and accept bishop e6 so
i'm just
i'm just feeling
not happy
about fabby's chances now before the
move h7h6 i just wanted to say
that aleandro said
if you can't calculate and find a
forcing variation that saves you
sometimes you just have to make a move
like king h8 and go with the flow and
say okay give me your best shot i i
can't improve my position i don't know
what i'm supposed to do is again i know
he's thinking about pawn h6 for white
because if if punish sticks and if
that's the big diagonal a1h8 gets opened
up then it's easy for white to just put
that bishop in there and just
you know sit back like this and look
into faba's eyes
that's not gonna be a very
okay but uh you know me i i'm a pawn
grubber are you free yeah you kind of
you you may be
you you may be doing it though what
you're saying is you put your pawn on h6
with the purpose
of putting your bishop on the long
diagonal
now if you could get a situation like
this where
your bishop is about ready to traverse
to d4
[Laughter]
you got it you got it
and uh
why is karu playing mad
oh yes look at that big fat donut on
round one you know who that was against
i can only imagine it was against pappy
you're right yes
so that's what that's about but in truth
uh if hikaru name may not be completely
happy with this tournament but he's in
there with a shout
potentially to get to the second place
and
if he could
get get there
magnus decides whatever his issues are
that he doesn't want to defend the event
and this is the line-by-line score
what a beautiful score if he won the
first round he won the last two rounds
but i don't i don't think it's going to
work out for him the remarkable thing is
when you look at nepo's line-by-line
score nepa is not only leading the
tournament but look what he did in the
last four rounds
he is going to score an extraordinary
three and a half half he's going to
score three wins
in one draw from the last four rounds
wow wow that's amazing it's amazing well
uh back over to you alejandro as we're
sitting here we're looking at a hikaru's
uh position it's sort of like we're
sharpening our knives and we're saying
we really really like hikaru's position
absolutely and dorsal mentioned the move
h6 favi stopped it it makes a lot of
sense you guys were mentioning b4 it's a
good move takes days you renew the
threat of going before if you play king
h8 allowing b4 this knight's not really
going anywhere the edges are saying you
know give up a piece
what knight a6 allow bishop e6 taking
the rook remember it's just an exchange
but when you have two minor pieces for a
rook and you're in an exchange you're
actually winning a piece but you do get
the b4 pawn back and you're saying i
finally have moves the angels are of
course saying this is winning for white
but that it will take some care hikara
played the top engine move which is the
move queen e3 and instantly fighting
replied with queen f4 trying to get this
queens off the board taking advantage of
the fact that bishop e6 is not quite
ready perhaps this he feels gives him
the best chances of survival
of course queen takes f4 is the most
natural move in the position you can
even take a pawn
because bishop e6 check cannot be met
with knight takes e6 thank you for the
fork on the rooks remember that f2 is
defended by the knight
so that picks up a pawn and it's an
important pawn because after bishop
takes d5 this bishop is good this knight
is still dominated and you haven't
really improved your position suddenly
you have another target on e4 material
is dwindling as well for black remember
that he had two pawns and a rook for two
minor pieces now it's only one
the position doesn't quite collapse
fully yet
but this is pretty close to it yeah that
that's a very very big step in that
direction that move bishop d5 check i
mean
every fiber of my being
wants to get that pawn
and the fact that it's a fork and
there's no knight takes e6 i mean i
would uh leap
at such an opportunity it this really
really feels very good and once again
the players are not going to get any
increments uh until they get to move 60
they're still trying to make the first
time control
fabi uh under pressure on the position
on his clock any karu's fans are just
fingers crossed i do have a question
about this position after queen f4 now
considering the time difference and
considering that fabi needs to play 10
moves with nine minutes um would it be
favorable for hikara to keep the queens
on the board sure one of the one of the
rules of thumb
is easy on the opponent right when your
opponent's suffering on the clock don't
simplify the position
on the other hand if simplification is
the fastest way of getting you to your
uh promised land a victory by all means
queen f4 bishop e6 check take i hear you
the other problem though is avoiding the
queen trade with maybe a desirable move
like queen
uh h3 you always have to be
wait wait a minute did i open up
uh the possibility of queen d2 and
counter play never never never want to
give our opponent counter play when
they're low on the clock so
yeah that queen d2 move is is
is a more than a little off-putting i
i'm kind of a little bit surprised
there's no way to exploit the fact
that this knight on c5 is
for all intents and purposes hanging you
know just in in mid-air like did you we
don't have a way of doing anything with
that that's like
you you think you would but yeah i like
this queen f4 i like going for the pawn
uh very very much
how about the other players
we we left it
richie's
queen
this is a very interesting game for me
because i also wanted to ask alejandro
while he the few moves back when we were
still talking like when did black go
wrong because it's still like knight g5
field was it
that was it
but like what else to do the the what
else was
uh the pawn on h4 is weak yes the pawn
on g5 is strong it's really that simple
so g6
queen takes h3
king g7
prep
the move rook h8 knight will come to f6
and this pawn will be weak that's
that's
let's say small advantage black
the problem with the game continuation
is exactly what has happened this h file
has suddenly become open
what is that rook doing on e7
bingo thank you and that is exactly what
alejandro is saying that pawn on g5 is
limiting the rook on the rook wanted to
go to g6 that actually wanted to go to
h6
and right now i think both kings are
going to get on their tennis shoes and
start running uh maybe the king will go
to f8
and from white's point of view you go
rook h juan king g one and
you make a b-line
right
yeah d
you know what a king walk is right you
voluntarily make a king walk that you
every player usually has a favorite game
of theirs
where they make a king walk for me
i've had multiple blitz games that i've
managed to do that's beautiful walk but
i can't think of a specific classic game
that i did that okay but we'll work on
it i've had to try it i i mean we're
gonna make a update bruce harper and i
are going to make an updated version and
we're looking for great king walks
alejandro i'm sure you mentioned a game
where you attacked your opponent's king
from g1 to a1
all the way back but how about you just
making a voluntary king walk oh yeah
yeah i love these close positions and
i'm a very boring player so taking 10
moves to move my king to a slightly
better position definitely done that
guys i want to draw your attention
please to sharpness when you have a
tournament that feels right you play
accurate moves you see the nuances and
when you don't man it's just like
everything
doesn't even matter it's mud it's mud
you don't see clearly you don't see
tactics you don't solve your problems
and both alireza firuja and timor
rajabov
they're in a deep hole
in this moment precisely white's doing
very well we talked about the knights we
talked about how alireza can improve the
angels are saying it's time to finally
play the move d4 it is ready uh you have
defended e4 sufficiently you can also
say this queen is kind of annoying on
the diagonal kick it out with the move
b5 all of this is good you can also
think all right move the king to g1 and
you were thinking well why not rookie 3
of 100 didn't you say that rookie 3 a
long time ago uh solidifies your
position right yes it does another as i
said thought yeah that's a good move he
played rookie 3. the problem at this
exact moment timor has the following
sequence that solves all of his problems
knight takes h4 check
whoa pawn takes
check
k1 you sacrifice tonight but guess what
where's that one going it's a nice night
trap so you'll just exchange pieces
but check out that night yeah yeah yeah
i like that night i like that that is a
good night on f4 white is the one that's
gonna have to try to equalize from this
position because his king size fell
apart right his king side fell apart he
has to take on e5 bring the knight to g5
and hope the knight on g5 is enough glue
to keep his position together because
while the knight can retreat to g6 and
attack h4 the rook can come to f4
timor didn't do it
no
he is
rookie 3 he played b5 the knight came to
f3 now the knight has h2 as a resource
this knight f4 was missed it would have
solved teamwork's chances he's back to
being in problems clearly they're not in
shape you can kind of understand that
they've somewhat mentally checked out of
this tournament neither of them with any
shot actually these statistics by just
by the numbers gives rajabov a very
pretty zero percent chance of winning
this tournament right
i would take great pride in the idea
that i would see the move knight h4 why
because for me when you look at
alejandro's position with that knight on
f4 it's a god yes that's such a powerful
knight and the fact that i can trade
the knight on g6
for a knight
in this position on g4 so
really one of the moves that i would be
looking at is knight f4 check
and which is the same idea exactly and
then to play h5 so
for me this this sequence
of trading
one night for another but at the end of
the day i end up with the night on f4
i mean you know that is just
yes
thank you doris
just what i wanted to hear you're
absolutely right and yeah when it's not
going well you miss these little little
opportunities what uh our predecessors
would call the petite combinations the
the small combinations and that was a
really nice one a very very big miss and
if both of these players were in form
they would both catch that so
the way you're explaining it kind of
made me think about it's not just about
their strengths or weaknesses and
justice mainly about the psychological
um aspects of the situation
yeah their mental acuity and kind of
what uh alejandro was saying it's not
like the players have checked out
but their disappointment they kind of
lost that that as as ambitious as they
were
well a week ago
right what they say in in in maverick
they've lost that loving feeling
i mean
it
from the start of the tournament they
might have seen uh such a variation at
this point where
they're kind of groggy with the lack of
success uh wow uh but that was a very
very nice uh missed opportunity thank
you for that alejandro uh back to fabi
again
uh
he went for
this whole line looks similar but there
is a difference in the position yasser
oh the knights got traded what
no i like the knight on d4 it is a
strange decision because right bishop e6
it's not like he could take on e6 with
the knight nope
no it just instantly loses and the
question would be would you rather have
this position that you have on the board
right now
right with the knights or without the
knights oh for me there was no question
that i felt
that the knight on c5 was a tactical
target versus the feeling that the
knight on d4 was excellent
beautifully anchored on the d4 square
perfect in fact so
when i'm having the minor pieces the
more miners the better yeah okay
the the worst thing i want
is everything traded off and it's just a
straight rook versus bishop at night i
would like more pieces
queens more pieces
no no i just realized because the move
rook f5 was played that if that knight
was on d4
that wouldn't have happened either so
white could have kept the h5 pawn in
that case
exactly this knight on d4 not only
as you say
hitting e6 but also defending f5 which
means that after for example check takes
the game the move in the game uh that
we're about to experience would not be
available because of the knight of d4
very important question please that's
knight on d4 yes would you would you
rather that knight on d4 or the other
potential knight on f4
the knight on f4 was so good and the
reason why i love the knight on f4
versus the knight on d4 is in that
particular case of the duda game with
the knight on f4 there's an exposed
white king
and that knight on f4 is going to make
white's life very very difficult um
but fabi
uh clipping that h-pawn
kind of helps him breathe new life into
the position uh in my view
um two and a half minutes five more
moves
still think white's for cheering it's
bad for him that it's still very bad for
fabiano caruana more than a two point
advantage more than two even i didn't
guess it was that high i wouldn't guess
it either if i saw this position i would
think of course i take white i like the
pieces and i like the blockade
but
where's where's white's plan
well he just found a very good square a
very good square for his bishop he's
played the move bishop d4 as a prelude
to either knight g3 and knight takes e4
there's going to be no rookie 5
and or knight 10 f2
i like that again you say it's a
two-point advantage yes that's right
two-point advantage the thing is wow
black pretty much loses e4 by force
you're not gonna be it's a big loss it's
a big loss you're gonna not gonna be
able to keep your rooks alive for the
moment you actually have to be a little
bit careful as black because knight g3
id has already trapped this rook
remember that you don't want to get
skewered rook g5 bishop e3 so you're
running out of squares for the rook you
want to return this guy to the f5 as
quickly as possible but what happens
knight g3 you can go back to f8 i can
immediately start thinking about
capturing on e4 but the engine says you
know what you're going to be able to do
that whenever you feel like it so it
makes some preparatory moves the place
bishop b7 tries to induce you to go a5
it doesn't take right away
right but it does say that you do take
eventually and it is two minor pieces
against the rook and we know how strong
they are now do i as a human think that
it's easier conversion when your
opponent h5 was alive i think so but
does it spoil anything the engines say
no
nice i'm just being told that the live
shot of the caro
is normally hikara is always scowling
and
the the pain
the drama the ethos but apparently at in
madrid he's actually
this is easy life is so good he seems to
be enjoying himself one of the moves i
didn't understand uh alejandro help me
here
is after the move rook f5 which we
understand hits the bishop hits the pawn
it's not that i want to take the pawn i
really do want to take the pawn but why
didn't he put his bishop on b7 instantly
and then get the same position as the in
the game where he's always giving
himself the opportunity to i don't know
maybe it's he's going to capture the
bomb was bishop
b7 better than bishop c6
yes
nice you're pawn
for the go play it was just a better
place for the bishop i'm actually really
curious on why he didn't go bishop b7
it's a nice tempo i mean you could take
it is not gonna kill you right right now
he's returned to bishop to b7 bishop b7
was just much easier he must have seen
something that he really liked down the
lines of bishop c6 but the end just
agree with you yes there's a reason you
worked in those candidate tournaments
yourself bishop b7 is just a better move
than bishop c6 again the engines are
thinking that the position is so
dominant that multiple moves keep the
evaluation about the same now when it
comes to precision i think bishop b7 is
just making your life a lot easier the
engines don't even think that you have
time to take on h5 forces to move a5
anyway
that being said
no way to defend the h5 pawn so you will
have to give it up at some point right
but okay
and we now have three minutes and 30
seconds for fabiano caruana to make only
four moves of chess it shouldn't be the
hardest moves in his life because well
there's immediate threats on the rooks
you need to defend the rooks i think
rook hf5 is almost an automatic deal the
engine move the second best engine move
is e3 i don't think anybody even thinks
of that move
no do you no not really right no so i
expect rook hf5 to come on the board and
he's gonna suffer for a while in a very
difficult position i don't know
practically if he has good chances of
saving i don't i don't think so i think
practically it's just so much easier to
play for the white side and objectively
the engines are loving it right well
like you said the there is a problem
that this rook on h5 is running out of
moves because this move bishop f2 to d
like one of the things as black you
might be thinking about is that when the
knight does make it to g3 you'll play
the move rook e5 you'll defend e4 life
is okay
the move bishop d4 simply took away the
square e5 and now you start to think oh
you know railroad knight g6 rook g5
bishop e3 i could blunder in exchange i
better play the move rook f5
and
using some played action yeah you you're
using some time on his clock fabi
eventually agreed but same move faster
was better now again just a few moves to
make
uh for the time control to be two and a
half minutes right
now okay here i don't think there's any
question that you want to stop rook f1
and knight g3 comes with a tempo
uh not only does it defend f1
it attacks the rook
and virtually forces the rook to drop
back now as alejandro was saying this
pawn on e4 is going to fall
you don't have to be
eager it's not going anywhere
so you could potentially
consider ideas of a4 and the
the like
but
i'm a pawn grubber if i just take it
alejandro yeah it's fine
and
i'll trade bishops if you like if i can
take it with the bishop
you don't have rook e7 that's important
i don't want to see
this move because i have a discovered
check
exactly that makes life
but then you talk about two minor pieces
versus rook i haven't seen
minor pieces of this caliber
versus a rook in a long time the bishop
is superb the knight is superb it's
looking
this is
i would consider this winning i think so
too right as well now i have a question
about this there's i like when i look at
games i always want to know where things
started to kind of fall apart so from
what i remember the in favi's game his
was his opening was fine everything was
good i love the c5 i love those pawns
so i i can only think about when he
chose to play c4 versus e4 right i might
i think that was when well obviously i
have engine on you guys and we're
talking about it so it's much easier for
us to make that decision but for me i'm
i'm just kind of um trying to just
trying to understand like
would i actually play e4 instead of c4
if i was playing
but um
position and we we definitely looked at
this as an alternative but we said uh
queen d1 queen of schwab was scary yeah
this is not a piece of cake for
uh black either we are threatening to
take the pawn thanks to the fact that
we've got this nasty pin and if you did
something like king
[Music]
h-8 this move that alejandra pointed out
queen to d1 to h5 white is enjoying life
but doris is making a very good question
um alejandro was there a particular
moment where
the computer actually just
oops uh blunder alert blunder check did
he make a bad move somewhere that we
missed there's two moments that you can
take a look at the position the first
one will go back there the more
egregious one the engine does thing is
the move queen g6 and it's only because
of h4 great move found by hikaru
punishing the move queen g6 which
essentially lost him to tempe gotcha
because the pawn on h5 is nice right and
the bishop came to g4 the engine is
thinking that knight c5 still vanished
white but not as big
the
line that you guys were looking at here
to play e4 knight g5 yes king h8 we saw
queen d1 at vanish white as well but
remember there was a fourth draw
starting with the move knight a5 please
take my pawn it does require quite a bit
of calculation and no guarantee that
hikaru would have played knight g5 it
was just one of the alternatives he
could also play the move knight h4 the
game goes on complex position but the
knight on h4 compared to the knight on
d4 i think that's where we stop
analyzing and we realize which variation
black would rather play
on knight g5 you get scared of this if
you don't have an engine in front of you
because e4 is hanging but we saw this
simplification by force with the move
knight a5 hitting this bishop if you
move the bishop out of the diagonal then
knight takes e4 is no longer a threat
and going down the forced variation
now
no that takes here that takes on b3
this is a great variation
right off the board it was very wild
well
yeah i mean i wish i could you know
bring bobby here and ask him what were
you thinking but
that's that's a little hard to do that's
why we have confession boost no
confession moves uh at the uh
at the uh candidates i use one of those
confession boots um it was the first
championship i put i yeah i was playing
uh arena crush and um well i was i was
had a great position i think it was one
of the lines that i had prepared with
alejandro actually or it was another
teammate of mine that was helping me and
and i had a great position okay i know
my my position is good i love my queen i
love my pieces and i was so nervous and
i remember i that that confession is
still somewhere on youtube when i'm like
what did you confess that i'm nervous i
mean i
i lost but primarily due to the time
control for me and i just got so nervous
and she just played amazing in time
pressure
and like well she she can get it i i i
couldn't do it under time pressure and
sometimes you just gotta tip your head
yeah let's just uh come back to uh the
current position and again uh
the moves uh
did he do no that's our analysis i beg
your pardon uh that would have been we
are here we're expecting hikaru and
kara's got all the time in the world
while
well fabby is suffering with less time
uh how much time does
he have at the moment bobby has two
minutes and 43 seconds versus 30 plus oh
yeah i think it's almost 40 actually oh
my god 39 yeah yeah well we're expecting
the move knight i mean it's kind of hard
for me to understand why why uh
hikar is considering
well
is knight f2 really
i mean i want to
i mean i want to cover the f1 square
protect the f1 square from rook f1 i
want to do it with a gain of tempo i
play knight g3 because i really
do want to
force that rook and cover the square but
the more i'm thinking about it maybe
maybe hikaru pardon me is right
to consider the move knight f2 because
this rook is a little awkward isn't it
oh
that's
well instantly by the way fabi said i
don't care
you don't want to attack my rook i want
to get my rook out of there uh do rook
drop back well to be fair if um if
hikaru does take on e4 it would just be
a transposition true true uh but i think
what you know in a in a wonderful world
uh hikaru would like
to keep the bishops on the board as well
so for example he hikaru
may be considering the fact that it
would be nice
to sidestep
rook f1
so uh induce the move g3 pardon me play
the move g3 induce the move rook f3 and
now prepare knight takes e4
knight to g5 discover check picking up
this rook if i could get the rook to
drop back
i
haven't
uh had to trade light squared bishop i'm
just saying
yeah exactly when you have the two
bishops oftentimes you want to keep them
and what you said too if your prominence
in time trouble don't simplify
and make make your opponent's life a
little bit more difficult also just
look at this as a possibility
knight takes d3 you're welcome to munch
up my g3 pawn i'll attack the rook
and if you end up capturing with the
rook hello
this bishop this bishop monsters uh
so there there are reasons why
knight i i'm liking it i think knight f2
was a better decision alejandro than
knight g3 more torturous
yes more possibility they were
equivalent in both cases white has ways
to finagle the position in a way that
you don't have to trade so many things
right away okay i like your move g3 it's
one of many ways to keep the position
alive i was going down these variations
and yeah this is very strong g3 you just
can't play rook f3 the engines are
actually saying that you should take
with the e pawn and hope for the best
with this pass pawn but good luck with
that somebody believes this right
no rook f7 black is in a world of
trouble and i think proper technique
is to not trade down in this position
you could take on e4 right away but why
if you take with the knight i will be
thrilled to exchange a pair of rooks
this is good chess knowledge for you
guys out there whether you have two
minor pieces against a rook or you are
down the exchange in both scenarios it
is very often that is in the interest of
the person with only one rook to keep
that rook alive
and it's in the interest of the pair of
rooks to trade
uh one of the rooks off the board why
you gain a lot of momentum for having
only one rook against the pair of pieces
in an open board you can swing around
whereas the rook could just cover both
penetration squares by itself especially
if the bishop on d3 disappears so don't
play knight takes e4 because rook f1
comes in you could take with the bishop
and we think that it's a technically
winning end game
but why hurry do it in your easiest way
i like the move g3 the engines are
saying you should just retreat to
this rook on f5 and you could even
continue improving your position play
something like king g2 and only take on
e4 when favi made time control exactly
uh there was a legendary uh grand master
ben larson and i was very close uh with
bent and i played a
number of games
and in a post-mortem i made this
brilliant speech this great explanation
of why this was happening why this was
good for me and that was good for me at
the end of which ben looked at me in the
eye and said
nobody believes you
just absolutely
put me down
sometimes alejandro throws that back at
me that nobody believes you but i'm glad
he believed me in this case that knight
f2 and finagle this nice little way g2
g3 just make it that much more difficult
for fabi to make the time control and it
wow what uh uh
what a stunning
uh statement it would be if uh
if hikaru could win this game like
throws the tournament once again
in a complete spiral uh let's take a
look at the standings as a currently
with three games to go again jan and
ding laren have already drawn the game
that's it they're they're they're in the
duck house they're gone they're they're
they're out of here but fabi with a win
very unlikely as it might be could tie
you on yon sitting there
cheering hikaru on
go hikaru get to four and a half points
uh we all love you oh yes
what a what what a sequence that would
be wait a second were you the one who
chose hikara
as predictions oh yeah i mean
you see
usually i mean if you look at those
predictions once more you know you can
kind of get the sense of you know why i
dominate you know there's alejandro look
at his choice now you came in you chose
godzilla
very unfair
but you know
uh
you know
alejandro gets a participation trophy
now we far this is a this is extreme you
know like the broken clock being right
once every day you know
far usually nobody nobody pays attention
but
no maurice magnus right yes of course
who's going to win the candidate is
going to be magnus it's been a
surprising tournament guys i mean yes
seeing dingley rand fail at the
candidates for a third time in a row
it's like
dude well he's number two in the world
and he's done so great whether it be in
a sinkfield cup in all of these
competitions he's a guest of the
candidates
and he doesn't deliver he just doesn't
read yourself i was just wondering
in your opinion well what can dink you
know do better but we can come back to
that after because
we've got h6
yeah yeah yeah
me too uh sorry once again don't allow
the move rook f1 for some strange reason
i looked at knight h3
and i was thinking oh my gosh am i
losing an exchange rook f1
you got to move the rock either after f5
and then knight takes d3 would be
knight takes d3 this was uh that's
something we were also looking at and
the computer says you've got to pass
pawn on d3 and
nobody believes
now we're talking i'll take i'll take
the extra piece
that's all very nice and cute right and
you can do all of that
but first block the h5 pawn off the
board oh
if you go bishop e8 in this position oh
no
you can't defend it you can't trap your
rook on f4
you will lose it you go bishop i mean
among other ways i assume but that's
just trap that's just trap you go to h4
i go g3 and it's actually trapped
oh
why did he caro put his bishop on c6
dorsa ah yeah
e8 ideas yeah well boy talk about making
the bishop on c6 look good
no bishop e8 we've talked about the fact
that the e pawn is not running
you're not worried about e3 on almost
any variation
so you don't have to be rushing and the
pawn on h5 is a very
very tender target bishop e8
that's huge actually
that's that's game when we talked about
the technically winning end games with
the pawn on h6 yeah they were
technically winning but you still have
to win them right with the without the
power on h6 you just take it off the
board and throw it somewhere it's not
even a contest no then it's play on all
on one goal those those variations where
we had a knight on e4 bishop on
it's easy enough the computer's saying
plus five oh oh
oh dear well time trouble as as our
friend maurice ashley likes to say time
trouble makes a fool out of us all
and
fabi has not
made
many many mistakes in this event so
there's here and there
but h5 may be egregious
because of this move bishop e8
sometimes you overlook
such moves on your first rank right you
know when your opponent
plays a move like bishop you go oh
bishop e8 rook f5 bishop e3 my rook is
trapped
and that's all she wrote
this is kind of actually a funny story i
remember years ago i knew this kid who
would always like
like sit like this on the board so like
you wouldn't see his first right he
wouldn't see his because like he's just
sitting like this exactly and i remember
once i was playing him in a rapid
tournament and i tried to do a
background check but i couldn't reach
because
he was physically blocking it
but i think it's just kind of hilarious
how um
the back rank first rank it's all just
it's all falling apart exactly it's
falling apart four five hikaru's gonna
spot bishop eight in an instant right
not to mention the move h5 is just bad
this knight on f2 is very happy that he
has a square on g5 now truly i mean best
move in this position is probably h5 to
h6 right fabi's just not finding the
moves today he's not in his element he
hates defending these passive plan-less
positions another person that is getting
himself in trouble jan shishtov duda
take a look at what happened to his time
42 minutes here two moves ago played g6
16 minutes
okay
advantage disappeared they were now
equal rook h1 played almost instantly
because well that looks pretty nice
right can't i just checkmate you yes and
another long thing this one sorry this
one came quickly and then kg1 came and
said
f5 are you running
how does this help you right queen h3 is
coming
and i'm going to mate you
that's very clear ooh
rookish 6 looks pretty and you're
welcome to capture on e4 and transfer my
knight to the prime square f6
and i'm going to meet you
i mean
wow dude's position is falling apart
totally completely falling apart within
a few moves he
put his this spot on g5 and then he just
didn't know what to do and g6f5 just a
symptom of the position he has to find
moves just to barely scrape some kind of
survival
but blight's attack plays itself and
again rapport hasn't sacrificed anything
it's not that he needs to concretely win
something the attack is free right
that pawn on g5 is just uh
a bow in the throat the inter muscle
that drukshi one few moves ago was just
wonderful um
yes yes precisely right here
uh when i first saw that move i really
liked it tom knows this word
switch
i'm going to stay with intermission
hey look welcome it's your show dorset
you got to put your print you know
um
our our friend christian has the tag
line only time will tell but uh
oh i tried nice
also known as an inter mezzo one in
german and one in italian exactly
intermezzo just feels more like
you can you know like throw your fists
out there and say enter a muzzle
now most of my students almost
every single one of my students i always
tell them like on weekly basis you have
to do about 10 intermeso puzzles
doesn't really get the hang of it
to understand the controls yeah it's
just like it's something so easily
miscible because it's so you know
opponent takes you just want to take
back it's not it's you know it's
automatic but
if if that had happened we would not
have this position so
uh it's all uh richard after this move
king g1 we've just seen the move b4
again talk about moves that aren't
necessarily helping it's not like this
knight on c3 is any great shakes
driving it to a superior square well
thank you very much abab knight
likely maybe there's something even to
be said for knight d1 to f2 and maybe on
a good day this knight even gets to go
to g4 e4 it's all good do we even need
to move that knight
oh you think it's just mate i'm just
thinking but
yeah i don't disagree uh
alejandra was saying you know
get those
doggies moving uh
either queen h3 or rook
h2 and you're right dorset it might just
be me
we're going to take a very very quick
break because we've got time troubles
and stuff like that but we're going to
take a quick break and we're going to
see on the other side very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2022 candidates we have
two rounds in the books as jan versus
ding loren was earlier drawn but guess
what
somebody
other than yan and fabi and ikaru has
won a game yes finally richard rapport
has won
in his game against duda
uh in convincing passion as he gets his
first victory in the event
congratulations to richie it was amazing
the enter mezzo brought it home
well uh let's throw it immediately to
alejandro as we had a lunch break
we feel replenished alejandro what have
we missed
guys plenty let's take a look first at
how richie finished judah off because we
did leave this position
in uh
just about after i believe was b4 b4 b4
was played now we got the position and
there are many winning moves in here e
takes f5 was one door so you're missing
rook h2 wasn't the best move by the
engine it turns out not to be checkmate
because you do kind of escape still
waiting for white nice e-tex f5 was a
nice way to do so because after g takes
f5 that was played by duda pretty much
everything wins queen h5 not bad knight
e4 also pretty nice you cannot really
take here on uh e4 because now that the
f file is open for this rook i'm going
to follow this up with rook f2 after
i've played the move queen h8 or queen
h8 i'm going to go to f6 and play qriket
it doesn't matter you choose the way you
made your opponent duda wasn't about to
let that happen after the move knight e4
he just gave away that's it that's it
they don't want to suffer anymore due to
having a catastrophic tournament
in madrid just absolute disaster in
minus two a lot of people thought this
talented young player might be pulling
for a position you never know he might
give a surprise world cup winner he beat
magnus
not showing up in madrid he just got
demolished let's go to the key matchup
of the day this is hikaru nakamura
against fabiano caron a lot has changed
we left off with the idea of bishop p8
pick up the pawn and then reconfigure
the pieces
he could have done that the move bishop
pier moved the rook somewhere bishop
takes instead he played the move a4
opening up the queen side also a good
move in my opinion he could have done it
after plucking the pawn return the
bishop to d1 and then play a4 nothing's
going to prevent you from doing so
because the rooks they don't have any
real targets you can't play e3 black
position doesn't change right so do it
slowly but this is good enough h4 play
bishop e3 was played after something i'm
not entirely sure
why hicaro is blocking his path
to the e4 pawn right but again the
position doesn't change that much after
rook hf5 he played the mover okay one
and after something five played this
very clever move h3 and it's this
point that you could have snapped yeah
that is currently giving him a little
bit of play now what happens if i take
the pawn
the idea is clear rook f1
takes stakes king h2 and now that i've
discombobulated your pieces your
bishop's here your knights on the rim i
can play rookie one and suddenly
yeah and alejandra you were mentioning
before the break that how it's a good
idea for black to try and exchange off
one of those rooks exactly so nice
exactly so h3 what else can he do he
could take with a pawn but this opens up
your structure a little bit specifically
in this position again thank you for
putting the bishop on f3 on e3 you know
what is thank you for putting that
bishop all the way on a4 rook f3 comes i
attack this i go rookie one check then
take the bishop if you defend it check
this out right oh no
and the tables turn so you don't want to
take with the h-pawn the computers are
saying there's two moves that retain an
advantage one is clear and one is
decisive now remember we're talking
about a plus four plus five advantage
right going into the break now we're
down to plus two and a half
knight g4 is one just two side doesn't
make any sense to me
i would rather take the pawn but the
knight does defend the bishop on e3
which blocks the important passer so
here the move rook f1 doesn't come with
as big of an umph however you do trade
the uh the rooks and you get to get rid
of the g2 pawn win win for black the
correct move in this position for hikaru
nakamura
not the easiest move in my opinion it
does make a lot of sense you reinforce
the knight which allows you after pawn
takes g2 to not hurry and take this pawn
because again
we've been talking about the recap 3.
yeah here you go bishop d1
cover the f3 square and then you can
take on g2 slowly you're not going to
take this perhaps anytime soon
but you need this coordination between
your pieces to move for k2 in my opinion
a little bit hidden why are you playing
rook a2 because there's another threat
in the position if you play bishop d1
with the idea of covering f3 immediately
h2 check h2 check the punk keeps
marching forward it's funny because the
spawn could have been captured for free
and after king takes h2 which is forced
nobody is defending well somebody's
defending but it's insufficient defense
on the f2 knight and that is how you
come up with the move rook a2 defend the
knight defuse the move h2 and hikaru is
still in control
that being said
he was more in control he's letting this
slip a little bit he hasn't let it slip
to the point where five is fully back in
the game but he now has a move and an
important move to find i think
he will find it because it's a bit of a
necessity okay uh gh
it's not good because rook f3 you don't
want to trade the rooks what else can i
do h2 is too strong gotta go rk too now
hikaru he is famous for letting some
advantages slip
he i one of the most shocking
developments when i saw it was a game
that hikara played here at the sink
field cup against magnus carls and he
got this decisive advantage straight out
of the opening two bishops against the
rook nothing really much to say about it
and somehow he didn't win that one it
was one of the more spectacular games
that hikaro failed to convert he also
failed to convert against nepal from a
really really really nice position
earlier in the tournament earlier in
this tournament hikaru needs to ride his
ship the last couple of moves have been
inaccurate he needs to find the move for
k2 to give himself those winning chances
still very strongly alive in his favor
so still planning to play for
despite the fact that fabi was the one
in time pressure he's made this a game
thank you alejandro uh
i want to say a kind of
discombobulation of what hikaru has done
is bishop was great on d4 his rook was
good on e1
and he's moved his pieces
to poor squares so
not very eaten but not very nice
do you think it's possible that tikara
is just
you know he finally sees that okay i'm
clearly better and then he just blows it
a little because psychologically you
know i was able to relax
he didn't find it exactly he found it
nice he did find rick a2 and by the way
for those who of you who are joining us
a little late uh christian i had to go
off to a wedding
and uh not his own
and dorsa is so very kind to come and
replenish the ranks it's wonderful
wonderful to have you and so i wanted to
say once again dorset thank you thank
you for joining us
and you came during a very very eventful
round because
for us it has just been a two-man show i
mean up to this point it's just been
fabi
and
nepo
lapping the field
and then finally uh richard has joined
the party
and it looked for a while there as if
hikaru was just cruising towards victory
and he's made it a little awkward for
those of you who are joining us late
once again we do have two
games in the books jan made an early
draw with dingler in to cement his lead
fabiano's struggling but it was richard
rapport
who got the best of duda in a very uh
impressive way um to
make 50
that was a very very beautiful game i
think so far that's been just such an
amazing game that i will definitely be
showing to all my students in my lecture
so make sure to join
that's the other nice thing about
calling the action and events like the
candidates
all your lectures
you got material for the next few months
uh it really is uh extraordinary to me
that once you
i'm okay with what hikaru did
exactly at this point he's got his
bishop on a4 it was time
to come back
just some move like bishop c6
the rook is again
keeping an eye over the e4 pawn the rook
looks good to me everything looks good
he hikaru did have an opportunity of
spearing this pawn on h5 with the move
bishop e8 earlier but it's this move
bishop e3 and rook a1
these last two moves he's kind of
drifted away from the action and he
allowed as
alejandra has been explaining such a
beautiful pawn this move h3
can now disturb a white setup for all of
the reasons you don't want to allow this
rook to either come to f1 with a check
or to land on your doorstep with the
move rook f3 so we do have rook a2 on
the board
still big advantage for hikaru but not
the massive advantage he had
uh a move or two ago rook a2 on the
board i'm trying to decide would i want
to start would i want to just trade off
those h pawn i'm sure you would right i
mean you don't want to see this g2 pawn
lit exactly i mean knight takes and
check would allow just your king to go
so i mean
that's really an accomplishment this
pawn was on h6 bothering nobody and
somehow
it managed it's almost like
managed the impossible task of going all
the way up the board and capturing now
once you take on g2 dorsa
um yes white you're sitting there going
no
no no i'm not really
i'm not about anymore yeah i'm not a fan
of allowing this rook to drop in on f3
so i might just
start with the move bishop d1 to cover
up
and only take the pawn on g4
after i've stopped rook f3 and he did it
very quickly bishop d1 of course takes
on g2 bishop d1 on the board
the players are now in the second
time control
and help me out those probably has 45
minutes okay naka has a hundred and not
sorry an hour and 10 minutes so 70. so
uh naka has been ahead on the clock for
quite some time in fact from the opening
both players blitzed out their first 20
moves or so
and then it was actually
fabi going into the tank
on a number of occasions
and uh thank you for joining our
conversation we really like you to keep
us on our toes and we have something
from social media dorsa what do you have
for us
all right
twitter user
james
guymon okay
can the panel explain
practical strategy from
for someone like naca to win games
moving forward against players who are
less
incentivized to play for wins now that
they are not in a position to win the
tournament well so the idea that that
james has in his question is
you're playing
you're motivated yeah okay
because you're hikaru and you want
to win some games you're motivated but
your opponents aren't so what's a
practical advice
for you don't play four nights
and allow them an easy draw
um that's an interesting question i got
to think that one over alejandro jump in
uh practical advice for hikaru against
somebody's not as motivated as you
ikaro is a type of player that thrives
by putting himself in a motivational
place he likes thing having this project
he likes
what he brings to the board he likes
that in his mind he has a chance and he
has the attitude and i think this is
such a huge game
because if hikaru wins he's still in the
tournament right he still feels i'm in
the tournament i got a shot i need to
give it my best
but there are some players man that are
just falling apart right duda fell apart
oh he did
this dude at least if dude is leading
this tournament
he doesn't lose like this right he sits
down he figures something out but his
mind is already clouded
hikaru i think knows exactly where he
stands he currently knows that he has
practical chances against his players
and he is a very practical player
himself he likes taking these long games
against such opponents he mentioned
himself a game that he played against
vichy and on here at the singh field cup
i just wanted to play an equal but long
game and tire him out so you know that
he is preparing against opponents that
he's very capable on this long tiring
games where do you really want to sit
there as a duda on minus two play this
really long drawn out game where you're
maybe suffering a little bit for
absolutely nothing anymore yeah and uh
jump in on this particular game is it as
extraordinary to you as it is to my mind
for seeing a black pawn that was on h6
now sitting on g2 don't you sit there
and ask yourself
how did i allow that to happen
yeah it almost feels like something kind
of went wrong and the angels are saying
no problems white's still winning not as
much as before but still winning but it
certainly has that feeling right right
that this pawn shouldn't have ever made
it not even close not even close to g2
it looks like a typo right it looks like
a misprint that this should be a white
pawn
right and somehow this pawn it just kind
of marched right it didn't like have any
fancy tactics or it just marched right
it just went h5 h4h3 and took
now it's still very difficult for black
to defend the position the spawn on a6
is very very weak the spawner g2 will be
plucked at some point and the bishops
are doing a fantastic job at keeping the
rooks out of the important squares which
is the important square right now that
square on f3 so for the time being it's
difficult for black uh to retain his
position i think the move knight rook
five of six would be my choice so just
so i hold on
to a4 sorry a6 right uh but here white
can start improving and again it likes
rerouting this bishop to where it was
it's a very nice controlling bishop it
controls a lot of squares maybe on a
good day i can also drop to c8 and pluck
that pawn on a6 and once this becomes a
passer
then we start thinking about the clear
plan for hikaru to convert his advantage
make this into a queen it'll cost black
a rook because no way this bishop is
getting back to defend against that
right and that is just going to be the
end of the game so still incredibly
difficult for fabiano to figure out a
way out of this one it's possible that
he doesn't have it that he still has
this well within reach
but not the cleanest technique so far
thank you for that alejandro
question this magnus carl yes
magnus is definitely definitely
definitely watching did you have any
practical advice for
jim that we can share
with uh hikaru as well like what do you
do
when you know you're playing opponent
who's not doing that good in the
tournament and maybe they just want to
get out of the event how do you keep
them and take advantage of the
i think a huge a huge part of it of
course is the opening choice but there's
certain openings that you know like by
this time in the tournament you know
your opponents have already you know
tried out and didn't like or it's just
not their style or just not comfortable
in so what i would do if i'm when i'm
playing you know tournaments that is a
few round in is i would go back and
study the games that opponent played so
far and then just try to figure out
what is the thing that they're not
liking in this tournament because you
know for example duda didn't really seem
he just kind of completely fell apart
in a if i'm not mistaken it was quite
even a few moves before that sure it was
so for me i would like always try to go
for that specific weaknesses that
they're showing right away
so i wouldn't necessarily say you know
super killer sharp opening but
not four nights that's much i will say
so
a big part of your uh of how you
approach i also think it's a um
mental uh game in the sense that
for me uh chess
really has a lot to do with confidence
when you're confident and you're playing
well you're really looking forward to
the game
and you need
to come to the game with this mental
fortitude
we're going to be playing a long long
long game i'm going to want to win
and i'm going to grind you down and if
you come with that exuding that
confidence it's something your opponent
picks up
if they're feeling bad about their
tournament already looking across the
board and seeing somebody who's there to
fight to the very last moment is really
going to put them off in their game so
having that mental
confidence that you're going to come
you're playing a really long game you're
playing for the victory uh will go a
long way so keep that in mind i just
wanted to
go
through the ali raza game for a moment
because lots of things have happened
between ali reza and timor
one thing is
that timor once again had offered a kind
of a repetition here you're about to see
that the
the two players could have continued
with rook f3 to e3 and timor is
basically not made the draw offer openly
like would you like to draw but hey i'm
i'm i'm willing to make a repetition if
you are
takes on f6
structure changed with this capture
knight f3
97 the queen presumably on c4 is a
little bit too strong
uh white kicks the queen back
and we're
up to date with the players
now again it's what's the times between
these well they they just caught the
time control 42 there yeah
so uh
rajabov was 57 and ali rizzo was 50.
so still i mean it's very i think
reasonable except that's it it really
feels to me that white has done
some nice progress here like
uh i look at the structure and i feel
like this pawn has somehow gotten
very very weak
versus what's going on on the king side
the rook on f3
normally speaking you know
it's strange to see the half open file
that our opponent has it's black who has
the half open that file being possessed
by white so
feels to me like white is for choice
and once again back to the game of
hikaru because so much is writing on the
outcome of this game we left it we just
left it here we saw this move rook a2
and bishop to d1
rook
that was interesting i think alejandro
was using the other rook to defend the
a6 pawn
and by using
the rook on f7
the bishop gets to come with to g4 with
tempo and basically drive this rook far
away from the f3 square
um
i'm assuming white is going to take that
g2 pawn with the king sure after the
rook has gone yes okay so let's put a
move on the board rook to d
uh
okay and king takes g2 i'm all for it i
like it
um
let's do it yeah
that's waiting for your green light no
i'm just trying to see was there like
maybe a bishop ca to try to poke the
other pawn i was just trying to
calculate this pluck that baby before it
bishops on f1 all right bishop's on f1
you're gonna regret a lot of choices
exactly exactly
get rid of that pawn on g2 the rooks
but it's strange alejandro it feels to
me that the rooks got
a little bit thrown off kilter they're
no longer
bishop g4
uh is going to force rook d5 right
bishop g4 is a good move bitching g4 is
the best move thing is how do you make
progress you take on h2 and let's say i
pass i'm not saying it's the best move
right but let's have you guys play
against the engine okay i'll pass okay
um
so i always look
at you know how i'm going to maximize in
my opinion the king would be
better on g3 than g2 the rook would be
better on a1 than a2
my bishop would be better on d4 than on
e3 well how about your g4 bishop would
you want to try and use that i know it's
kind of keeping rook g6 in advance uh my
knight
okay so what's a good square for our
knight oh maybe h3 f4
if we can do rook a1
i like okay i like the hold on
oh you you've been helping me you've
been letting me get on so you've been
going back and forth you're look you're
letting us put our pieces on our ideal
squares we want your knight that's the
question
she likes it on f4 i like it on f4
now i can't blunder something on here
i'm blending my rook so i have to move
my rook can't give you the rook for free
gotcha that's fair and then
and then
so our knight went to f4 but
why was our knight so great on f4
you want to put it back square no i i'm
just thinking that
okay yeah put the knight back on f2 for
just a quick sec
okay so
maybe
if i
i was thinking the bishop would be
really good on d4 let's go for it but
the knight would be really good maybe on
e3
uh where how do i do that
where's the best square for the night
what is the best square for the night
you want to put the knight on e3 and a
bishop on d4 yeah i'm thinking that
would be a nice setup how about if the
knight gets to e6 comfortably and the
bishop is on d4 the moment you play this
yes
whoa
whoa
okay so
our knight went to f4 we like it we put
our knight back on that f4 we're we're
happy campers
and we take on d3 and what happened
knight thanks d3
rook shack
king h4
takes takes takes i mean it's winning
but it's not the clean it's not super
clean you still have to work this one
out all right as i mentioned hikaru is
winning yes the thing is his king's now
a little bit vulnerable that's true and
at some point he is going to have to
allow
certain counter play in order to convert
right in the positions that we were
looking up before because there were no
targets specifically there was no
intrusion
right on the f3 square white had a
pretty much a free hand on the queen
side right you
put it up the h pawn then you go a4 and
you do the same thing difference here
you're gonna have to allow rook f3 is it
a big deal at the end of the day yeah it
changes the character of the position in
the sense that black obtains some
counterplay is white still winning yes
white is still winning this is still a
winning position for hikaru nakamura the
thing is he's gonna have to at some
point sit down and calculate i felt that
he didn't have to do so in the other
variations well the other variations
like you're saying you have a white pawn
on g2 there's no rook paying a visit on
f3 we understand that there was an issue
with the f1 square but absolutely
absolutely right alejandra put that
white pawn on g2 and white has a very
easy free hand on the queen side can
make some progress so work to be to do
dorsal when i was a kid playing in
friendly rapid tournaments right i
always had this one sneaky
person
who would always switch out material
like whenever he would castle he would
put his rook on e1 i'm like no no no no
put the rook back or like at some point
i remember in one game
that's shocking it was friendly but it
was just so annoying like i remember at
one point i took three white nights and
i was like that's impossible man it's
the third night i'm taking so i was like
holding his pieces so he couldn't take
it so if i feel like if i was playing
that specific opponent they would have
no problem just switching the color of
the palms right and putting a white pawn
on g2
i'm shocked
shocked by this speaker
it was friendly games but uh-huh
very frustrated
doesn't sound so friendly
uh and uh thank you for joining the
conversation we have a social media
let's go let's go
you heard it here first
youtuber user
ryan
wand
snyder nice
what would it win by hikaru in this
round mean for the outcome of the
tournament
well it would completely
uh open up the event for hikaru i mean
it would knock fabi a point
off the lead
against yan and give hikaru who's
currently at three and a half
four and a half points leapfrogging
richard and putting himself in a
position that should magnus for whatever
reasons
decide not to play the world
championship match the top two players
would um then be invited by the fetus
guys
to a match please
if hikaru wins the only thing that's
being opened up is a bottle of champagne
are you kidding me a full point ahead
just has to survive against favi yeah
we're talking about potential matchups
if second place but
nepo is so far ahead of hikaru
it's up
it's not opening up anything it's
opening up a potential second in the
case that magnus calls and declines his
match then we've got to go back to the
regulations right but for the tournament
winner no no nothing nothing not only
changes everything improves for yeah
yes absolutely he would be he came into
today's round with a half a point lead
over fabi
fabi loses he will have a point
lead over fobby so yes from
nepo's point of view he's in the hotel
room cheering i go you could do any caro
get your revenge for that uh round one
setback
although they're playing together
tomorrow
so that i feel like after tomorrow we
might have a better
feel for the field
feel for the deal
you said it
and these are the pairings tomorrow and
like you said it's that date with
destiny as fabi uh goes against our
tournament leader nepo
to i think decide all the marbles right
there and there then ding duda rajab
naka well uh timor again uh in trouble a
little bit against farouja farouja
versus rapport uh always interesting
pairings
but uh
fabi versus napo that's that's what it's
all about
and another social media let's let's hit
em while the iron is hot another youtube
user
red hollow nice
what do i think about blind round-robin
tournaments through computers so players
don't know who they're up against and
how the strong
uh the magnus affect well when they
don't know if they're like playing
against him uh
i'm not sure i got this completely so
okay so you're asking what do you think
about a blind
oh so you just don't even know your
opponent
um i i i said i like it but i don't like
the fact that it's computer don't get me
wrong i love computers but
like that that feel of the
over-the-board chest is just so
different and i mean when i see you i'll
know you right so you've got the screen
the computer is
the interface and you're just playing
against an opponent just like you would
go
on a
game site
where they're using different handles in
your clueless
um
yeah what do i think about around the
problem is i like online play for blitz
yes i
don't like online playing for classical
so great exactly it gets my heart rate
up yes
it gives you a good workout exactly no
i'm i'm i'm not a big fan of uh
of uh i like to know my opponent for an
over the board game yeah but uh i love
preparing as my opponent i lived for
that alejandra knows every time we had a
tournament preparing
yeah every time hey coach it's like
three in the morning i have this line
it's like
leave me alone
call me at nine i
jump in with that uh the user's question
and there was something there about the
magnus effect sorry i didn't
what was that all about i think he's
referring to the fact that magnus might
be intimidating to his opponents ah let
me tell you the truth the magnus effect
is the magnus makes very good moves
right these players are really strong i
don't feel that at that level they're
really that negatively impacted by the
fact that they know that they're playing
magnus carlsen and at that moment these
players started the tournament very even
right they didn't really look at each
other and be like that guy's stronger
than me that guy is my target they all
came as eight equal players
and i don't
think that making them play without
knowing each other let's say in a
hypothetical where you split the room
and
you know somehow they can't see each
other that it would really add too much
to the actual games themselves and as
you mentioned guys preparing is part of
chess it is part of our sport you would
be taking that away and leaving it to a
different kind of preparation where you
prepare more generally but in those
cases we won't be seeing some of the
heavy theoretical disputes that we see
for example today with hikaru knowing a
novelty that favi did but doing the
homework and preparing something against
it anyway so
i'm not a fan of the idea yeah i like uh
kind of what you were saying there too
uh one of the uh great pleasures in
chess is preparing your openings you it
doesn't matter
people who love the french defense love
the french defense people who love the
night or love the night or so they
prepare their beloved openings their
defenses
they get them at the board they spring
their novelty they're very very pleased
with themselves they won a wonderful
game
and
that's really the charm of uh of chess
is that you get to
all of those aspects of preparation and
overwhelming or winning against a person
that you would really like to defeat
yeah yeah that's what we live for i
completely love preparing
some of my best wins were solely
preparing and
some of the lectures that i've done for
the club you can check it on our youtube
channel it's literally me just promoting
how much i love preparing and how much
the whole preparation like won me the
tournament or one of the title or like
how sweet it is
wonderful preparing is amazing exactly
uh let's uh catch up with the players
because uh fabi
not exactly uh the non-moving target he
wasn't as nice as alejandro who just let
us kind of improve our position as we'd
like bishop g4 did uh was met pardon me
by the move rook f5 to d5 getting out of
the way
king takes g2 get rid of that pawn i
mean alejandro is mentioning that you
know there is a bishop f1 sighting
and bad things might happen if a rook
ever lands on d3 so get rid of that pawn
uh very logical move the move rook to g6
maybe prepping the possibility of bishop
e2 that's a pin well um
king to g3 and we have
caught up with the players after this
move king to g3
looks still like white's
enjoying himself um
as uh
alejandro was mentioning at some point
you just have to figure out
you know like how am i doing this
how am i winning the game i'm looking at
ideas of bishop d4 alejandro mentioned
that bishop d4
rook takes d4
c3 takes d4
c4 c3 could be an opportunity
for fabiano to save the game keep that
exchange sacrifice in mind
the meantime bishop e2 protected by the
rook
that's not happening
it's just not easy for black i think
fabi pardon me alejandra might have it
right you just gotta chill
sometimes none of the pawns can move i
can't really think of the bishop doing
anything different
the g6 trick is just there right i mean
you could go down but i'm not really
sure whether or not you want to just
leave this pawn hanging maybe even ideas
of king
f4 so at the moment black is just stuck
so making the move king h8 and
back to the question that alejandra
might have asked us
uh is it time um dorsa should we be
putting our knight to f4 i mean i kind
of like it right now more because it's a
fork
but
i mean i feel like we were talking about
rookie one rookich one idea but i don't
know if that's necessary anymore because
yeah the rook can just get to where it
needs to go as is if we don't move the
knight exactly so in fact the more i'm
looking at this by the way i do think
that the knight
jumping to h3 and onwards to f4
especially maybe with this rook sliding
over
there are issues here alejandro uh and i
like uh this does
again um
does fabi have
i mean
is there a way for him to play actively
i just don't see it i'm just
it seems like white still has all of the
dynamic potential
yep
yeah
it's difficult to make a move
right that's why he's such a great
commentator you know his analysis boy
just like right there nicely done the
problem is bishops right they control
too many squares uh this rook doesn't
have a way in this rook is spinning me
but so what you're kind of trying to
pass
precisely that's exactly what i feel i'm
trying to do that's right so you might
as well i mean there's moves like rook
f6 bishop f1 there's a lot of passing
moves you're just waiting for hikaru to
put his pieces in the right place right
and finally attack a weakness so when
his car was able to attack a weakness
everything falls apart right so this is
what favi needs to be very careful of
for the moment there are no threats this
uh knight's not running anything you
don't really want to take on d3 you can
but that makes your life harder
uh this bishop is pinned so it's not
threatening bishop c8 so for the moment
you really kind of have to chill for
black there's no active plan it's a very
difficult position to even make a move
in
but that's that's the position he's in
now he's played bishop f1 one of those
let's call them passing moves exactly uh
of course if you take on e4 uh rook d3
or rookie five yeah both our ideas start
making the game very messy exactly the
pawn on e4 is for now uh taboo right
it's better to play some other move i
think rook d4 bishop d4 sorry it's a
better way to start and you don't have
the sacrifices anymore
when this bishop has left unfortunately
the diagonal right i would love to see
that sacrifice actually because in this
position i just take your pawn and
you're not running c2
the bishop is also not defending the
pawn on e4 right so this is the time if
you had a time to play bishop d4 i think
it's this one uh might as well take
advantage of that the game kind of goes
on though bishop d4 you can't really
defend this guy except for bishop d3 so
that's what i assume would happen you
kind of go back and then you keep asking
hikaru how are you going to improve your
position this is the only thing that
karana can do at the moment and again in
this exact position if we see the move
king f4
uh
those sacrifices of rook takes deforest
are not on right well you're losing also
this one right oh there's a bishop f5
you're absolutely right so you pick up
this rook and the pawn is not going to
force itself because it's on a dark
square so no no chances of that
uh bishop f1 on the board king f4 is a
good move bishop d4 is a good move
most moves retain the advantage but
those i would see as the most logical
ways to improve the position
anything to i mean again i
i personally i just hate
those pins i hate being in pins uh i
would be looking at king f4 king h4 just
to sidestep those pins just be a little
bit careful okay please tell me how i
can blow it
where are you going
i'm going back
i'm the president of the pond grover's
club but i did spot bishop g2 getting
him from oh oh
oh that's going in my checkmate's
beautiful collection there you go there
you go it's very nice so self-admiration
start with bishop d4 right so you don't
have rook forces but i don't have a rook
f6 because if you play king f4 right now
and i go rook f6 you force me back to g3
and we just repeat moves exactly so okay
put the king back on g3 for just a quick
sec put the bishop on d4
and then when you play the move bishop
to d4 king f4
is on white's agenda exactly because
then you have the e3 square available
for your king bishop g2 is not mate
and there's not even a follow-up check
the bishop on g4 controls f3 control c6
the bishop 1d4 controls c5 king on e3
perfectly safe those bishops look great
awesome torso oh thank you speaking of
pawn eating can we just eat e4
i say what oh you mean now after no the
problem was that uh what alejandro said
is that the rook actually pays
um
a vision yeah i mean again we're in the
silly pin we don't get a chance to go
knight g5
please oh i'm just trying to see how
would it work even if uh tikara makes a
mistake and gives up two pieces for
the rook
would that still be because that a6 pawn
is still you know
edible yes yes you've got knight g5 and
maybe rook takes a6 would that still be
you know it's better for white but it's
one of those things where you you know
you get you start getting worried like
the materials coming off the board and
at the end of that day in that variation
it might be two versus two right like
type of thing i know what you're saying
that uh
well i like where you're heading they're
grabbed upon you know but it is this
rook d3 and these double pins
that you start to think well why did i
allow that i mean because black really
doesn't have a threat black is actually
marking time as alejandro said with this
move bishop um
bishop f1 so it's like
we can improve our position slowly
bishop to two well now maybe we could
eat it
after no no sorry i mean um i was still
on the e4 pawn if we go bishop d4
perhaps we could still try on the next
turn yeah yes no question about it
knight takes e4
is now looking like an
excellent excellent move uh especially
as there's still no bishop e2 and you
can't you know exploit the pin with rook
g5 because the knight will cover it so
it's still it's it's all hikaru karu
yeah it's in really a great position to
win this game more reasons for bishop d4
sorry i'm just going to no worries uh
refresh my board
as we have bishop f1 on the board
uh this moment
um
it's it's kind of interesting one of the
things that was going on when i was
playing chess it was the cold war oh uh
soviet union and the united states and i
think very unfairly i think the soviets
were really really phenomenal players
very unfairly the western players would
say those guys are cheating they didn't
have to cheat to beat us they were just
really really really good so whenever
the soviets played against each other
you know the western guys would always
say oh when they drew that was okay you
know like they weren't giving one
another the point now the americans come
and the americans are beating the hell
out of
no friendly games between these two
right uh alejandro
i mean can you can you imagine that
hikaru's not playing the olympia
that is true but imagine that he carl
plays the olympiad after knocking fabi
from catching nepo
that that'd be some team chemistry right
yeah
that thing like a beautiful team meeting
right but it is an individual sport and
hikaru is bringing it in this game he
wants to keep his chances alive he's
playing for first place still he hasn't
checked out of this tournament he
doesn't care who's in front of him his
best friend in the world doesn't matter
still gonna try to beat him and in this
case man he is very very close exactly
and
again
the time control in this event
you don't get increments until you pass
the 60th move
uh
40 moves for two hours
20 moves to be made in one hour so
that's the second time control we're on
the second time control so for those of
you who are used to increments you're
not going to see him until we get to the
60th move and we've just seen this move
bishop f1 by fabi marking time we think
that there are nice ways
i believe left
to get to to complete the second time
control right and we're seeing fabi just
marking time as black uh
ikaru can really nicely improve his
position with little moves like bishop
f4 followed by king f4
and the engines are saying it's it's wow
you know we also one of our our cheapos
that i like to use on the show
is and i usually only use it once a
broadcast is when they make the move
that we recommended he said these guys
are so good
they discovered the move that i want to
play i mean i just
i just i'm in awe
that they could do that thank you for
using it with me exactly so bishop d4 on
the board and we are expecting with
these little incremental moves king f4
that slowly slows slowly uh fabi's
position will slip slide into a lost
position
but there's no question hikaru has made
it difficult on himself because there
should be a pawn on g2 that is not there
and he still
um well has to reel in the point
for yourself
when you think about your chess career
and you think about all the winning
positions you had and so on are you good
at bringing home the point
or do you
sometimes or often times slip and let
your opponent escape
i think for me a huge part of it is the
time if i'm low on time
coach knows it's it's not good it's not
the way you win the game but it's kind
of funny this is like two years ago i
was in gibraltar tournament 2017 and i
was being interviewed i believe it was
by tanya and she was asking so like
how's you know what's your style and
people were saying i'm defensive i'm
aggressive and i'm like i'm a snake
okay define that explain what you're
thinking so my perfect
game is if i like go like a buddha
around the position i make sure you're
like stuck in the queen side you got
nothing to do center is closed up
king side is mine and i'm just like i
squeeze squeeze squeeze like a python
yes
yeah tigran petrossian
admire that
and really i thought you were a nice
person and now i'm completely uh tasered
nice
coach is she right is it is she uh she's
got the vice-like
grip
over her opponents
i mean it comes and goes for most times
but that's my perfect uh perfect game
but
yes i love the control like if i get the
choice between you know not to give
opponents counter play or like if it's
if you know it's a super tactical line
i'm choosing no counter play i want you
to suffer i mean
just over the board of course
in a nice way in a nice way exactly
exactly fine
very good very very good thank you no
but uh for for me the same and that's
actually one of the things i've always
enjoyed about
chess and i relished
is this idea of playing a really
beautiful control game where i i mean i
feel like i was always dictating the
action
and conversely you know my worst uh
type of a game is a game where
you you you know of course the concept
of the eternal pin you're on the back
right you got a bishop on f8 the rook
your king can't move the bishop you're
an eternal player oh yes that's the name
that's the worst right you're completely
tied up you never get out
and so i hate those
kind of games where my opponent has
actually
you know wrapped me up but i've always
liked that aspect of chass this
battle of ideas and you've got your
ideas i've got my ideas but if i can tie
you up
i'm loving it bishop d4 um hikaru is
loving it alejandro it should be it's a
position
to take the full point and bishop d4 as
we mentioned is a good move and of
course
for fabi it's about surviving until time
control at the moment because he spent
four minutes in this move
19 minutes left on the second time
control it's not really that much time
and remember that he makes needs to make
uncomfortable moves i can sit back here
with my computer and my engine and say
i'm going to pass past pass pass what
are you going to do right but
humans don't really work like that
fabiano caron specifically hates doing
that right he's a very active player he
likes to solve his problems that he has
positionally with tactics with
complications with precise calculation
nothing to calculate here every time
that you make an active move you're just
making your position worse you have to
sit back and kind of take it until
hikaru finds a threat and then you're
saying okay i need to prevent that
threat i'll do it
but he is on the back foot in that
scenario in which he cannot create an
active idea which is the worst we've
been talking about that precisely which
is the worst
type of position to have
where you're reacting just reacting like
okay i i'll pass i'll pass i won't make
a weakness i won't make your life that
easy but uh it's
it's very very hard to do i mean because
we are always looking for our counter
chances sometimes it's just not there
and any attempts to make a counter
chance just worsens
uh the situation
i saw that because it was behind you
timor's game with ali raisa could you
just bring us up to date on that game i
know
apologies to the fans of these two
players but uh the other game is just so
much more important to our standings
anything in particular happening or not
um alejandro
all right next game
and again you see why he gets the big
bucks i mean he's just like he just
thrills us with his
insights and
it's been a strange game
like it hasn't really changed that much
the structure changed a little bit right
now a couple of pawns were traded
somehow the d-pawn got traded for the
g-pawn
not something you're expected to hear
right yeah
but it's true but it's pretty much what
happened right the g-pawn disappeared
and the d-pawn disappeared and now we
have a more static structure
you can't really easily pawn break f4 is
never going to help white
and you don't really want to play c5
because it leaves p5 as a weakness right
so neither side has a break neither side
has really that weak pawns i mean
e6 is a bit of a target and it's
tethering this queen on g6 to the
defense but who's going to join the
attack not so clear now white's still a
little bit better you still have the
control of the a file because right now
uh the move rook g8 leaves you weak on
the king side you need the rook to
defend in some variation especially if
the nitro is the fray but it's still a
long game it's a long maneuvering game
we're barely out of move 40 and the
players are taking a very very long time
on their moves especially laresa you
know that he loves thinking already down
to 27 minutes in the second time control
which means he's used up 33 minutes for
the five moves that he made after mu 40.
it's a very long thing nothing much has
changed in the position it's between
equal i'd rather take white just a
smidge
but everything to play for i love this
move but wait a minute i love this move
rook a2 very much the rook on b2 was
lousy yes in my opinion and when the
move rook a2 if i could trade rooks on a
good day
i get to play rook f8 and queen a8 yeah
meet you from behind i i can see a way
the into the position for uh white thing
is
the more you propose ideas as white the
more you give ideas to black the moment
that you start trading everything and
putting the queen up there on the board
i'm going to start harassing you
on this side of the board tethering the
knight to the rook hinting that i'm
going to go knight g6
knight takes h4 i appreciate that one
check made you first
so not as easy as i said i do prefer
white because as you mentioned there are
some trickies with the queen coming to
a7 perhaps coming to a8 there are things
that i can attack however the engine
very objectively thinks that black just
has about enough counter chances with
the major pieces on the king side
because this structure as solid as it
looks
the moment one of these pawns disappears
it opens up
the major pieces for black which is why
you so desperately want this knight to
be hitting this pawn on h4 the move
queen g4 makes a lot of sense that queen
will be greatly placed on a g4 or h5
depending on the fact of you attacking
e6 or not i could also go queen h5
knight g6 knight takes h4 so it seems
that timor has just about enough counter
chances on the king side to counter what
you're going to do on the queen side
with the queen penetration and that's
why the engines are giving zeroes i as i
said i would still uh think that white
is the one that i would prefer playing
all right thank you for that insight
absolutely i i'd like the move rook a2
got myself all excited about the idea of
going rook takes queen takes a2 and
queen a7
and this move knight h4
could hurt my feelings so i'm just
buying pawns because
of that previous game no no this this
specific game because
well
you mean ali raises game yes yes okay
let me get back oh my apologies no
that's okay don't worry rook a2 yes yeah
the b5 pawn is just looking kind of
potentially
yeah
i'm not sure if that's ever gonna happen
but
i can't really think of like a specific
pawn from white's points that black
could try and grab
i would be more eager to target the c7
pawn than i would the v5 pawn but just
to let's let's consider ollie uh
alejandro's idea here
the queen
uh defends e6
as he mentioned it tethers the knight in
the rook together and he sets up for
this knight
jumping
to h4
knight
g6 takes h4
and uh
well our king
starts to feel a little bit funny
again just because i happen to have this
king walk in uh my mind uh walking the
king out of the danger zone of the
g-file might be the way to go for
example king to g2
knight part of it the g6 yeah cause the
h4 pawn
could fall but i mean then the e6 pawn
would go so yeah that was a trade
i
felt i as white that i would like to do
this pawn on h4
yeah that's a nice pawn but this pawn on
e6 also
it's a gateway to the king right my king
my queen pounces and if you don't make
that trade if you do go for this
threat
of knight h4 i can just simply
sidestep
all the good stuff and eventually this
queen
will one day uh
like what alejandro said the trickies
yes there could be some trickies over
there we'll keep an eye on that game
and uh once again thank you for joining
the conversation as we have another
social media hello what do you got first
come on endorsement which platform there
we go
from youtube our friend patrick patrick
comes on off he does he's very much
involved in my lectures as well nice
lovely nice to see you
are
nepo and fabi
actually this much better than the field
question mark
is this a form thing
or
are they just playing the the right way
in the opening asking hard questions of
their opponents
um i think that's a very good
question uh patrick we had
um former u.s champion sam shankland on
and sam said there's
nepo a
and nepo b
and when he's playing against nepo a in
sam shanklin's
world he's the second best player on the
planet like that's it
he he thinks that that greatly about
nepo
a but the problem is nepo a also comes
with his evil twin
nepo b where he does bad things to
himself
uh and uh makes it uh that much
uh more difficult for him to win events
fabby
when fabi's inform wow only magnus can
stop fabi so i've got to say that these
two guys
have demonstrated their
superiority now having said that
i think just so much things have gone
wrong for the rest of the field like
whether again it could be openings it
could be form there could be all kinds
of other things
i for one never expected
it to be such a dominant two-horse race
type of thing i mean i chose hikaru as
this kind of a dark horse i didn't see
his chances as being two percent or
something like that i thought you know
it's reasonable to expect that they were
10
and jump in with this one alejandro
it's just everything went
well right
for our top two uh
players today sometimes things go right
during a tournament the pieces fall into
place like magic like magic you're in
form you get the openings that you want
your opponents miss things at key
moments and they make some kind of
strange decision
nepo's form
nepo's
openings
don't really explain what happened to
richard rapport
against nepal oh yes
right he gives napo half a point in a
position where everybody knows lanier
came in
fave complained about it after the game
nepo clearly knew it he caro knew it he
went he won during the game looked at
what's richard doing right
except richard
it seemed like richard was the only one
that didn't know this variation and he
proposed it right and
he mixed something up
thought he was doing okay and just
gifted half a point
this kind of small gifts add up
now
compiled with the fact that nepo is
playing better
than anybody in this tournament i would
say favi's close behind except that he
really is getting outplayed today
it gives nepo a commanding lead so it
was a combination of things i do think
that netbook is playing better chess
than the other people i mean take a look
at what duda did today
it it's just not duda they're not
showing up with their strength uh ding
loren
without a win yeah in eight right what
come on that's not dingley ren dingley
ran is such a brilliant player right and
he he's not really showing it
even timor
timor is playing below his level
i don't think anybody really gave timo
rajabo a chance at this event to win it
but he's a very very very strong player
he's been a
talented prodigy he beat kasparov at 15
he's touched the 2800 ceiling
where is he
this is not the teamwork that you want
to see out of candidates yeah
i had i was
reading all of these articles that's
what i like to do by the way about the
candidates especially and the world
championship matches is i love to read
everybody's take and perspectives i'm
bringing up the game from yesterday this
is the game that richie lost
to nepo to give him the lead the gift
and as
richard explained he wasn't trying to
win the game so much as to commit
suicide i thought that was very
insightful of richard anyway the point
what
what
alejandro was saying is we had lanier
on the air and he says yeah i know this
variation i know that bishop h3 is a
draw
and if your opponent
finds all the right moves you give them
a draw well done if they find the wrong
moves
they lose
okay so
richie had prepared this position as
white yes he knows the position as a
draw but according to his engine
according to his files
the drawing move is bishop d6
which also everybody knows
now the problem was richie may have had
that in his files against a weaker
engine today's engines just play bishop
h3 routinely
so in richard's mind and as he explained
it he knows he's playing in a position
that's drawn and bishop d6 is the
his engine approved way of getting into
a draw
uh when
nepo put the move bishop h3 down
he's thinking to himself blunder blunder
bishop d6 draws bishop h3 and then he's
thinking thinking thinking and he starts
to realize oh
this is not that good for me
uh and
should i make a draw should i make a
draw should i make a draw but really
like should have played bishop b6 nepal
was blitzing everything you think
opening preparation for the world
championship was faulty are you kidding
me
i'm just saying that richard came he
expected a draw to be achieved by bishop
d6 and that really for him bishop h3 was
a surprise i also look at it i don't
understand why
he spent over an hour
yes he did yes he did yes he did good
god well that was a beautiful gift yes
exactly that was how
uh
you know when it when it rains it pours
and everything was going just
wonderfully
uh for uh
for napo throughout
and uh yesterday was you know case in
point of his opponents just being very
very generous i do remember one of the
things that i know for sure alejandra
has told me numerous times
it's like in order to actually in order
to win a game you got to play good but
if you're actually trying to win the
tournament you need luck without luck
you're not going to win the tournament
you can play you can get second you can
get third you can actually not have a
good tournament but to win it you need
luck exactly so
but good players push their luck too and
then you do that through your training
and your preparation and you're working
hard and by the way
talking about marking time that's what
fabi has done he started with the move
bishop f1 a moment ago
and then after bishop d4 bishop d3 so
he's kind of gone back and forth
and now that white has wormed his king
all the way to the f4 square
white is threatening to play bishop f5
or something to that effect so much so
that it induced the move
uh king g8 just getting out of the
potential of bishop f5 sure feels to me
alejandro like white's making made good
progress i'm still uh
i'm still liking bishop of five you
still like bishop
yeah pick it up i'm hungry
i just want to go for the ball on e4
okay is are we allowing rook g2 bishop
e6 could be a little
that hurts yeah you can't play rogue g2
there's bishop e6 so the rook has to
stay in the sixth rank oh man and that
means i can pluck the e4 pawn finally
and that's when things fall apart for
favi the moment that you can't keep your
position together all of it starts to
disappear the knight starts getting to
c5 the bishop loses his defense you all
transitions to end games like this one
are totally lost right the a6 pawn is
next to go yeah
and it's not like you're going to queen
your g pawn no
no
the way pop bobby pushed that h-pawn i
don't know
that's a good point
he's frightening that's for sure and
those
uh i i always stress this that when
you're playing with the minor pieces
protect them
minor pieces especially knights they
love protection this bishop on d4
anchored on what is called a prime
square
the bishop on a d4 covers
more territory than on d4 than any other
square on an open board the knight on e4
looks great the king looks great
this feels really
nice especially when you pointed out
thor said that the bishop e6 check is on
tap for
ikaru uh bishop f5 loving it i mean
uh
now it's now it feels like it's got the
flow
uh alejandro yeah it it does and i think
that
it's about time to collect for the
harvest for hikaria the harvest is here
uh you just have to make sure that you
don't believe in ghosts right this is
not a ghost yeah right it doesn't work
no you don't hit the knight the knight
can take the bishop and then the rook is
hanging this doesn't work so bishop f5
the moment you notice that this little
combination doesn't work go for it take
that pawn it's about time bishop f5 on
the board hikaru on his way
to make nepo a happier man
wow because he's just gonna cruise
through victory out of this position
fantastic we're gonna take a break um
uh promising to stay with us for
not just for today but for the whole
second half yes we got a promise yes all
right
we'll be back
doris and i will welcome you back on the
other side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sink field
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live
coverage of the 2022 candidates here are
our current standings as we are in round
eight with two games in the books our
tournament leader coming into the round
made a very early draw
against ding lehren
to increase his lead over fabi to a
point with fabi still the play richard
rapport wins his first game of the
tournament respects to richie as he
takes down a duda of poland to a jump to
four points and an even score
duda falls to minus two in the
tournament with two games going in this
round our all-important match-up
all-important american match-up is
between
fabi and hikaru and hikaru i have to say
dorset is playing all the right moves
when we left it we left it in this
position we really like the move king f4
king went back to g8 bishop f5 the pawn
on e4 is going to fall
except and i really really like what
hikaru did he said you know what
like before i don't need to win this on
on the contrary i like the fact that the
bishop on d3 is rather stuck i'm going
to play around the bishop i'm going to
put my knight on e3 and i'm going to go
after the g7 pawn which is what he did
he could have also in my opinion
started with a move like bishop e5 again
because bishop e6 checked the rook is
going to have to stay
on this
six ring the rook could then slide
across
and it's all about this pawn you're
threatening to play moves like knight
f6 check as well as knight e3 this is
really going swimmingly well for ikaru
kara starts with the move knight e3 we
do have rook b5 on this position is just
completely dominating there's absolutely
nothing black can do to cause any
trouble any discomfort
it's just black
i feel like black is right now
unfortunately a
kicking box sandbox right so that's
unfortunately i don't really think
i'm team fabi but well in this match i'm
tim fabian right he lives in the city
what am i supposed to do exactly
saint louis
yeah
it's it's just it's such a for me it's a
little sad match
but
well white is i mean he car is just
playing a better game i can't say
anything about that is playing a
fantastic game really it has been he he
made it
he came out of the opening with an edge
that he was really really pressing and
then he made his life so much more
difficult for himself as he did allow
fabi to push his h-pawn all the way up
the board even
going so far as being able to capture
the pawn on g2 but since at that time
hikaru has righted the ship and he's
played really really well
and it feels to us like i mean he's just
playing a great game and
should reel in the whole point here we
do have the position after rook b5 on
the board again i'm expecting a kind of
move like bishop e5
and the whole idea behind bishop e5 is
you want to sneak in
the move rook g2 and if that pawn falls
well i mean it's a gateway to black's
king as well bishop e5 bishop e6 uh why
don't you now
um are you uncomfortable with drug takes
d4 ideas
maybe
maybe uh
i'm not uncomfortable about forcing the
rook back i mean i know i i mean i would
play the move rook g2 if it did force
the rook back
i would
have to unfortunately calculate just to
make sure
that i'm not doing something untoward
and giving making my life a little bit
difficult i think it's winning i do i do
think that rook g2 is winning one of the
things that i would like to see let me
just show you
almost a dream kind of uh patterns
bishops
you know i it wouldn't be surprising
that i might be setting up a
a checkmating pattern also a6 i can
almost hear your voice echoing with
pushing baby yeah yeah
when i get enthusiastic
there you go there you go
my problem
in chess was it didn't take me much to
get enthusiastic that is
you know when i was black
and i equalized i thought i was better
okay why
so i'm starting with black i'm starting
slightly worse
but now that i've equalized
you see how much i've been the trend is
in my favor and sometimes i was too
optimistic how about yourself the upward
trend um yeah
this is a huge topic and for for college
students you know because
everybody usually messes up their first
year or first semester or it's just like
or you just take too many classes you
just don't know what you're doing so
it's expected to kind of mess up your
first semester and then if you want to
later on get into professional school
med school
grad school anything they kept then you
were like ah i have like these really
ugly c's here what do i do with them
even though your gpa might be perfect by
the end of it the whole point is that
they always tell you the upward trend we
care about the upward trend as long as
you you know you it's fine to mess up a
little here a little there
oh yes especially but then on your
second third year they're expecting the
upward trend and then all is forgiven so
what you were mentioning with how you
start from a little below and you're
having the upward trend not just in
chess but i i completely feel that as
well okay uh alejandra jump right in uh
either in this game or in the team or uh
rajaboff game uh what has drawn your
attention
favi is just a dead yeah is a couple of
moves away from finishing this one off
and what a great game this was this and
the one that he won against timor
rajabov excellent games prep just on
point today got a position where he
understood it better than his opponent
knew that the move c4 was probably
inaccurate and since then it's all been
on hikaru's camp what a great game he's
playing today he really is showing that
he belongs with the candidates and again
it's all about nepal being happy about
this result now that being said remember
there is the potential that the match
will be the world championship match
that is between the number one player
and the number two player in the
candidates but it's all a maybe and it's
all an if and it's all of
very hypothetical things the only thing
that's not hypothetical first place gets
you into the world championship match
and that that's what nepo is looking for
just a little bit of a thing this is not
a move because of g5 excuse me but
besides that everything's about right
bishop c5 was played instead with a very
similar idea the rook jumped to f6 and
you have your choices rook g2 is played
with the idea of bishop d4 later since
g6 is not playable the engine wants to
go king e5 which is a little inhuman oh
as you were mentioning ke5 king f7 on
the board instantly instantly six moves
to make four five he only has four five
minutes but honestly that's the least of
his problems
white is activated all of his pieces
managed to disconnect the rooks as you
mentioned dorsa there is no way to
create a thread to make uh white
uncomfortable with this position the
knight is just tethering everybody the
bishop is anchored you can't even break
on a5 because it gives me a passed pawn
nothing to do here for the white uh for
the black side now it's just a matter of
taste on how you want to finish this one
off you can even if you felt like it
already in an exchange with the move
knight g4 where's this rook go
uh baby
uh
c6 is bishop d7 right
oops you can sacrifice and keep on
playing but it's completely lost no it
sure is oh dear and what is
what is alejandro explaining uh
unfortunately
uh depending on your point of view
magnus carlsen has made noises then look
i've won five world championship matches
and each and every one of those matches
were exhausting i spent months of my
life training for the match preparing
24 hours a day locked in then the match
itself is incredibly tense
i don't need it anymore and he said
unless i'm playing somebody who i think
is a real challenge like farouza
i may not play
so
uh the winner will be the challenger but
if the champion steps down then it's the
number two guy and that's why
this game for hikaru
uh is so important because it's happened
once before
fischer
1975 versus anatoly karpa bobby fisher
wanted to change the rules from
uh
world championship match in 24 games to
the first player to win 10
games draws not counting the soviets
said no way jose
we'll be here for months
we don't want that we want a 24 game
match bobby refused to play and anatoly
karpov was declared the winner
very very sad day and we don't explore
american fans we don't expect that we
won't have a fisher-type situation in
which the negotiations fall apart right
this would be a different scenario
magnus in hindsight says look guys i'm
i'm not interested figure it out before
you get to that point
we have almost a year
to be talking about it you know figure
out what you want to do with your
regulations don't involve me anymore if
you want to have a match you can have it
between two other people and we might
have a world championship match just no
defense
and there you go uh
you're you're saying that that that
there are ways of winning
uh and you mentioned knight g4
uh attacking the rook
alejandro and you were saying you know
the rook was trapped because of the rook
went here to c6 there was bishop to g7
um
icarus had 94 95 uh nicely centralizing
the night looks pretty darn good to me
i'm kind of feeling like uh right now
hikaru is
um you know
putting up such a nice piece
it feels like
such a nice step it it has a beautiful
geometry to it doesn't it the bishops on
c5 and f5 the knight in the middle of
the king on e on e5 uh to be fair i
haven't not seen that that looks
real i i don't know the exact word but
what i'm thinking about is maybe a nice
showmanship
would that be a would that fit here i
can imagine that it's like i would you
know knight g4 would make total sense
because you're still grabbing the rook
but
again no complaint with this i love
seeing these wild pawn runs and wild
rook wraps and
well it was all going so swimmingly well
for white that
fabi said look you know my bishop on d3
i might as well if it's tethered i might
as well have a pawn on e2 one square
away from promoting so let me sacrifice
an exchange uh
uh rook takes f5 king takes f5 e3 check
uh discover check i'm
assuming the king is going to go i don't
know
f4 e2 and then i'm going to stop this
pawn from
going any further with the move rook e1
it was strange i mean you know sometimes
you get these
positions where they're so overwhelming
you know you almost fall asleep you
forget that you have to win them
all of those moves knight g4 knight d5
yes yes and yes but i love this knight
on e3 i thought that knight on e3 was
ideal if you will and after king f7 i
would have probably myself gone after
this pawn so that i could bring my rook
to a7 and not allow anything like what
we're seeing and what we're seeing by
the way i'm sure it's completely winning
for white
but
there are ways of winning without giving
anything to your opponent and well okay
maybe a few moves ago you mentioned
something really nice that you know all
of the pieces were kind of protecting
each other exactly i really like that so
um i think we had something on our
chest language a slide something about
right no
no no loose pieces
yeah loose pieces fall off well this uh
tom is enamored
with our
chest vernacular so certain
words pull out for him tom pull up that
graphic that you like so much about the
swish and
when tom doesn't know what we're talking
about he goes zugzwang oh
and here it is what were you saying
fancy piece draw puff that that was
loose now have you ever used that
because i've never used
i'm not necessarily drop off i always do
think about not having loose pieces
especially when you're low on time just
to avoid blunders right but i thought
yesterday i was in the truck and i saw
that and i thought it was quite fun
loose piece drop-off okay and fancy play
syndrome sometimes we overdo it we
really don't know 95 might have been a
fancy play syndrome instead of knight g4
right
and or for my taste i would have like i
said i've mentioned bishop c8 i would
have gone for that but all right uh
alejandro um
it's time to finish the game guys enough
of this maneuvering enough of enjoying
torturing your opponent just finished
the game and he can do so already one
material what else do you want from the
man right and right now he can return a
little bit to finish the game
immediately or he can play the move king
d4 and keep going king d4 rook a1 you're
going to cover uh e1 very solidly this
pawn is never going to promote but you
can also just give up your bishop rook
takes you promote
and congratulations as black
you get to pick this guy up right but uh
after check or even starting with b5
who's catching that
nobody it'll require a little bit of
calculation but hicaro is very very
comfortable in that if you don't feel
like calculating
you can just play the move king d4 and
then rook a1 catch that pawn for now and
then you'll have to maneuver around a
little bit again to pick up a6 but you
will pick it off eventually this one's
not going anywhere really actually it's
defended bishop one was just played
instead of i believe rook yeah
should be winning as well right yeah
no bomb no pawn movements the a6 pawn is
falling
well king d4 wait the angel's already
saying king d4 is the only winning move
what
that possible no way seriously i would
have assumed everything wins right
yeah i mean king d4
is the most natural way of winning so i
wouldn't
be looking for anything else why is it
difficult maybe king d6 fancy play
syndrome might might catch up yeah you
still have to calculate a little bit
here after the move bishop e1 because if
you get into this position yeah i am
threatening bishop e4
let's say they don't take the pawn right
okay i go bishop e4 i'll go rook d6 yes
but now i've got you stuck here
uh i'm ready to push my pawn aren't i
you are
but now i'm gonna
come around
they'll be coming around the mountain
there's still a piece the g pawn isn't
really much of a use the king is still
but again there because you're stuck on
this side a little bit i'm not going to
promote
uh-huh i'm going to keep hitting your
business oh king f4 was played
maybe fluffy will bounce back still
still within
margins
but that is making himself difficult g5
okay
king goes to g3 i presume yeah because
if you take i just pick up the knight no
that's not what i'm doing i assume you
go here correct
rookie five
well when i go knight c7
and i attack this guy
well then i got rook a1 i can deal with
that so i take a pawn yeah knight takes
a6 i think right
let's say
rook f1
and now i challenge you to win the game
rorro
you're a bit stuck i am i am i am stuck
here i mean you can never take doesn't
help you to ever take this bishop i
don't even think i'm going to let you
take my bishop not that i even want to
take the bishop but boy it's getting
it's getting a little dicey yeah dicey
uh one more move for fabiano carvanha
only g5 is good here
only g5 is logical as well to be honest
right this king is really nicely placed
on f4 just kick it out of the way oh my
goodness um
maybe still winning for hikaru but
unnecessary very unnecessary letting
this is what i was asking you about do
you let your opponent do you slip
and let your opponent back in the game
winning a one position
is far more difficult than we we care to
admit um g5 on the board
remember move 60 15 minutes extra for
both players and increment start
sticking wow they just got their move 60
so i feel like this this game has three
acts uh the first act three yeah
well like act 16 by this point
wow
clear some cobwebs with for me alejandro
you mentioned that one move g5 when i
wanted to play e bishop e5 that's a
awkward in this position i think it was
move
king f7 moved 54
and knight d5
was not exactly my first choice knight
g4 wasn't my second choice i was it was
bit i just want to claim the game i
don't want to
was bishop c8
a nice way of claiming the game or is it
not as good as i'm
letting on immediately equal oh
immediately equal that clarifies my drug
create is the only move right i was
going to take a pawn
right oh the king gets a little handsy
why are you hiding your king oh
then that desirable knight d5 you got
knight d5 but after rook f5 bishop b7 e3
again the problem with the pawn right
your king is overloaded it either
defends against the pawn advancing by
taking it or defends the knight it
cannot do both at the same time and
since there's opposite colored bishops i
have enough time to get my bishop back
and defend the slightly better end game
still for white but that's not the the
clean that's not clean if you wanted to
clean in my opinion it was rook g2
dorset mentioned also that she liked
this move very much sliding the rook
across slide the rook across it adds
fuel to all of these threats because you
keep a lot of blacks threats under
control with the rook on g2 keeping this
g pawn
at bay so instead we have this position
and and we have we have a game guys i
mean my white still
in the driver's seat white still might
be winning
but
he's making his life uh that much
much
remember in round five hicaro did have a
decisive advantage and let's not make it
again
nowhere near
this type of advantage exactly no
nowhere close near by any stretch of the
imagination i agree i mean hikaru was a
couple of moves away
from forcing resignation right i mean
had he plucked the at h5 pawn back that
would have made it so easy he would have
made his life so easy right right but
now there's a pawn or need two
five
see there's a thing
five looks at this position and if he
had been
automatically making moves for the first
half hour right he now wakes up
because i got to move 60 wait a second i
have a pawn on youtube right is is
that's inspiring is there a way
can i trick him could i put a rook on f1
and they put a rook somewhere to do
something you start looking for okay
chad rookie here you go
rookie five might not be the most
logical move
right
but it is the engine move the end
recommendation even a move like rook e6
it's not
it might be winning
but what what's the plan
well i like what you were saying if you
put the rook on f1 the white king is
essentially cut off
yes the
the
the rook will be attacking the bishop on
e1 which will mean that the rook on a
two will go to a1 so white's king and
white's rook will be stuck the bishop is
stuck then it will be knight versus king
the the the white knight will try to
escort his b pawn but black's king will
try to stop and that
might be drawn it's
remarkable uh that
was played rookie six on the board and
the engines don't like that one as much
because but it's a bit hidden to me why
not
they're almost like that's true they
really wanted to put a rook on f1 the
the sooner the better
is it possible that white could play
king f2 to e3 in case of some checks
king f2 rook h6 allows me very similar
type of ideas i'm also very good i'm
going to go g4 king
i'm gonna go king e3 and maybe i
maybe this way i'll get a a free rook
king to d2
bishop v1 yeah
why does favi have tricks it's amazing
he shouldn't have tricks and again it's
kind of that position where we had uh h3
takes g2 where hikaru again needs to sit
down and figure things out he's done it
once in this game already he maneuvered
himself into a completely winning
position
i think personally that this still
should be winning somehow right you have
a a pizza it's a piece
but you still you got to figure it out
one of the most amazing things i've ever
called in
the years i've been here in st louis it
was the world championship match in
london
um fabi was a piece up against magnus
just a whole piece up
and i said okay fabby's gonna win let's
go let's go
and there was some supercomputer in
norway that was giving
all zeroes
and it was the one of the one of the one
of the biggest shocks in my life that
you can be a whole piece up and the game
was even we have a comparison graph that
we'd like to share with you
nepo
in
in the 2020
i want to say 2020 candidates but it
actually was a year long
he stood
after eight rounds with a score of 5-0
uh today he's scored a 6-0 because that
round seven
where he lost to mvl
in a french
no no french winner were in this event
and he won that tournament a point clear
sorry a round clear yes a full round to
go and you're telling me he has an extra
point on that performance
not that not bad at all that is very
very impressive
the tournament was postponed after round
seven so round eight was his comeback it
was a bit more than a year
of wait time that we had between those
candidates and it seemed like everybody
was beating each other up favi came guns
blazing against mvl in that round eight
knocked him out
and nepo said oh thank you thank you
fabi
thank you for opening that pathway and
he took the tournament yeah i mean
somewhere
there's got to be a trivial pursuit uh
question there where it's sort of like
what was the longest tournament ever it
lasted more than a year
that uh candidates uh because of the
pandemic forces to break halfway through
a lot of people felt that the break was
beneficial
to nepo because nepo does have a
reputation of slip sliding in the second
half regardless
we do have king f2
which might have been
an indication why the first choice of
the engine to play rookie 5 and rook f5
and rook f1 might have been more
accurate real quick doesn't like this
move king it does not like king f2 no
uh take it away alejandro
it it's that variation that we were
looking at guys it's rook h6 i don't
think there's another logical move in
the position okay
let me just check it out with human eyes
not really i guess i could spook the
knight away with rook d6 but i feel i'm
just pushing it to a better square okay
like knight c7 to take my pawn right so
go rook h6 immediately start pretending
that there's some kind of checks
on this side of the board and how do we
make progress
uh
check is a question but that's not my
main thread rook h1 rook f1 is my main
threat exactly i do see that the
computer engine is suggesting
knight on d5 to e3 i don't know exactly
what my knight is going to why why i
want to put my knight on e3 you're not
even putting it on ether you're putting
it on g2
in order to defend the bishop okay fair
enough if i could go knight e3 and rook
a5
in one turn
uh that's okay with me because then my
my rook will be attacking the pawn on g5
i'm i'm there it looks weird it looks
very weird to me i'm just hopeful for us
at some point g4 g3 start pushing just
like it was females ago we were talking
about i was like ah i like that g-pawn
maybe he can push it he did
how far can it go how far can this it
goes pretty it goes pretty far let's go
down that variation right right well uh
rook h6
not played on the board yet here rook h1
knight g2
you can even go g4 immediately okay
let's just do it for me that's pretty
dangerous i mean you can't even take on
a6 you start going rook h3
oh i love this position right now it's
awkward
it's wonderful it's very awkward for
hikaru at the moment rook h6 is a big
move it's not on the board yet i'm still
having some trouble figuring out how
my brain hurts in that final position
where you played rook takes a6 i mean
uh i equal by the way
yeah
really confusing just just help me out
here i go uh rook a2
well i have a very pressing thread no
don't i have rook f3 and g3
whoa whoa whoa that's now black feels
like it's that's the pressing threat
yeah the minus two
yeah yeah yeah
you're pressing threat very good you
don't wanna do that no i don't
my goodness
and remember
they're tired oh gosh yes this is a long
tournament and they're just engaged on
which hour of play right now exactly
well we started our broadcast at eight
o'clock yeah
what time is it
two o'clock st louis time so five and a
half hours yeah five hours 40 minutes of
broadcast time
closing until six hours it's a five hour
40 minute game they're exhausted they're
tired they know that this is an
important game a lot is riding on this
for both players expect more mistakes
five is going down to ten minutes
remember he does have increment now
right but 10 minutes is not a lot i
don't care what position you have i
don't care how much increment you get 10
minutes is not a lot and that's for the
rest of the game there's no fourth time
control thankfully right and will he
find rook h6 will he play something else
i agree that if you give me rook a5 for
free yes that's an important template
it's an important tempo to attack the
spawn on g5 and not allow your rook to
penetrate so rook h6 is a big move in
this in this moment
and i also think it's the only logical
move in this moment i remember
everything alejandro was saying about
the length of this game the
energy that the players had put into the
game uh the tiredness factor and there
was this game that hikaru played with
timor
where it was such a difficult ending and
at the very end
hikaru had to calculate unbelievably
precisely
after six exhausting maybe even closer
to seven hours
of hard fight and he did
and i just thought my god this was a
superhuman effort i mean it was really
really extraordinary so we know that
these two players can calculate
i love it it's gonna we're gonna start
pushing the g clock right we got a game
guys yeah we got a game here
has to figure this out what wow uh the
game flare is a new uh
now there's a jeep on me there's a jeep
on in the mix there's
what happened to hikaru's beautiful
position exactly he had all of these i
think
he's five ninety-five was the fancy
syndrome
right
and his body language you know it from
hikaru we're being told that he is
bullying a hikaru he is upset at himself
he's mad because he knows he's a strong
player he knows that even if he's
winning he's slipped
this is slipping yeah he's going down
the wrong path right that he missed
something yeah because much more he
played king of two you know pretty
quickly
and he probably thought the same as you
yasser that he can go king through king
d uh king d2 right and of course it
looks like once you get your king to d2
we're all super happy exactly but what
about the g pawn the jeep yeah but you
think the g pawn is controlled by the
bishop right right
but then you realize that you don't have
to check this way
this is the stunning move right here
rookie six because i thought it was all
about rook hwan and i thought well
rookie six aren't you just driving me
back to a nice square and the trick is
that king d2 rook d6 and it just happens
that you've got this tactic of bishop b1
and bishop e4
you can't believe it it's like bad luck
right your rook happens to be on a2 like
what if bobby holds or well you know
wins this we should start calling him
the madrid magician
he does he does spend a lot of time in
madrid
not exactly madrid but he does have a
place in madrid where he stays between
tournaments right when he has this long
periods of time in which you might as
well stay in europe right you don't want
to go all the way back
jet lag and did it to death yeah he's
familiar with the city so do we have an
agreement if he does
he's a magician to save this
yes take a look and wow
um
i'm confounded because again it just
feels like this game
uh hikaru has won several times yeah
it's like he had the game he should have
just taken the h-pawn
then he had all of the pieces nicely
arranged on the fifth rank
it looks like he's about to claim and
immediately by the way king e3
immediately rookie six now the question
is do you go forward you could you start
risking a little bit that this uh this
configuration is not going to hold
anymore right i could return with rook
h6 rook h1 do you want to pin yourself
and allow this pawn to go down the board
uh not really sure that's what you want
to do i expecting to actually go king f2
and repeat once right but uh k2 would
immediately lose all of his advantage so
those are the only two options
and uh
again if from this moment onwards he
ikaro was to play perfectly or engine
approved move uh just take us through
how
hikaru should be playing this position
at this moment after king f2
no that's
still
it wants to play as some combination of
rook a193 it still wants to go knight e3
okay g4 oh no not g4 it was rook h1
first sorry the otherwise you just take
my pawn that's not very helpful thank
you very much here and we looked at g4
here i think we also looked at rook h3
first it doesn't really matter okay and
here you start to have to find some
stuff here's maybe the time to go king
e3 but then you have rook g1 and king f2
right okay if you will go king g3 yeah
you have some issues for example bishop
here no way really takes
bishop f3 and where do you want to put
if you put your rook on this
part of the board
check
rook h2 right
i just want to mention king
six was played on the board rook f2 king
e6 is incredibly awkward
you're just no way you paralyze yourself
chess is unfair sometimes it's unfair
and we have king f2 rook h6
so do you do you think it's just safe
for hikaru to realize that you know
things are getting a little ugly and
just repeat that is the most hopeful
question i have ever heard in my entire
life the mind is a piece up when he
blows it he still has a draw
i mean we saw some nice lines that you
know self pins and g pawn moves and you
know minus three and let me help a
little
right that was about to say you got napo
get out of here
no you're looking for the
okay glad we
glad we can agree on that one okay but
here's the point i mean for hikaru
it's it's
game or bust i'm sorry i think he just
has to play all out for the win he just
cannot afford there's no difference
between him losing a him drawing exactly
at this point and now
uh king f2 rook h6 on the board
expecting something like knight e3
uh to continue the game and
flair
you know i i i i keep hearing a report
that team nepo just cancelled an order
of
champagne
[Laughter]
it's a game guys it's still a piece and
i'm sure that he's going to try somehow
he has 40 minutes to figure it out and
here comes knight e3 here goes knight e3
it's on the board i expect rook h1 to
come quickly right uh i don't know if
you go rook f6 actually
rook f6 i guess i have to go rook f6
king g3 rook f1 would also be an option
the engine doesn't like that one as much
some of these resources are a little bit
hidden right knight g2 is forced exactly
because otherwise rook f1 comes but here
i would i i played g4
i thought rook h3 preparing g4
maybe looked a little bit nicer okay um
yeah how do you win this
he gets like except for example you take
right right g4 is already equal
already already equal rook f3 threat g3
follows can't stop it so if you don't
take the pawn
what do you do
repeat
uh king ji won't make any g1 go g4 same
idea
you might be able to win this eventually
but you have to find some awkward what
is this
yeah it's a string a strange thing my
pieces are are
really uh
poor they're not
they're not doing enough uh rook a5 i
don't like rookie rook takes a6 g3 but
if i could play rook a5 to g5
i feel like okay i'm back in i'm i'm
back in business
rook g5 uh alejandro
i think
don't tell me bishop e4 whoa this is
just no
it's like almost not fair to hikaru's
position exactly it's almost not fair to
hikaru that this is this can happen
right right those pawns are just so
strong and they're shockingly strong
because they're split yeah exactly the
moment grandmasters see split pawns you
think
there has to be a way right there must
be a way this is a weak they're weak i
must be able to even pick them up
but no such thing the pawns are
incredibly well defended
and they're causing trouble
rookie 93 rook f6 check played now this
allows white a couple of uh ideas
because now the king can go to g3
blocking the pawn
that's significant that is significant
that being said
how do you win this like okay say i go
back
what
get out of here no no you can't be this
this is so unfair bishop f2 okay that
position where you go back
i think you eventually win it but it's
still not that easy can i put the knight
on e1 in that case like my bishop on e1
is kind of terrible but my knight on e1
is all knights are great block haters
i agree with what you're saying but let
me bring my king to the queen side it's
your the only chance to win is going to
be to win the spawn on a6 okay so knight
e1 let's just say i get
it and rook a5 yay
you get everything that you want i want
to take the pawn is what i want i
probably have to give it to you at some
point i can yes it can survive a little
bit longer with g4 but it won't survive
for very long okay i think this
eventually you will finagle to a win
but
it'll take some time
right rook to g5 and a finagle a win and
this is the current position
on the board the engine wants to play
this kind of esoteric rook h1 with the
idea of bishop f5 and try to get this
king out of the way
push that pawn on the g file so it's
still not trivial by any means a nice i
said explain mistakes from both players
because they're so low on time well
especially favi in in this precise
position with the rook on f1
can i get that configuration that i'd
like bishop to f2 and knight to e1
alejandro well it's blocked to move
other than the fact that
i mean uh other than the fact that it is
black to move uh bishop f2 and knight on
e1 would be a very desirable
remaneuvering of the two minor pieces i
feel that the
that the knight
would be a much
better blockader than the bishop
um
this position feels very
key critical
let's say black was rick one
yes
would you still want to go bishop f2 or
would you still would you consider rook
takes pawn
such a question of course i would
consider rook takes it
pawn anytime i but
uh i'm thinking that the bishop on e4
i've got rook takes so the moment i go
away i've got to make sure that bishop
e4 i've got a a good response for so
against rook h1 maybe i would first
try to do this
you know nice little remaneuver or a
shuffling of the pieces bishop to f2 and
knight e1
um i i'm feeling alejandro that we're
going to know in the next five moves
whether this game is going to be a draw
or a win for ikaro okay
that uh
that's it that's
that he'll have made the progress he
needs to make or final take yeah yeah
yeah or he or the pawn will be on g4 and
a miracle of miracles is going to be a
draw here but he's getting the better
version right he got his king to g3 the
king is not on g1 that's a better
version that's a much better version and
the fact that favi didn't go for this
version with the king on g1 instead when
czech and rook f1 is that he's not
finding this accurate moves that perhaps
would have given hikaru a bigger run for
his money at the moment i think that
keeping the rook on the first rank makes
a lot of sense
i
don't really want to play the move rook
f6 in the position that we're that we
currently have
with the
okay yes knight is on g2 you mean just
dropping back with the rook no yeah
although
uh it's funny i'm trying to find a move
for black because i wanted to play
something like king e8 okay but the
problem is that after you take on a6 i
don't have bishop b4 not in this case
not in check i've given you a check so
perhaps can i play king e7
it's the same type of oh that's pretty
nice if i cross to the e file you have
this
also the same and you pick up with check
which means that you don't have time to
take on g2 so perhaps that's why the
engine wants to play rook h1 it just
needs to pass
and in the case of rook to h1 can we
make that reshuffling of the minor
pieces bishop f2 you shall i'll thread
in checkmate just in case you forget how
uh
right and we gotta calculate king f3
chuck
king takes rook takes c3 is messy a
little yeah you gotta say it bishop to
g3 therefore chuck
good grief not again
and again you'll take i'll take
it's a win
but not the totally clean one it's not a
total clean one now that is with the
move rook h1 there's no other move i
think if you play rook f6 and you
destroy your own configuration right and
you go passively then yes white
eventually gets out of a bishop f2
knight e1 and starts harassing your
bishop brings the king in you run out of
resources rook h1 is an important move
in this position moving the king to the
g file i think just makes your position
worse so
rook h1 is the move that still
potentially causes trouble in this it's
a little bit of a hidden move because
you don't really want to allow
king f2 in many cases
so i can see why rook h1 in some ways is
illogical right but it is the engine
move okay and dorsa the players are on
their third time control yes
they've gotten their 15 minutes that's
it that's over they get their 30 seconds
but what are the times for the players
now that they're on move 68 four four
minutes for phobia only he will never
get any more time
except
five minutes and 20
seconds on this move
i'm telling it's a critical moment uh
and for ikaru how much time from
38 minutes
so he's got plenty of time he's got
plenty of uh
fabi is the one who's suffering at the
moment and he's playing rook to f6 yeah
it might make life higher life easier
dropping back with the rook he didn't go
for that move rook h1 that you
prescribed alejandro and you even went
so far i think to say it was necessary
yeah it's still a fight but it seems
that eventually
white gets out of this after bishop f2
knight e1 he gets the nice coordination
and by the way with the bishop on f2 the
knight e1 the king on g3 there's no
disturbance in the force exactly you
know and he played it very quickly for
bobby fortress i think he i think he's
in he's grooving again he's back he's
back in he knows that something at some
point went wrong right but he sees this
knight only one controlling the position
and he feels that somehow the moose will
come easily because he's up a piece
and now he's
and now he's back to that uh
got this got this before he was scowling
and so forth and so on but yeah we can
see that the knight coming to e1 the
rook going to a1 then
then
with with the pawn absolutely positively
corralled then you can go ahead and do
knight f3 and everything is is going
your your way
what a fight
wow
it was a beautiful game i mean it's
still going on there's still
time to king g6 on the board we now are
expecting knight e1 they're logical yeah
get getting that going
and uh as much as we do love this game
and where
it has been a magnet for us we have to
mention that still there's another game
going on that's the uh my country man
yes uh
somehow the pawn went to f3 and i
as far as i can tell that's the only
difference
yeah
yeah
i mean
this is one of those
literally nothing happened right
the players are also playing for the
increment uh alejandro two minutes for
teemo rajabov and 16 minutes for ali
reza ferruccio so timor is the one that
well
if he makes he's it's almost 60 he makes
the move he gives the the the extra time
the extra 15 minutes never mind
f2 f3 uh that is a pardon me queen e2
white that is white's sixth either move
we're waiting for
timor no we're not we're waiting for
hikaru
knight h5 and now the players will get
their 15 minutes they'll get their 30
second increments
and
uh well away you go
we'll be back in like another half hour
we'll see we'll see if the palm makes it
to g4 by the time we get back and the
rook is on a5 nicely done
that means that the rook is now ready to
uh centralize get behind the pawn
where it will be active hitting pawns on
g4 g5 e2
and then we can
maneuver our knight to f3
um
give me your winning percentage
at this exact moment
i'm confident on whites now because like
five months ago
i could still push the g pawn when my g
plan isn't stuck fully blockaded yeah
unfortunately for for fobby i don't
really see this
going anywhere but
you're a fair weather friend get out of
here
i mean you would know you're here to
tell it the way you see it you got it i
mean so you think it's
yeah you think it's now it's almost a
certainty yeah
unless there's a blunder but like the to
the best of my
the foreseeable
future is impossible to push any of the
pawns but i feel like we're back again
in you know the 30 moves ago when the
position was like good but stuck we're
there again the position is good the
pawns are good the bishop is wonderful
the rook was fine but it's just stuck
again so it means now the white can just
travel pieces start attacking the little
pawns and exactly i mean uh we've just
seen the move rook f6 to e6 by fabi
stopping the move rook d5 but i hear you
wholeheartedly dorset i'm thinking
like you are the king on g3 is
wonderfully placed you're not disturbing
it
which means that the pawn on g5 goes
nowhere the pawn on e2 is well blockaded
you've got ideas of knight f3 and it
feels
like this is close to 100 yeah alejandro
uh
as the engine's bar gone through the
roof as the way we feel it
not
quite
yet yasser we're still waiting on some
but we have moves quickly yes we have
moves quickly we have the move 91 bishop
f5 now played
and we are expecting knight f3 we expect
knight f3 and that's a good move
yep yep it's climbing and climbing and
climbing it's up to plus four now okay
that's what i thought it was going to
happen that uh the the engine would
start to really realize that white has
made great progress great strides
i have to say it again i mean what a
what a game uh this is when coming into
today's round we thought that this game
was going to be our marquee matchup like
it's a titanic struggle so often we're
disappointed right you know like these
two great gladiators made a draw
they're all american matches yeah the
grand master draw but no this has lived
up to its billing and then some i uh
kudos to both players it's really been
uh in my estimation a great game fun to
call quite bloody i would say
right so like seriously i agree you
mentioned there like multiple acts it
was first act was uh
the preparation yeah the d4 square when
the d4 square was cut it was just like
okay white is comfortable now black is
struggling exactly and then the second
axe was just improving that and then the
third act was the the downhill that we
just saw and now it's the final i i i
can't think of
any other magical pawns that's
phobican push no they were
no
uh actually now you you start to see the
petite combination
uh rook takes f5 and knight d4 check and
that's going to be a very easy game to
win because this pawn on d
pardon me the pawn on c3 is going to be
defended by a bishop on d4 he stepped
out of that
threat with the move
uh rook
to d6 i think we're up to date with the
players yes we are of course we are that
makes sense
now how do you feel about rook to e5 for
white i love that i'm just thinking
always what is my opponent up to well i
can see my opponent wants to play rook
to d3
once the rook gets to d3 then i get
worried about the move g4 so
i start to think should i be playing
knight to e4
i love the idea of rook to e5 full stop
end of story but should i just stop and
prevent my opponent from this rook to d3
if i play knight to d4
i'm pretty sure rook takes is a no yeah
i'll take with the pawn and i'll put my
rook on c5
in the meantime this bishop is hanging
if your bishop goes back now well same
position and you've got exactly what you
want the ego is now
edible yep
yes exactly so i think knight d4 and
that is on the board just to stop
rook to d3 play quickly
by hikaru and ikaru by the way
he's
he his play
has really accelerated uh in the last
few turns here right and we have bishop
d3 rookie five on the board as well yeah
once again dare i say dorsa oh bye bye
paul these guys are good
uh knight takes e2 as you're mentioning
uh gift meet upon
uh knight takes e2 bishop takes e2 rook
takes e2 rook to d3 check i do have rook
to e3
um
also
if it was my turn truth be told i'd
probably be more inclined towards knight
f3
no pawn eating
yes i'm i'm pawn eating oh the other
pawn yeah upon eating that one first
and it all looks very very good and the
in the other game did the players make
their third time control yes yes they
did
and good
good going
what changed
not much
not much
back to
and here we have king f6
that was the last
f3 would also be very
nice
i like knight f3
suddenly even the idea of bishop d4
setting up for a nasty
discover check
um
i find very attractive
i mean now it's all it's it's too late
it feels like it's it's gone uh
completely now knight f3
um
easy
uh alejandro uh
wow what a shake-up of the tournament
standings nepo uh
reordering the champagne
i think so i think this one looks close
to boston knight f3 on the board guys g5
is about to fall bishop d4 on tap it is
falling apart finally for fabiano
caruana hikara will win this game quite
the struggle indeed it was a titanic
struggle it felt like fabi was twice
on the verge of making it back but not
quite there right in both cases
tie the anchor said
you know what the ship is staying afloat
we're not going down we're going to
continue to where we were promised the
full point and i think he's finally done
it hikaru about to win nepo
perhaps the even bigger winner of this
game wow and uh remembering their first
game that they played earlier in the
first half
hikaru was that person just give me a
tempo just give me time i'm not almost
making a draw almost making a draw and
fabby uh
grind out the win
let me show you again that stat of the
head-to-head match-up because for those
of you who don't understand we're
witnessing two great gladiators and
again this stat that you're about to see
includes the win that happened in the
first half 33 draws and i want to say it
was eight to six i believe so as well
where's my style
it was the head-to-head uh between fabi
and nakamura how did these guys do
against one another i believe you were
right i remember the same stat as well
33 draws eight to six
this is what we had teed up at the top
of the show
uh alejandro these guys know one another
kind of
[Laughter]
it is over and suddenly it's seven wins
to eight
and
what
shake-up that has done and i wish i
could but thankfully for the show guys
let's not forget
we still have one game remaining yes
yes yeah we do so don't go anywhere
after this we're going to throw
alejandro in the pool you see that's why
he likes that thank you yeah that's why
we got a pool
uh
alejandro uh one other thing to note uh
you're right we do have a game going on
of course uh tomorrow is the day of
destiny as fabi will be playing nepo but
of course in that game he'll come into
the game trailing by a whole point must
win must win must win he'll be white too
he will be white must win there's
nothing else
this is what it's looking like uh dorsa
for tomorrow
fear is your rapport
right job of naka
karwana nepo that's the one you know i
actually like that to shorten these
names oh yeah yeah
but yes it's more correct to say ding
lehren uh we shouldn't be shorting
shortening his name
the chinese etiquette i know this
because of alejandro
oh wow alejandro's in the no i mean
this guy doesn't just know chess
coaching
he's a man of great culture
first time i hear that
all right uh well we and then there was
one alejandro
anybody got chances chances we'll take a
look at the standings well we'll take a
look at the
surging four and a half points for him
but that still means he's a point and a
half away from nepaliachi fabiano caron
is the one that gets dragged back and of
course we have this incredibly relevant
game between the people that are
currently tied for seventh
still going on in their sixth hour of
play kudos to their fighting spirit
right but my god uh not much going on in
this game they've been shuffling around
the pieces
for a for a really long time
yeah all right well after this
incredible game that we just witnessed
and again a big congratulations to
hikaru i mean winning
such a difficult game we're going to
take a break yes recharge recalibrate
what's happening over here we'll discuss
the game in private
discuss the new game in private exactly
and we're going to see you on the other
side of this break when we return
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
can you hear it
[Music]
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
[Music]
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates we
are in round eight the second half of
the tournament has started with a bang
as we have so far
two wins out of three games and my
goodness what games jan and ding lehren
made it early draw get them out of the
way but it was the game that between
fabi and hikaru
that was
incredible is a titanic duel
hikaru seemed to have won this game
three times as he is now a half a point
behind fabi and then of course
richard
richard rapport finally he wins a game
he gets the best of duda with one game
remaining and that is between um perugia
and timor as the players
are oh my gosh what did they move that
move number are they on it they just
plowed the 69th move played for white
black
three
in truth not much has been happening for
quite a long while not much not much
let me show you how much not much
happen show us show us this is
guys this is
42. okay
look at the structure
yeah ferruja 50 minutes
this isn't adding the 15 that he got
right
timor 57 okay
this is the current
position oh my god pawn went to f3 paul
went to f3 we traded a pair of rooks and
that's it no other changes except
ferruccia spent all that hour yes and
burned nine minutes of his extra 15 okay
and timur burned
all of that hour
and 11 minutes
of those 15.
but these moves were extraordinarily
difficult
[Laughter]
depth and understanding dorsa you came
and congratulations you brought with you
the longest broadcast
so a baptism by fire it's great of you
to hang in there with us you know i'd
rather think about it as the most
exciting day because there was two wins
you know thus far it could be the three
we we had such a
third one
the the favi naka game i was just it was
really beautiful to watch
so it was just really
tough on that roller coaster
i got my cardio for the day watching
that
feel like your heart rate went up a
little bit there
okay uh let's break down the position
why is it so hard
for either player to make progress as i
see it
this pawn structure on the king side
this four pawn structure
h4 g3 f3
e4 is lending it to white
that he's got ideas potentially of g4 g5
that's one way of
trying to put his
pawn majority in motion the other much
more direct way is to play for f4 of
course i understand
and from black's point of view black
only has the move d4 wait a second
come at a good moment because ferrous is
changing the character of the position
with the last move he just played move
94 inviting teamwork
to take on g4 this of course shatters
this beautiful boat like pawn structure
that we have on the king side
but it does give me access to the f file
because he will lose a tempo or to the a
file and the queen here will take care
of the king side something that wasn't
able to be done just with the queen
earlier
and this rook is going to go a1 a5 take
this pawn or force c6 go to a6 and start
pressuring stuff difficult for this rook
to get back in the game actually the
engines think that this part this
particular move king h3 uh
wait a second
why didn't he take
g4
check
king g3 okay go somewhere
ah and this queen is trapped no it's
like a half g6
so it was just a
healthy
pawn question mark what it's the sixth
hour of play what are you telling me
knight takes e4 was on and he played
king h8 yes
no
well
yeah it's actually not that hard right
g4 checked you can't go to h2 because i
pluck your pawn you can't go to you can
go to g2 and i cannot plug your pawn
because rook h1 but it doesn't matter
which way you go as long as you're on
the g file i can move my knight pin your
pawn
right and then uh move my queen to g6
i mean i still don't think black is
gonna be that more
that much more i mean you could take on
b5 and recover your material balance but
there's e4 looming now i agree it's
central pawn i agree
i feel the big one good we gotta take it
you gotta take it free fun
a fun oh my gosh he played king h8
rather quickly i didn't even i let that
moment uh pass
uh completely by alejandro um
i mean double cases of double blindness
are so common i mean they're they're
chess
they're just
they're going around in circles right
and it feels like they're go they're
making each other loopy
this is what it feels like at this
moment that they're going around and
around around in circles right and
they're going crazy and i have the
feeling that it's hour six
plus change right and they're they're
not calculating accurately anymore yeah
the game has simplified a little bit
we've traded the knights can't take on
b5 because f3 is hanging you might want
to defend that guy don't defend it like
this because this hangs that pawn
so i guess you're defending like rook f1
but then i will continue with queen g6
harass this pawn and at some point
you're gonna have to make a decision do
you agree to the draw because i cannot
defend my king side or you bite the
bullet and go g4
kind of ugly to leave f4 undefended but
on the other hand if you do go and move
c6 in this particular moment after c4
again reinforcing the threat on the b5
pawn and you take and you take you start
having a lot of weaknesses in this
complex
over here uh d5 doesn't help you very
much you have to defend c6 keep e6
defended and this fortunately for white
kind of defends itself
so this is the moment he's actually
played the move rook a1 doesn't come
with a direct threat because queen takes
b5 queen takes f3 is still an issue
yeah and rook a5 i can meet with c6 so
they're also an incredible time pressure
right three minutes four minutes
three minutes thirty fourteen or they do
have the increment
but
it's tough to play right now exactly
queen g6 on the board
i'm anticipating that ali reza's idea is
that he wants to
you know let his rook roam free
and his idea is to play queen f2 and
just keep his pawns how do you start
pawn to g4 because i was very
uncomfortable playing pawn to g4 as long
as there was a knight that could jump
jump to f4 but since there's no more the
good boys to join there
exactly exactly um
yeah well
i'm okay with the pawn moving to g4 i'm
just gonna say
that now you've put this backward pawn
on the f3 square um
i'm going to try to attack it as b as as
much as i can i'll play the move rook f7
intending to move queen f6 and then
you know you can't really put your king
on g3 i'll check you on f4 um
it feels like the move g4 is
going to be was it played oh yes doesn't
it yet wow
no that's my analysis oh you're right it
came there was a a
relay delay there so g4 okay so after
rook f7 the
the backward pawn on f3 is going to get
immediately hit i think the threat is
queen f6 and we could be making a
repetition
uh rather
quickly i want to say
hope to say
that it was that was your trick all
along
you're thinking how do i get out of here
make a draw
right
very nice very nice
so
a very very long game but in some ways
neither player really landing a blow
alejandro i mean no the engines do like
white
they do they do like white they think
that the weaknesses on the queen side
are more relevant and the weaknesses on
the king side again can you hold the
king's side together without needing
your queen that's the key of the
position that's what i'm trying to start
i see a line and i'm like i'm gonna
forget it let's take rook f7 king g2
queen f6 okay
like
is that a terrible idea to let that
queen actually come to h4 again
no i mean a bit are you going to
what are you going to take for the h
pawnee you you you want to go
grab the b5 like you want to make a move
uh i was considering ponto h5 oh
well that's much better you're not
sacrificing the goal i don't want to
give up any points very good
let me worry though you know i've been
training with alejandra for a number of
years and getting those concepts down no
no no free pawns yeah i feel like i feel
like he's a work in progress but his
progress has been remarkable
you know
he wakes up sometimes at night and you
think yeah to protect my pond
then he wants to kill me
i mean just coaches have nightmares too
and on another note uh how about nepo's
road ahead uh alejandra what's uh what's
he's facing i think we know what he's
facing tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow is a
big one guys monday
it'll be a faithful one for this event
can fabi make this a tournament
or will nepo just run away with it
because take a look what comes out for
nepal after where nepal will be white
against timor rajava
black against firuja who's also not
playing amazing
both players currently in the cellar
they are actually the two players that
are at the bottom of the table so it's
this round nine
it's this round nine guys where we
define the tournament yeah it's uh it's
destiny that's it that's it
wow and we're i mean if
tomorrow's game lives up to the game
that bobby played today
with hikaru i will be ecstatic like
today i thought the game that hikaru won
really should go down properly speaking
as a titanic strike
fight between two players who really
really really want to play for the world
championship and it it befit
this event and uh
power to them both obviously not the
result
that fabby wanted
certainly the result nepo wanted
but
uh power to to um
um
hikaru for overcoming the resistance of
his opponent and boy
there was some great resistance there
too why
in this position after h5
does the chest they're playing quickly
guys
yeah white what's going on why is it
there has been a few moves
okay do you need to update your board i
will i'll do it right away talking about
uh pushing those king sides but i guess
blacks just didn't
provoke us enough
queen dropped back to
uh
f7 and then we saw queen to e3
gift meet the pawn on that would be
wonderful that would be wonderful king
h7 defending the pawn
rook a5
queen
slid
to d7 to defend on b5 and now
it does feel like after the move queen
d3 that finally
the move c6 will be provoked and
maybe these pawns are weak
i don't know
what
how to continue it has to be based on
the move c3 c4 right well the one thing
that i'm trying to decide on is
when do we want to play h5 as white is
that something we actually want to try
or is h5
far-fetched you know it's one of those
things
that it's better postponed because it's
something we can always do
i mean it might be
it's crazily enough that one day we
would want to play g5 we don't know but
once we played h5
there's no turning back we've done it
that's it that's
nothing to be said so keeping that
flexibility i'm thinking more like we're
going to have to play c4
rook a6 we're going to have to force
something
in black's position to
crack we we need a big big target
is
does
does ali reza have such ideas as rook
a64 alejandro
well the engine doesn't think that c6 is
as necessary as you guys think and i
haven't really figured out why
the engine just wants to go back it the
engine says c6 terrible move decisive
advantage white
what i just wanted to play queen f7
what do you take with uh well i can't
take with the queen so
rick takes and he wants to do this h5
g5 queen f4
rook f7 coming
not in time
to defend f3
wow
um is that
completely clear uh say rook b7 sure
rook b7 uh i can start with rook f7
right i will see one is an issue but
there's no issues with rook f7 it's good
because if i go c4 and i invite you to
capture on f3 this one i won't capture
if i capture it's better for white and
probably winning i would guess the gun
game the problem is that you go here and
i start harassing you this way when h1
rook at four actually wins so wow you
need to be very careful at this point
yeah not to allow that so black could
try to go h5 to stop rh5 then there you
go dorsa wants uh
to get in h4 h5 for white
so she doesn't have to deal with your h6
h5 does that help white's cause
uh at the moment yes uh h5 either now or
the next move is is what the engine is
recommending that white does want to
play this just to prevent black from
playing h5 and it's the access to the
pawn on h4 mainly that the engines want
to get rid of gotcha so in the game c6
thank you
c6 was played
c6 we were thinking about you know it's
risky to give that pun up so i'm glad
that
and h5 the idea is to stop black from
playing h 6h5 puts the queen
um next to the pawn on h4 so h5 just
cuts that out and then you
blurted the engine just loves
that you provoked the move c7 c6 and
considers white advantage to be great
why
alejandro
well
ah because your work's on the open file
there you go
[Laughter]
that was that yeah that's why
[Laughter]
wow uh
website you can contact me on chats.com
i get lessons right exactly
i mean it's just easier to play for
white there's no direct win
it's annoying to play for black though
can't move to work because rookie 7
actually wins don't want to push your
pawns because you just make more
weaknesses
in this
point in particular because i already
covered oh yes f4 yeah i can go g5 and
cover this way with king g3 you're not
going to be able to get that in how do
you win you start harassing this stuff
on the queen side as you said at some
point you do go rk6 or you defend this
with rook f1 and go queen b6 okay
is it easy nope it's still very close to
a fortress
for black the thing is that now instead
of both sides having weaknesses to
attack the way that we had a few uh
moves ago where black was uh oscillating
between attacking f3 and g3 right here
it's just playing on one goal and one
minute left for uh timor jabo as well
yeah 230 for uh alireza's not a lot of
time remember there is increment it has
kicked in so it's not that any side will
flag
but it's difficult to find the moves
yeah and the players will soon be
relying
completely on that 30-second increment
very hard
to
gain time
when the players are down to their 32nd
are they required to keep a score
at that point
on their score sheet alejandro do you
know sorry
with increment you you got it so it
takes you a few seconds just to write
down your moves so that 30 seconds isn't
all
one thing i've noticed is i don't know
about you know super high level
tournaments but whenever my opponents
were in time trouble on you know normal
23 to 2500 they were just like right
like a like a squirrel yeah just it's
like
i don't think there's a more unenforced
rule in chess
that notation
by definition and by the rules of chess
has to be legible
right i
do have you even seen a legible
scoresheet not where pal benko and
victor corsnoy were concerned
i mean ulf anderson john nunn had these
really nice score sheets you're like can
i borrow your scoresheet
it could read them other players less so
and uh we then now the players uh how
much faster yeah well they're down on
the clock one minute
for t more two minutes two and a half
for farrugia and now
we're going to be seeing kind of a bit
their blitz skills i still think that h5
like two moves back was still
interesting i don't know if h5 is that
good anymore but i i sorry for white yes
um
he's got the moment yeah no dorsa he's
not making a lot of progress that was
putting a rook on d1 yeah that's rock
felt much nicer on a1 and the queen i
mean i think queen on ether is okay
because it's uh protecting the a7 square
and might have some queen b6 ideas later
but your koi not knee three with the
king gone g3 your queen is just there
it's not good
[Applause]
it's not gonna really go anywhere so i
don't really know
how i i don't i'm having a hard time
thinking how would this position
actually improve for either side yeah
the engine thinks that we're putting the
rook on d1 destroyed all white's
advantage and it's now 0.2
really yeah well well i mean it seems to
me like if you if uh
if ali reza did play the move h5 it
wouldn't surprise me at all if later his
rook ended up on a1 and a6
like i don't think the players are
completely aware
that the move rook d1 tossed away much
of white that's fair advantage although
i think black is trying to d5 it with
the you know because there's d7 so i'm
not
i'm not comfortable
um moving the rook away even though d5
is coming up so you think for example h5
you think that uh
well that would be a very very big
decision d6 d5 maybe it's a good move
i'm just saying it totally changes the
uh the pawn structure yes in that uh the
e5 pawn
might be tender
i could take and play rookie one maybe
i'm just undoubling your pawns and not
achieving anything
i don't know alejandro is d6 d5 a blow
for freedom and goodness or
it's a nice move because in some ways it
tethers white's position a bit
but you're not running d4 and you're not
threading d4
so it's just
it's just kind of there
okay
it's a good move it's a good move all
right well he's being invited to play it
if he oh and he did
rush d2 d5 was played on the board
okay the
the game is definitely
uh getting spicy
on the boil as the brits would say
no h4h5 both players have resisted
uh touching their h pawns and now comes
d
six d5
were you saying that d5 d4 is not a
threat alejandro
no why not
why don't you like the expansion
uh i think it's because you can take and
if you take back i think i can throw in
e5
uh
something like this this this e5
[Music]
wow
the pontian game is dead lost right
with the king on g3 i'm not so i mean
i put the king on the king was trying to
sidestep some i don't know okay i put
the king on g3 but okay so you're saying
let's put the king no i can't put the
king on g2 what should i do all right
whatever
yeah right two three okay uh and
you've got this nice little tickle here
e5 and this is what you were saying that
this pawn and
oop excuse me rook takes ch check
this pawn and game is dead lost yeah you
just go f4 right and the king just comes
waltzing
over
i agree with that that looks pretty
clear
so no threat of d4 sorry
p2 yeah white did play rookie two
instead of t3 which
i'm not thinking well d4 could work in
this situation
because if well after rookie two d4 he
wants it to
take the pawn so d4 could work in this
situation sorry go ahead no no uh and i
was just thinking because we don't
really have that beautiful e5 with the
threat of picking up the pawn anymore
exactly although if we take they take e5
it could still be quite interesting
hmm
i'm looking at a bailout variation with
queen takes h4 king takes h4 takes
uh
whoa uh the
game
it's extraordinary that the game gets so
interesting at a moment when neither
player has much time on their clocks how
does that happen
six five four
three
two
well we know there's a little bit of a
delay so we do have a move let's move
through cafe seven
uh
maybe two seconds on the clock wow don't
worry you can you can start another
countdown alice is 25 seconds very very
soon wow that was uh
a little bit scary wasn't it i mean
somebody's heart must have been racing
by the time he pressed the clock
how much time how much how many so
we made it with eight seconds to delhi
wrestle king g2
okay
whoa these players are every drop
maximizing uh
their clocks and king g2 inviting
h4
uh
h5
crazy ideas
can i take the pawn and go for h5 i
don't know
but king g8 was played king g8 okay
so
if if we take twice we're hanging the f3
pawn with check and that's no me gusta i
don't like giving up
that f3 pawn which i think is kind of
like oops excuse me
uh and the game punish five was played
i'm sorry king g2 is also an interesting
no i i am h5 on the board yes okay
very good
i'm going to just refresh my board for a
moment so how fast they're playing it
might be hard to
look in any other lines exactly um yeah
it's basically a slow blitz game right
right
uh i still don't see anything that's
really impactful here of can black just
sit aleandro play
i don't know move like king no king g7
allows queen takes e5
no
really okay that's just egregious you
can't let your clock tick down to two
seconds your coaches are gonna be
hospitalized
that is just
terrible terrible form
two seconds 32 seconds you can see
that timor did let his clock take down
to that
moment the rook on e2 doesn't seem to be
doing much
in my opinion because
oh well i was going to say you're not
you're never really going to be well
taking
on d5 but
cheap tricks always work cheap tricks
huh
is that what i taught you
i remember that i don't remember that
lesson we uh in in seattle we called
them cheapos oh cheapos cheap tricks
cheapos coach that was a you know that
was i think a team lesson i think that
was one of the first team lessons i had
that slew
he was just teaching
cheap tricks winning games
ollie hunter you got a whole lecture
about now that's probably his best
lecture i bet you they're national
champions for a reason
cheap tricks by ali master ramirez uh
sign up for our course you were saying
you didn't like the rook on e2 how you
like the rook on e3
now with the rook on e3 you get the
queen behind and then maybe you can uh
we do but without the queen on e3
there's rook a7 for black as well so
that that you know that kind of gives
that away okay you give up the file but
hold on
can i if if i'm
getting into the mind of uh ali reza i
think he wants to play
queen e2 and
provoke d4 all right you've provoked me
i know what but did i did i do good
coach or did i do bad
takes takes e5 well
queen
feels a little dangerous for why not
do i
i could easily have blown it uh queen d8
queen hey two and guess
lookie lookie who's got the a file
we had a fort blade instead which means
f4 i i think he's actually going for
king f6 well he might not
no he sorry i'm going to refresh my
border once again
but i'm wondering what he plays against
queenie too i assume that's fellow
russell's idea hold on uh my spidey
sense is tank tickling here couldn't i
have taken a gun queen g6 check no
no
next question
i mean legally yes
i mean he gets played the big bucks for
these insightful pithy
you get to play edcd queen g6 but i go
king f8 and yeah i'm coming back i guess
you just have to come back right right
maybe that's why rookie two was played
so rookie two was played instead
okay
well he could go back with the queen
king
whoa whoa whoa once again i'm invited to
go to the g6 square is he going to h4
i'm so tempted i would love to see that
i would pay to say this king
boy you guys wow
wow too much uh you know if the king
gets to age four i'll be happy to say
another hour
speak for yourself
[Laughter]
oh there's a strike being organized over
there at the production truck that's
right they're like
we invited into our midst the king on h4
we had like two different kings in the
middle of the board in two different
games if you can get a king to h4
that'll be another
personal record for me i was about to
say you're optimistic if you think
you're ever gonna get a queen g3 check
on me but okay the queen has dropped
back to d1
and alejandro
the players are playing quickly because
they have to yeah are they playing
accurately yeah it's been 0-0 for the
last
logo
king g5 i mean i can hardly believe my
eyes i mean it almost feels like a a
suicide mark
yeah well the rest only has one move not
to lose what yeah
are you kidding me nope one move not to
lose well probably not hard to find
because black has a pretty pertinent
threat queen takes f3 check
and you want to be able to meet king
with some kind of check so i assume you
want to play rookie one good job and it
was played
very good very good he's found his only
move
wow
you kept liking h4 if you felt like it
there's nothing right because check just
drives you back i get that
but that is funny i mean again
i just want to see it for the aesthetics
it's not about the chest at this point
for me i just want to see that king is
for thank you threatening queens
[Laughter]
is happy to stay here for another hour
alejandro i would like to go swimming
we're going to leave dorsa
oh
bring it home for us bring out the
brother i saw the king of shore that i
wanted and uh please repeat uh right you
were i'm assuming the rook is going to
come back and then i believe
the players will be very happy to make a
repetition professional repetition
alejandro the most professional
excellent very good 90 plus moves i i'll
take that
90 plus your longest game uh seven hours
40 minutes
and how many moves about 100 less than
120.
more than a century
it was it was very
weird for me because it was like i had
extra pawn it's a queen end game
i just i knew i messed up somewhere i
know if i win i have bronze of the world
youth championship i'm the last game of
the whole tournament to finish and
they're literally like picking up the
tables and the boards and setting the
clothes and sewing
and i couldn't win it it just ended in a
draw and i'm still very sore about it i
can feel that that intensity that lack
of
winning the gold medal probably uh
you were in the slump after that
pretty much yeah
okay
rip the e1
yes that's the professional repetition
that we're expecting i know those
junior championships those youth
championships can be so emotional on the
players that they're really really uh
impactful a lot of the american coaches
of the friedman i mean
spends a lot of time commissary
another king h4
this is it we're going to see rookie one
check because this one is forced exactly
queen g3 is a killer
uh blow as alejandro says you have only
one move not to lose
and uh i'm told by tom that you're
welcome to stay because we're going to
have
an extensive interview
extensive interviews with the players
not true by the way not true
do not hang around waiting for any
interviews we are pushed out of here
fast we have a lot of houses in the pool
yes
yes
we have certain traditions here in saint
louis you know that must be upheld of
course yeah
oh what is this play the king h4 yes
it's wait actually this is threefold
right yeah i think it is because king g5
or k1 was it's that's that's it that's
it legally this is a draw unless they
you could indicate to the drive they
claim it right yeah
because when the rookie one was played
that's the third time that his play and
in that case you don't play the move
right yes
and this one is the show here it has
finally ended in a draw at the
reservation a marathon game against
timothy let me give you my final
thoughts of the day so we don't have to
come back to this
amazing
round guys it was all about that favi
game against hikaru yep great result for
nepo great result for hikaru the
tournament for second place
is on fire but nepo is just sitting
pretty saying i have an important task i
need to survive tomorrow and then the
path to the world championship match is
clear ahead in front of me it's going to
come down to it that's our current
standings after eight rounds of chess in
madrid four point advantage for yamuna
pognachi fabiano caron is still the one
trailing but the lead has extended and
hikaru nakamura is rearing his head
saying guys don't forget about me
second place might be important and you
know what maybe i can string some wins
together and spoil your party he'll be
playing against jan with the black
pieces in this round between the in this
half of the tournament because he wasn't
able to convert with white against this
player
date with destiny tomorrow you don't
want to miss it as fabio will be taking
on the number one uh player in the
tournament nepo uh
we think for all the marbles
thank you so much for sharing your day
with us we know it's been a long day
dorsa i thought you were thank you thank
you for having me no on the contrary you
gotta come back now
now you're in now you're in with us
thank you for reinforcing
us and thank you everybody
good night everybody and we'll see you
all tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you